les conseillers du chef de la gestion
épidémique de au début par de 30 de
l'épidémie de kovy deux états unis
antonio fauci il nous a accordé une
interview exclusive et le parti
républicain a fait ses clips en piquant
les images de france 24 en anglais on a
dû j'ai dû intervenir
donc s'il faut croire qu'on est quand
même passé absent des états unis voilà
merci là deux dernières questions
j'aurais mon cette question s'adresse au
président du directoire d'arte et france
monsieur bruno patino lors de votre
dernière audition à l'occasion de
l'examen du budget vous aviez indiqué qu
arte france souhaitait développer la
co-création européenne de ce qui
nécessitait une évolution de la
réglementation des droits au niveau
européen vous en avait parlé dans votre
propos liminaire le projet de qom
mentionne la nécessité d'une obtention
de droits équivalents de diffusion et
l'exploitation à l'échelle européenne
mais n'évoque aucune méthode ni aucun
calendrier pour atteindre cet objectif
pourquoi ce manque de précision est ce
le signe que l'actionnaire n'entend pas
agir afin de faire évoluer au niveau
national et européen la réglementation
sur les droits attachés aux productions
plus généralement comment comptez-vous
développer votre ambition en matière de
production européenne
merci beaucoup alors évidemment le tout
stratégie européenne passe par une
disponibilité et une capacité d'obtenir
des droits européens et aujourd'hui ce
qui fait d'une certaine façon la
spécificité d'arte et c'est qu'on a
l'habitude de construire au cas par cas
des des disponibilités européenne pour
pour chacune ou quasiment chacune de nos
productions
quand on peut financièrement se le
permettre encore une fois il ya deux
économies qui sont totalement
différentes en termes de droit européen
les fictions et tout le reste tout le
reste est assez accessible aujourd'hui
les fictions depuis l'éruption des
plateformes mondiale avoir des droits
européens pour les fictions est quelque
chose qui paradoxalement est
techniquement plus facile et
économiquement
plus inaccessibles donc aujourd'hui ce
que nous faisons c'est au cas par cas
avec la production avec les pros avec
les différents producteurs négocier une
extension européenne de leurs droits on
le fait au seinde arte france au dauphin
au sein du gie eu lieu aussi et comme
vous le savez une partie de la stratégie
européenne voire toute la stratégie
européenne d'arreter passe par le j'ai
eu lieu nous avons un certain nombre de
chaînes partenaires aussi donc pour nous
si vous voulez clairement dans les
années qui viennent l'ambition c'est et
vous me pardonnerez ce terme qui ne
réflète pas de façon très juste ce que
nous allons faire mais c'est
d'industrialiser ou en tout cas de deux
de faire que ce soit pas à chaque fois
un artisanat ou de la haute couture pour
chacun des programmes parce que sinon ça
demande évidemment beaucoup de temps
beaucoup de beaucoup de beaucoup
d'agilité pour chacun des programmes
donc ça c'est un enjeu et qui ne peut se
faire qu'au sein j'allais dire qu'avec
l'accord à la fois des cadres
réglementaires d'une part et des
différentes sociétés production d'autres
donc le j'ai eu pour nous est un bon
endroit
en plus en écho avec lui un air pur pour
avancer dans ce domaine je me permets de
mentionner ce qui n'est pas un détail
que le le vice président du géant lieu
comme comme vous le savez la france à la
présidence du g us en ce moment et je
l'exercé le président et le
vice-président du géant yeux qui est
monsieur peter webber est le directeur
juridique de la zdf est très très actif
au sein de l'ue air mais mais mais
delphine ernotte en parlerait mieux que
moi au sein de la commission juridique
de l'ue est donc je pense car tu es peut
être effectivement un facilitateur dans
la création de solutions on va dire
industrielle jamais vraiment mille
guillemets à industriels pour plus
européanisée les droits par ailleurs
comme vous l'avez mentionné je veux pas
être trop long là dessus une de nos
ambitions c'est de remonter petit à
petit la collaboration européenne c'est
à dire que là aussi art est pour moi un
rôle absolument centrale aujourd'hui
nous coproduisons beaucoup
la grande majorité de nos fictions sont
des coproductions européennes des
coproductions ça veut dire évidemment
des financements de plusieurs
partenaires européens nous sommes
rentrés depuis un certain nombre
d'années déjà dans un mécanisme de
co-création alors de temps en temps de
co-création un pays prend en charge le
développement fait participer d'autres
pays nous avons parfois aussi au sein de
mécanismes spécifiques eu des bureaux
d'écriture qui qui comment dire
regrouper de nationalité ça ne
surprendra pas de savoir que c'était la
nationalité allemande et nationalité
française évidemment pour arte je
mentirais en disant que c'est
extrêmement simple mais en même temps je
mentirais aussi en disant que ça
n'apporte pas des choses absolument
absolument fascinante dans la complexité
des récits et dans la capacité de voir
que effectivement ces récits né de
plusieurs de plusieurs regards européens
donnent une profondeur forte donc dans
les années qui viennent notamment dans
les coproductions en termes de fiction
nous allons passer à une étape
supérieure en essayant d'instaurer des
mécanismes d'incubation d'écriture au
sein du gie eu lieu bonjour à toutes et
tous ses meilleurs voeux encore à nos
présidents de l'audiovisuel public
français pour une année qui s'annonce un
peu difficile compte tenu de la
persistance de la de la crise sanitaire
dira peut-être en préambule que nous
sommes tout de même nombreux à regretter
la suppression de cette réforme
audiovisuelle
tout simplement parce qu'on ne fait que
reculer
un certain nombre de problèmes que yahvé
à résoudre et je remercie mari fils
saragosse d'avoir souligné la fragilité
finalement indirectement de ceux comme
qui ne porte que sur deux ans j'aurai
mon bonnet l'a rappelé il est presque
hors la loi puisque les comme c'est
minimum de 3 à 5 ans et donc le fait de
ne pas avoir traité cette question de la
réforme ça laisse l'audiovisuel de toute
façon dans une forme de fragilité
à l'échéance 2022 vous avant les
élections majeures et ne faut jamais
sous-estimer la possibilité de l'arrivée
où vous voulez en avoir la tête de
l'état de le gouvernement justement
qu'il pourrait avoir tentation de
réformer profondément la aux deux ans
pour la supprimer
si ça va ça vient d'évoquer le risque
qu'ils auraient de se conformer une
dotation publique en une dotation d'état
sapant la l'indépendance de nos
entreprises de l'audiovisuel public donc
je suis lié la fragilité de liste cohn
mais en même temps bien entendu le côté
positif les cinq indicateurs comme à
l'esa gassion spécialise dans les
indicateurs communs et je serai une de
mes premières questions à l'ensemble des
présidents de l'audiovisuel public n'est
pas évoqué la question des publics dits
empêcher
j'ai bien noté que la recherche de la
diversité de la parité l'égalité
professionnelle tout ça enlève
d'ailleurs de ce qu'on appelle plus
largement les droits culturels dans une
certaine mesure inscrit dans la loi par
le sénat
et j'imagine que c'est un des objectifs
forts aussi que vous portez que celui de
la tension à la question des publics
empêchés du handicap mais j'aimerais
vous entendre de peut-être en reparler
un satisfecit bien sûr pour ce qui est
le modèle vertueux de l'entreprise à
savoir le respect environnemental au
disque où serait tout à fait ma question
plus large les transversales serait de
vous demander comment vous avez
travaillé et préparé
c'est comme vous êtes il était demandé
concrètement de travailler en équipe et
de constitue en quelque sorte aussi un
bilan des actions si vous ont rapprochés
puisque c'était un peu l'objectif
notamment
par exemple à travers la question des
matinales en ce 3 france bleu la
question de france info à ti y at il eu
un bilan de france info qu' un petit peu
décevant en terme d'audience donc
comment on corrige le tir
comment on retravaille de la
transversalité entre vos différentes
équipes
est-ce que vous avez travaillé la
question comme l'a évoqué tout à l'heure
où bono patine ou d'un bouquet éditorial
par exemple on va prendre le thème de
j'ai passé parce que la formation
prônons le thème de la jeunesse qui est
très important puisque on va supprimer
malheureusement en skate en dépit la
réaffirmation de delphine ernotte de la
nécessité de cette chaîne pour porter
l'ambition pour la jeunesse y at il eu
donc un travail sur un objectif
atteindre 2 vraiment ensemble cibler la
jeunesse avec une déclinaison
programmatique d'une entreprise à
l'autre permettant voilà une offre
extrêmement force et on pourrait parler
de l'ensemble des des thèmes bien
entendu le sport la culture mais je vais
pas trop être longue sur ces sujets
magazine questions portent sur
l'ambition universel de notre
audiovisuel public même chose comment
avez vous travaillé entre france
télévisions qui forcément envoie aussi
des reporteurs à l'étranger france ce
média monde dansait le coeur de métier
mais aussi art et pardonnez moi de ne
pas citer tout le monde quand même et
vous avez travaillé ensemble cette
dimension universelle et cet
approfondissement européen cette
stratégie européenne si nécessaire peut
être mariée quasi saragosse
pourra-t-elle de manière spécifique
d'ailleurs expliqué le travail qui est
fait et à y at-il assez de moyens dans
ce contrat d'objectifs et de moyens
selon vous pour toutes cette ambition
notamment de lutter contre la
désinformation
ce qu'on appelle les uns fox mais aussi
la radicalisation il ya ce programme en
europe et un réacteur qui est
certainement extrêmement important somme
toute est ce que ce com selon vous
décline qu'il a suffisamment ambitieux
en matière de moyens pour porter
ce rôle qu'est devenu fondamental de
notre devise est lé public à l'heure de
la mondialisation et de la puissance des
dégâts femmes et on l'a vu dans la crise
c'est à dire que plus que jamais le nul
est important pour pour cela voilà en
quelques sortes mais mes questions elles
sont assez peu nombreuses parce que
seulement vous à vouloir intervenir si
catherine david assouline
merci monsieur le président merci à tous
les patrons et patronnes de
l'audiovisuel public
non seulement nous avoir exposé ses com
et mais d'avoir travailler à leur mise
en place
sur la forme il ya une avancée certaine
qui est
ces indicateurs communs ça commence à
nous donner une idée d'une spécificité
global de l'audiovisuel public et pas
dans quelque chose qui s'égayent et qui
n'est pas visible
ça compense qu'en partie le fait qu'il
n'y aura pas de audi mais qu' il n'y a
pas de marque commune comme peut l'être
la bbc mais ça donne à quelque chose
d'important
je regrette quand il s'agit de comme
puisqu'il s'agit de suivre les
indicateurs et tout donc quelque chose
de très austère taux précis concrets
qu'on se soustraient à l'exercice
minimum qui est l'évaluation du comme
précédent parce que quand même derrière
faire semblant qu'à chaque fois
recommence à zéro parce que quand on
commence à avoir quelques années de
mandat on en a vu des corps et des
engagements et des trucs qui deux ans
après
n'était même pas discuter dire que les
budget était complètement différent les
objectifs changé et on disait pas ben
voilà on a échoué
la scène a été donc on a rectifié ce
même pas on fait qu'à chaque fois comme
si on a inventé l'eau chaude
bon donc 2022 quai espérons que ce ne
soit pas une majorité si différentes que
discutera pas de com mais de ophain beau
donc ça c'est sur la forme
pourquoi n'y a pas d'évaluation si on
veut dans la culture des indicateurs
tatatata et pourquoi et bravo pour cette
mise en commun
je regrette une chose qui est que vous
n'évoquez pas qui est complètement
acquis dans les indicateurs communs
culture création jeunesse éducation
d'information proximité entre action
extérieure très bien donc on a décidé
que un pas gigantesque dans le jeu du
linéaire
parce que il ya les spécificités du
linéaire qui fait qu'on regarde encore
la télé qu'on écoute la radio et qu'on
est pas que sur des plateformes
donc ça c'est la force de ce que vous
représentez
c'est le direct et dans le direct il ya
un marché gigantesque entre guillemets
marché
c'est le sport qui se regardent direct
donc le service public a abandonné
l'idée qu'il pouvait avoir un quelconque
rôle jeudi à main pas concurrentiel mais
un quelconque rôle spécifique pour ce
domaine dont le pays qui organisent les
jo en 2021 voilà je lance ça avec la
crise mediapro et c'est du financement
du fou qui n'est qu'une partie du sport
je pense que
il serait bon de relancer ce débat
sérieusement très sérieuse mouvement
parce que l'audiovisuel public ne peut
pas abandonner ce qui est la visibilité
la plus populaire et la plus fédératrice
de nos concitoyens que le sport point
qu'on peut juger il ya la culture et où
moi je suis sereine dans la culture vous
le savez et je la mets en avant et je la
défends mais là cet abandon de quelque
chose de très populaire et de
spécifiquement linéaire et de partage
d'émotions de deux communes
extraordinaire le service public dit
c'est pas mon truc
bon voilà ça c'est sur la forme juste
une chose je connais l'exercice
compliqué que vous avez parce que vous
ne pouvait être que satisfait entre
guillemets de vos com même quand voilà
en france 4 qui est un engagement
important de delphine ernotte et mis à
la poubelle alors je dis pas que rien
n'assure la jeunesse a je pense pas non
plus que vous l'auriez accepté mais
davantage c'est que nous politique où on
pense toujours qu'on peut faire bouger
les choses et on n'a pas de patron des
tutelles enfin certains en ont mais qu'à
moi je peux vous dire que jusqu'à la
dernière minute
je ferai tout pour que franska ne ferme
pas la peut-être perdre la tête hein
mais on a moins perdu doté des frondes a
gagné des médailles
donc ça c'est vraiment incroyable
si 1re confinement vous allez voir
incroyable parce que tout le monde est
d'accord je ne rencontre pas une
personne de droite ou de gauche ou
professionnels ou spécialistes ou
impliqués dans l'audiovisuel qui me
disent c'est bien de fermiers france 4
non ça vient d'où ce truc là le
président a dit mais où on est mais on
est franchement c'est scandaleux
des fois il ya des pouilles à l'écouté
des vrais arguments notamment l'argument
financier aurait pu en être un or il a
été battu en brèche parce que ça coûte
pas grand chose et que forcément le fait
de
quand même faire une offre va donc je
veux le soulever je veux féliciter votre
travail et tout mais je vois bien que on
demande de faire bien mieux
qui à la concurrence des plateformes
tout ça et bien analyser on demande de
faire la révolution numérique et de
l'approfondir avec des vrais objectifs
mais sur fonds propres et on diminue
globalement d'ici 2022
la dotation donc ça c'est inacceptable
non plus on va pas faire semblant qu'on
est content parce qu'il faudra rectifier
cela
et la question de la deûle à qui fait
consensus
maintenant de la redevance universel du
fait que l'audiovisuel soit entièrement
financé par ce tuyau pour assurer
l'indépendance
madame ça à loos a dit les choses telles
que nous les pensons mais pareil il y as
consensus et ceux qui gouvernent la
partie bercy que ce soit sous la gauche
ou sous la droite actuelle fait toujours
la même chose
elle empêche parce qu'elle ait consensus
aussi moi je travaille concrètement à la
mise en place de cela dont le
quinquennat précédent et j'ai vu qu'on
m'a dit l'année prochaine l'année
prochaine l'année prochaine là on réduit
l'année prochaine l'année prochaine
venue prochaine donc deux quinquennats
où il y avait plus ou moins un consensus
politique pour pas être en retard par
rapport à des usages et rien n'a bougé
donc il faudra parler ensemble très fort
là dessus je suis d'accord
avec marie-christine ça va merci julien
bargeton qui ensuite céline brulin
julien et tournon en temps je viens d'un
petit bonjour oui très bien rapidement
ok les sujets numériques est ce que vous
pouvez nous préciser un peu ce que vous
attendez notamment de sato de la façon
dont vous travaillez ensemble et quels
sont les objectifs précis que que vous
attendez sur sur le sujet du numérique
pour approfondir un peu le les drogues
qui a juste été abordés pour l'instant
merci celui de moulins
merci monsieur le président merci
mesdames messieurs le président je parle
plus près du micro pour ma part je mets
connaissait cet exercice et je voudrais
dire ma frustration pas du tout à
l'égard de vos interventions qui sont
très éclairantes mais en fait on a face
à nous et on ne peut interroger qu'une
partie des acteurs d'un contrat et pour
nous c'est quand même un peu compliqué
parce que ça éveille forcément des
questions d'autres l'ont dit avant moi
bac en voudrait poser à l'état
actionnaire tout simplement et on vous
met dans la difficulté de devoir y
répondre à sa place et y compris nous ne
partageons pas toujours les choix de cet
état actionnaire donc on est aussi en
difficulté pour vous questionnez voilà
et puis je rejoins ce tout ce qui a été
dit par mes prédécesseurs sur la
fragilité à laquelle conduit ce
c'est comme à laquelle conduit c'est
comme durée raccourcie
je vais vous dire même un peu mon
inquiétude parce que j'entends qu'en
2022 il ya des élections importantes
mais c'est précisément pas pour me
rassurer que le calendrier soit calé sur
ça pour des raisons d'indépendance
et puis pour quelques inquiétudes qu'on
peut aussi nourrir sur ce qui se passe
dans notre pays à la lumière de ce qui
se passe dans d'autres pays de par le
monde
alors vous avez tous dit et david
assouline disait que vous ne pouviez pas
faire autrement que de vous satisfaire
de ces com et vous avez quand même tous
10 ans vous en satisfaisant que que les
choses étaient extrêmement difficiles à
mettre en oeuvre dans certains domaines
après et je voudrais souligner des
efforts déjà extrêmement conséquent qui
ont été mis en oeuvre ces dernières
années donc pour éclairer le débat
public et les parlementaires que nous
sommes est ce que vous pourriez aller un
petit peu plus loin pour préciser très
concrètement sur quoi vont porter
précisément les difficultés qu'on peut
attendre dans les mois et les jours à
venir
ensuite il ya eu un nez à un élément
quand même important c'est la directive
et sema puisqu'on voit bien que à terme
il ya des enjeux de financement très
important quelle est votre réflexion je
déborde un peu le cadre de l'exercice
d'aujourd'hui mais quelle est votre
réflexion sur la manière dont pourrait
être réparti ses nouvelles recettes
parce que je crois que aux côtés de la
contribution
à l'audiovisuel c'est évidemment quelque
chose qui a regardé ensuite j'ai posé la
question d'une manière un peu détournée
si rêvons un peu
on pouvait se dire que d'ores et déjà on
peut mettre des avenants à ses com parce
qu'on considère qu'on est dans une
situation de crise plus durable qu'on ne
l'avait imaginé et que effectivement ça
a été dit france 4 a montré tout son
intérêt en matière éducative
on ne sait pas ce qui va advenir dans
les prochains jours les prochaines
semaines de l'éducation des enfants
mais on pourrait dire la même chose du
spectacle vivant et du fait que les
lieux culturels sont toujours fermés
donc si d'aventuré ensemble nous
pouvions dire que la crise est durable
et de que donc ça amène peut-être revoir
un peu c'est comme pour répondre à la
crise que nous traversions quelles
seraient les priorités que vous voudriez
définir et enfin vous êtes un certain
nombre et je trouve que c'est une
réflexion très juste avoir insisté sur
le besoin de proximité particulièrement
dans le contexte est ce que vous
pourriez aussi la préciser un peu les
choses
je pense évidemment à france ô
qui manque à beaucoup mais il ya eu par
le passé aussi des inquiétudes sur des
décrochages régionaux de france 3 etc
dans un contexte et j'en termine là deux
régions administratives qui sont
aujourd'hui des territoires un peu
bizarroïdes par moments faim qu'ils
correspondent tout à fait à de vrais
bassin de vie et donc comment se traduit
la proximité dans ce contexte là je vous
remercie
si des questions qui devraient être un
peu après à chacun d'entre eux ont
peut-être que delphine ernotte commencé
alors merci monsieur le président je
vais essayer de répondre à cet ensemble
de questions tout d'abord je voudrais
prendre un peu ma ma casquette
européenne puisque bruno patino il
faisait allusion depuis le 1er janvier
je suis présidente des télévisions et
radios publiques européennes
donc c'est lui le r le fameux er c'est
une très vieille association qui a plus
de 70 ans qui regroupe 56 pays et qui
met des gens en partage un certain
nombre de choses donc il faut savoir que
les sujets d'information sont partagés
entre membres publique de l'ue air
depuis soixante ans que nous que nous en
tant que m
répondant à des appels d'offres sur les
droits sportifs et c'est là dessus que
je voulais en venir parce que je crois
que david assouline a complètement
raison sur le sport ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est que comme vous l'avez
signalé nous nos moyens baissent enfin
bon on va pas on va pas dire autre chose
nous voyant baisse et les droits
sportifs augmente de manière
considérable et par ailleurs comme il ya
aussi une compétition effrénée des
médias globaux que sont amazon aurait
bien vu un roland garros a donné ses
matches du soir à amazon 1
eh bien on se retrouve dans une scène
dans une forme de squeeze donc si il n'y
a pas de sport dans le com
c'est pas de notre fait déjà mais c'est
aussi parce que finalement on peut pas
établir de stratégie sur le sport alors
qu'on a plus les moyens d'augmenter les
droits sportifs que nous mettons sur la
table et on n'a même plus les moyens au
niveau européen
je vous donne un exemple et là ça
concerne pas la france mais c'est avec
ma casquette européenne pour les jeux
paralympiques que les services publics
européens défendent depuis des années
nous on met senteurs de jeux
paralympiques sur nos antennes tous les
services publics européens défendent les
jeux paralympiques
il ya eu un appel d'offres du comité
olympique ils ont choisi non pas la
totalité des services européens mais une
agence de droit chinoise voilà qui va se
charger de vendre les droits
paralympiques
il ya un moment si vous voulez on peut
pas être nous sur des missions pur de
service public à défendre l'intérêt
général
la meilleure exposition des compétitions
sportives et à voir par ailleurs
finalement à l'aller comité qui joue un
autre jeu pour quoi 2 millions d'euros
moi je dis ça parce que je trouve que là
on est dans une espèce de
on est donc dans un squeeze économique
et je pense que ça sera préjudiciable je
pense qu'il finira pas y avoir une crise
c'est quand on verra que finalement la
bonne vieille télé c'est encore 4
français sur 5 toutes les semaines qui
regarde france télévisions etc etc c'est
la même chose partout en europe
quand on verra qui étaient les privés
sont extrêmement mise à mal par la
difficulté du marché publicitaire et que
en europe les seuls télé indépendante
ça va être et radio d'ailleurs un des
seuls médias indépendants s'arrêtent les
médias de service public on sera bien
content d'avoir des médias de service
public fort voilà et le sport c'est en
fait partie le sport en fait partie les
les émissions quotidiennes en font
partie parce que ce cas la télévision et
que non pas nos concurrents
c'est cette espèce de lien c'est le
plaisir de regarder la même chose
ensemble au même moment d'avoir la même
émotion et ça on sait maintenant depuis
le confinement que ça a une énorme
valeur et ça ça se joue tous les jours
au travers de la formation mais des
rendez vous quotidiens qu'ont les gens
avec leurs animateurs avec c'est à vous
voilà avec des émissions récurrentes
faut pas oublier qu'il ya des millions
de gens qui vivent seules en france des
millions de gens comptent rien dans leur
agenda le lendemain si ce n'est et je
l'espère ce c'est notre fierté
un rendez vous avec une émission de
france télévisions voilà c'est ça la
réalité humaine est ce qui fait ça c'est
les rendez vous quotidien le sport les
grands événements qui peuvent être des
grands spectacles vivants des grands
moments de partage et donc effectivement
il faut qu'on arrive à préserver à la
fois la création mais aussi ce qui est
le propre de la télévision donc le flux
le sport est donc je remercie nass&wind
c'est une bonne remarque alors même là
vous nous avez interpellé moi je vais
vous
j'adore ces début de l'année
on peut faire des voeux j'en ai deux
extrêmement concret le premier je le dis
c'est sur france 4
je pense que voilà on peut être qu'on
pourrait attendre un peu la fin de tout
ça pour pour fermer france 4 et on sait
pas quand on va être là fins ces deux
premières la première remarque et la
deuxième c'est france info parce que
madame morin desailly en parallèle on
parle toujours de ce qu'on sait pas
faire il ya quand même une chose qu'on a
su extrêmement bien faire tous ensemble
je dis bien tous ensemble c'est france
info on a des duplex avec
marie-christine les pas si de l'ina son
génial on à radio france qui qui poste
des choses aussi sur le numérique tout
ça tout ça dès des antennes des heures
d'antenne quotidienne commune avec radio
france donc france info il faut vous
dire quand même que la bbc est venu voir
comment on avait fait la rai est venu
voir que l'on avait fait les pays du
nord de l'europe sont venus voir comment
on avait fait donc tout le monde est
fier de france info sauf nous enfin ici
je veux dire non mais je le dis parce
que bon il ya des trucs qu'on fait bien
faut quand même le dire
voilà donc pour rené à 1 france info moi
mon souhait c'est un canal qui expose -
france info il faut savoir qu'entre le
canal 30 on est à peu près le canal 15
vous x 2 l'audience en hausse et cemex
et mécanique parce qu'il ya encore
beaucoup de gens pour une télécommande
et qui font un deux trois quatre cinq et
cédera donc voilà donc j'ai deux
souhaite très simple faisable à notre
échelle on a besoin de changer la
réglementation pour répondre à votre
sollicitation gentil de joux
monsieur breton devait aussi posé la
question sur le numérique
vous avez raison il ya énormément de
projets qu'on a je réponds aussi au
travers de ça à la question de mme morin
dessailly qui nous a interrogé sur
comment on avait travaillé en fait ça
fait déjà pas mal d'années qu'on
travaille ensemble il faut il faut le
dire tous ici on se connaît bien
d'ailleurs ça nous manque nos réunions
de partenaires parce que là on peut plus
les faire à cause de la pandémie mais on
a monté quand même beaucoup de projets
ensemble franceinfo bien sûr lumni on
oublie de le dire monsieur énorme
bibi que nous avons lancé relancer en
fait tous ensemble quand même fin 2019
on a été bien inspiré parce que
heureusement voilà voilà
il ya maintenant un élève sur deux un
prof sur deux qui connaît lui mit donc
voilà c'est quand même heureusement
qu'on a tous ensemble refabriquer 7,7
nature inconnue culture prime alors
c'est moins connu parce que c'est pas du
linéaire c'est sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est des pastilles mais ça bon ben
voilà ça existe et ça marche très très
bien
donc voilà donc on est dans une
dynamique en réalité donc il ya déjà
tout ce qu'on a fait qu'on va continuer
à faire grandir
et puis tous les projets nouveaux et là
dessus je pense qu on a oui un peu de
rationalisation à faire donc en effet si
on peut être si on peut arriver à faire
sur le reste ce qu'on a fait sur france
info se mettre tous derrière une même
ombrelle et ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
c'est le premier la première source
d'information sur numérique en france 1
donc c'est voilà on est on est leader
sur sur la formation
eh bien je pense qu'on pourra faire des
merveilles donc ça reste à construire
mais c'est quand même dans une dynamique
extrêmement positive voilà je sais pas
si j'ai pas été un peu longue mais
est-ce que d'autres personnes vont dire
tu devais partir non non je vais
répondre dans l'ordre alors parce que
catherine morin dessailly évoqué la
question des handicapés il me semblait
que le service public se doit de
d'être vigilant là dessus et que c'est
bien dans l'indicateur du comme c'est à
dire que ce c'est toutes les diversités
et notamment le handicap et nous par
exemple on a un indicateur de plan
d'action très précis et d'ailleurs
delphine mentionné qu'elle allait sous
titré tout france info en pour les
soussignés excédé effectivement ça
automatiquement mais donc c'était
clairement un des objectifs communs fort
du secteur je voulais je voulais le dire
je dire aussi que en termes de
coordination bien sûr on a en a fait le
bilan de ce qu'on faisait déjà ensemble
mais j'étais un tout petit peu étonné
par la question de david assouline sur
l'évaluation parce que chaque année on
présente un bilan du com année après
année avec tous les indicateurs et dieu
sait qu'il y en a 30
on vient de présenter en commission on
vient de présenter au cs a enfin avancé
d'administration devant ces mêmes
formalisé par la loi alors peut-être
qu'il voulait dire c'est la trajectoire
générale une sorte de bilan
alors le fait est que là les comme qu'il
était arrêté depuis longtemps puisqu'on
avait pu être électeur financière mais
on avait quand même des objectifs mais
donc là je comprends mais sinon il est
sur la baie sur leurs courts mais oui
mais en même temps chaque année quand on
vient de présenter devant les instances
eux on peut voir si on si ça a du sens
il me semble quand même on a une la loi
encadre ça mais je pense qu'il voulait
parler aussi de la durée complète et du
fait que c'était rarement respectés dans
leur durée complète
je reviens pas sur l'abandon du sport
parce que les filles à dhuisy juste dire
que nous à notre modeste échelle radio
on garde quand même tous les droits
mondiaux et on les a pas encore perdu
pour le privé et par exemple pour
l'afrique franchement on aurait pas
autant de succès si on n'avait pas radio
foot tous les jours et ce genre de droit
la can
si vous n'avez pas la cas dans l'afrique
c'est pas la peine d'essayer d'exister
par exemple donc c'est vrai que c'est un
enjeu qui est pas du tout second
monsieur le sénateur
jetons à parler des plateformes gelé
juste dire parce que souvent quand on
dit transformation numérique on dit
plate forme et c'est je reviens là
dessus parce que c'est vrai plateforme
salto d'autres plateformes la plateforme
de radio france n'a pas de prendre de
tv5 monde
mais je redis que pour moi la
consommation numérique c'est la lutte
contre les manipulations de
l'information le complotisme la perte de
confiance dans les médias traditionnels
et que c'est vrai à l'échelle de la
planète et c'est vrai dans toutes les
langues
il ya des langues particulièrement
offensive contre notre pays contre ses
valeurs contre sa démocratie et donc je
pense que la transformation numérique
c'est aussi notre capacité collective à
pas nous laisser faire et pas laisser
manipuler les jeunes non plus pas juste
quand on dit transformation numérique ne
pensons pas que plateforme
et puisqu'on a été invité à arriver par
madame la sénatrice
alors du coup tout de suite évidemment
pas de bijoux pas de choses comme ça
mais alors en revanche moi je rêverais
de langue étrangère nouvelles et par
exemple sur la vraie du tueur croyez
vous j'aurais beaucoup aimé répondre en
turc à monsieur erdogan a il n'y a pas
très longtemps
j'aurais beaucoup aimé m'adresser à la
communauté turque très nombreuses qui
est en france et qui communiquent en
turc sans qu'aucun service public ne
sache exactement puisque alors on
communique dans 18 langues dans mon
groupe mais pentue et il avait une
réaction turque figurez-vous en 2010 à
vérifier pas de chance elle a été fermée
dans un plan de départ donc je me
permets de dire que moi je trouverais ça
très bien qu'on parle tu es et aux
frontières de l'europe il ya plein de
niveaux toujours mieux blabla que
pendant disait churchill
donc je trouve qu'il faudrait faire
beaucoup de blabla en turc et dans les
langues africaines dont convient d'en
lancer on vient donc je vous disais
vous êtes si vous voulez vous branchez
ont fait la conférence paris dakar un
vrai paris-dakar en virtuel jeudi est
donc le foulfouldé donc la langue peule
pascal à l'épaule par un coup de coude
et c'est la langue la plus anti
françaises de la bande sahélienne et
c'est alors qu'il ya des talents
extraordinaires il ya des jeunes
extraordinaire des femmes
extraordinaires dans cette es donc on va
parler avec eux me ferait parler aussi
des longues touareg il faudrait
probablement parlé le lingala kehl qui
est la langue de la rdc 85 millions
d'habitants pays le principal pays
francophones d'afrique
donc en fait moi mon rêve ce serait de
d'avoir la tour de babel a encore plus à
issy les moulineaux
si c'était ou ailleurs d'ailleurs en
proximité voilà c'était ça mon cadeau de
ce que je demanderai pour bruno patino
mais si vous le permettez je vais vous
prendre la parole sans être très très
original d'ailleurs fort forcément pour
peut-être sur sur deux points pour
compléter ce qui était dit tout en juste
notant que sur la capacité de faire des
choses ensemble
moi je pense qu en ce moment on est
effectivement sur une dynamique où on
construit beaucoup de choses ensemble
sybille veille les n'est plus là pour
pour qu'on puisse évoquer l'offre qu'on
a fait avec france musique avec delphine
ernotte et france télévisions ont fait
pas mal de choses aussi et je voulais
juste souligner qu'avec marie christine
saragosse et france médias m'ont
beaucoup de nos reportages dans les
zones les plus compliqués
de la planète sont faits ensemble en
fait entre art et j'ai eu lieu la
rédaction d' art et j'ai eu lieu et
france médias monde et que c'est quelque
chose je pense qu'ils assurent aussi
cette couverture mondiale et
internationales de l'information non
juste sur deux points le premier puisque
puisqu'on nous a proposé de rêver et
d'avoir et d'avoir les cadeaux de début
d'année il sera pas dit que je n'aurais
pas évoqué cette possibilité là je
en ce qui nous concerne nous je vais
juste mettre l'accent sur deux choses en
fait
quand je parle du développement européen
quand je rêve du développement européen
d'arte et je me dis que de temps en
temps j'ai l'impression que notre
actionnaire peut être nos partenaires ne
se rendent pas compte qu'il suffit de
peu pour avoir potentiellement beaucoup
c'est à dire que effectivement on
pourrait venir devant vous et dire pour
avoir un développement européen
important il me faut 500 millions sur
deux ans et je connais déjà le résultat
de 2,2 telle demande
non je vais faire des demandes plus
modestes mais plus modeste et en même
temps plus compliqué parce
qu'aujourd'hui si je pense qu'on a en ce
qui concerne la chaîne arte de murs ou
plutôt deux obstacles majeurs à franchir
sur le développement européen ce sont
des obstacles accessible mais pas
toujours compris le premier il est
linguistique marie-christine en a parlé
aujourd'hui je vous ai mentionné le fait
d'avoir des droits europe sur un très
très grand nombre de programmes
pratiquement toute notre offre
culturelle musicale possède aujourd'hui
des droits europe
notre offre culturelle des droits europe
ne le droit nos parts dans nos
documentaires des droits en europe vous
avez bien alors pourquoi bas parce
qu'après il faut sous-titré voir doubler
alors sachez le camp même quand on
double on est vu par trois fois plus de
monde que canton sous titre c'est la
statistique dans l'ensemble des pays
d'europe donc le sous titre moi je moi
j'adore les sous titres mais en réalité
pour le rendre disponible pour rendre
disponible un programme dans d'autres
pays il faut il faut le double
ça a un coût c'est pas identique à un
coût de production évidemment mais c'est
un réel coup et qu'effectivement quand
on est dans un contexte de restrictions
budgétaires ce coup là devient très
important or pardonnez moi de le dire
comme ça c'est un investissement
somme toute modique pour un
élargissement territorial grand et je
pense que donc la rentabilité d'un tel
investissement a été extrêmement forte
pardon de parler comme ça la deuxième
chose et je pense que là aussi il faut
je me permets de parler pour arte mais
ça m'étonnerait que que mais mes
collègues et amis est un autre discours
souvent il ya beaucoup de neige répond
notamment à 1 catherine morin desailly
souvent il ya beaucoup de réflexions de
la part de deux de nos partenaires ou de
la tutelle sur mécanisme une seule plate
forme de plateformes trois plateformes
quatre plateformes en fait ma conviction
c'est que c'est pas si important il faut
qu'ils en aient beaucoup mais ce qui est
très important très important c'est la
compétence technologique derrière on
peut faire la plus grosse plateforme
française possible si elle est pas
technologiquement à jour ça ne servira à
rien mais fait 15 plateforme n'ont pas
concurrente parce que la magie de cet
univers numérique c'est quoi être
pourrait on peut être dans plusieurs
endroits en même temps c'est pas
compliqué ça ne nous a posé aucun
problème de rejoindre la plateforme de
radio france pour les podcasts parce que
ça nous a pas priver de quelque chose ça
nous a donné quelque chose de plus et
donc pouvoir travailler ensemble et se
creuse poster se lancer ensemble se
permettent la circulation entre ces
plusieurs endroits et quelque chose de
tout à fait possible et personnellement
moi j'ai tendance toujours à penser
qu'on nous met devant 1 devant un
arbitrage qui n'existe pas une seule ou
plusieurs bennes on peut faire plusieurs
et plusieurs qui marche très bien et qui
s'entraident
en revanche plusieurs qui parlent entre
elles plusieurs qui qui qui qui j'allais
dire qu'ils font communiqué et qui font
circuler le
le public entre elles et qui est je
crois que c'était le film tout à l'heure
qui a parlé de deux cultures prime
culture prime ça marche très bien parce
qu'en plus on grosse poste c'est à dire
qu on se pousse les uns les autres dans
les dents les audiences les uns les
autres et c'est pour ça que ça
fonctionne mais en revanche il faut de
la compétence technologique et la
compétence technologique ça coûte cher
et aujourd'hui je je je je crois que si
on ne veut pas désarmer le service
public
il faut lui permettre d'avoir les moyens
d'acquérir cette compétence
technologique
ça coûte cher non seulement en
investissements technologiques mais
aussi en ressources humaines dans des
marchés extrêmement compétitif et ça je
crois si je pouvais rajouter ce cadeau
là c'est qu'on nous permette
effectivement ensemble de développer
cette compétence technologique propre
merci oui bah en fait je vais sans doute
me dis que je ne leur ai dit
qu'effectivement au tour ce qui est de
des plateformes d'abord pour mina où
vous savez c'est pas un sujet de
plateformes versus antenne puisque nous
sommes que plateforme est à la fois plus
simple et très compliqué mais il ya
clairement un enjeu sur notre notre
plateforme gratuite n'a point fr voilà
devant richir et d'en faire un axe est
de profiter de la puissance din a.fr qui
est passé en cinq ans de de moins de 80
millions à près d'un milliard de vidéos
vues pour en faire un accès à l'ensemble
des offres des services a uniquement que
de contenus audiovisuels
mais pourquoi pas aussi de formation de
produits de notre recherche d'études etc
pour sa part la c'est ce que ina.fr
devient une espèce de pub
accès gratuit très large à toutes les
propositions services commerciaux ou pas
commerciaux de villenave
par ailleurs il ya évidemment eu l'idée
de contribuer de participer chaque fois
que c'est possible aux autres aux offres
communes comme sur france-info com sur
le crime comme sur l'ubs ni delphine a
dit serena qui a copiloté notamment en
travaillant sur la partie dite
professional faire les herbes et aux
enseignants avec des parcours
pédagogiques et certifiable en sac de
classe en douala en mettant tous qui le
sonore et les podcasts sur sur la
plateforme et applications de nos amis
de radio france est lui aussi en
développant des offres de niche veut
prendre irene a dit organisé comme comme
madeleine inquiets 9 payante qui répond
aussi à notre statut d'établissement
public et au fait que comme je vous ai
d'ailleurs il faut bien qu'il faut bien
qu'on gagne de quoi ce que vient couvrir
enfin de quoi le boucler notre budget
au delà des 70 % qui sont assurées pas
de la cap mais que au fond je crois que
c'est pas tant le nombre des plateformes
et l'idée d'une plateforme unique type
de temps tout est à cause peut pas être
stockée un autre projet est honnête un
projet de audio de piquet un très beau
projet mais d'exposition de la création
française
je crois que derrière c'est plus des
coopérations autour effectivement de
tout ce qui est la façon dont on se
saborde des contenus présents à
plusieurs endroits bruno patino a dit
ces plates formes différentes de
l'audiovisuel public qui ont des
objectifs différents de ceux
effectivement se renvoyer les unes vers
les autres
intégrée pour partie des contenus les
unes des autres et puis surtout il ya un
travail technique et y compris sur sur
la data qui peut être fait de façon très
utile voilà en back middle office de
l'ensemble de ses plateformes entre et
celles qui sont opérés au sein de
l'audiovisuel public et ça je crois que
il ya des expériences dans toutes les
entreprises et alina par définition
puisque on gère 80 pétaoctets de données
et de métadonnées
on est là aussi dans un champ de
coopération tout à fait intéressant à
développer dans les années qui viennent
me libérer je croyais une dernière
question de claude kern
oui très rapidement donc c'est une
question qui s'adresse pas directement à
madame r note une question et il peut
être aussi un peu puisque c'est la
période des des des voeux je vais
commencer par le veut puisque david un
solide m'a pris ma question sur le sport
moi c'est la culture géant grand regret
j'aimerais bien revoir un jour au
théâtre ce soir 2,99 par mois vous aurez
tout sur madeleine
je parlais de regin a à sortir de
l'ornière de yako vide
je parle de france si vous appréciez
naturellement une carte d'abonnement qui
rendra cette offre gratuite les six
premiers mois
merci gratuit tous les vendredis soirs
sur l'a5 d'accord il très bien voilà
donc mon voeu est déjà exaucé merci par
contre moi je voudrais rebondir sur des
questions qui ont été abordées et où je
trouve que la réponse n'a pas été
apportée
ça concerne
de ce qu'on retrouve dans le projet de
qom c'est-à-dire l'accélération de la
régionalisation de france 3 pour en
faire 13 chaînes locales
alors est-ce que france 3 est prête à
cela sur le terrain et surtout quel est
le devenir des anciennes chaînes je
parlais de france 3 paris ile de france
france 3 pays basque france 3 alsace
pour ne citer que celles-là des chaînes
auxquelles nos télés ce pacte
spectateurs sont très attachés alors
c'est vrai que vous avez raison j'ai pas
répondu à cette question est pourtant
c'est un des sujets peut-être les plus
importantes du du plan de travail de
france télévisions qui est cette
inversion du modèle de france 3 ça
repose beaucoup sur les attentes de nos
téléspectateurs qui se renforce
d'ailleurs de consultation citoyenne en
consultation citoyenne on voit que plus
le monde se complexifie plus ils ont
besoin d'avoir une vision du monde qui
va du très très haut très loin donc il
s'agit pas de transformer france 3 en
chaîne qui ne parlent que du local bien
entendu un mais en des chaînes qui parle
et du local et de et de ndioum et de la
france et du monde en fait donc donc
avec cette perspective de champ parce
que les gens aussi disent au fond deux
choses d'abord il se reprit ne se voit
pas représentés suffisamment à la
télévision et donc parler des zones
rurales des agriculteurs des petites
villes des périphéries convoi - la
télévision c'est important parce qu'ils
ont besoin qu'on parle de leur
territoire de leurs difficultés et aussi
ils ont besoin qu'on parle de de toute
l'énergie qui assure les différents
territoires dire des initiatives
d'ailleurs vous avez remarqué que sur le
nouveau trésor de la ii il ya une
nouvelle rubrique qui s'appelle
évidemment j'ai un trou de mémoire sur
le nom de la rubrique mais qui j'ai une
relation une idée pour la france et qui
montrent en fait une initiative locale
absolument génial qu'on transpose pas
forcément de reproduire à l'échelle
internationale mais qui montre la
vitalité une idée géniale ici ou là bon
c'est ce que françois aussi va chercher
à faire a montré à la fois les
difficultés et aussi les initiatives
d'individus de collectivités
d'associations qui sont quand même
incroyable et exemplaire voilà alors
pour faire ça on n'a pas de moyens
supplémentaires on a même des moyens en
baisse 1 je voulais dit on à une baisse
des effectifs qui est quand même très
très conséquente mais à l'intérieur de
cette baisse des effectifs on va pas du
tout les amis de la même manière sur
france 3 et sur le reste du groupe
même si france 3 les autres maires c'est
plus de la moitié des effectifs du
groupe
quand même donc
voilà on a des moyens plus modernes de
fabriquer de la télévision aujourd'hui
on en a l'expérience france 3 corse
fabrique une chaîne via stèle avec les
moyens de france 3 corse et plus
récemment on a fabriqué à la demande et
sous l'impulsion du conseil régional une
chaîne de plein exercice s'appelle noah
en nouvelles aquitaine donc si on a déjà
des savoir faire à l'intérieur de notre
maison dé manière de faire qui nous
permettent de construire ce qu'on a fait
encore ce qu'on a fait un noir ailleurs
sur le territoire
on a fait une approche dogmatique parce
que si on fait des chaînes régionales et
je reviendrai après sur la granularité 1
si on fait des chaînes régionales c'est
parce qu'on peut penser que la région
hôte france a pas avoir tout à fait la
même vision des choses que la région
paca et c'est pas gênant est d'ailleurs
tant mieux après tout la question et
c'est ce qu'on est en train de caler
sait quelle est la bonne graine une
arrêtez vous parliez des de ce qu'on
appelle les antennes locales qui ont
évidemment toute leur place sur une
chaîne régionale et notre notre plan de
marche qui comprend notamment les
matinales que nous faisons avec radio
france sociaux des échelles qui sont pas
celles de la région administrative donc
ce qu'on imagine nous c'est treize
chaînes régionales mais qui peuvent par
moments de la journée
déjà en commençant le matin beaucoup
plus fils parce qu'il n'ya pas 13
matinale à terme france bleu il y en a
donc on imagine qu'on peut être à 44 sur
les matinales sur les éditions
d'information on n'est déjà pas très
sonné à 24 donc continuer à être un 24
en édition d'information est en fait en
fonction des sujets trouver des
granularité qui vont du plus proche ou
au plus loin et puis investir d'autres
champs on parlait tout à l'heure du
sport des grandes compétitions qui ont
des droits exorbitants
il ya aussi beaucoup de compétitions qui
sont libres de droit ont fait
l'expérience sur nos à des compétitions
locales qui mériterait d'être captés et
de transmises en direct sur précisément
ces chaînes régionales il ya énormément
de vivacité culturelle dans les
territoires les festivals les
représentations qui mériterait aussi
d'être repris sur sur ses chaînes donc
entre l'information qui est quand même
le coeur de la tente des téléspectateurs
au sens large
l'actualité et puis l'actualité sportive
la qualité culturelle on voit que là on
a quand même un terreau extrêmement
riche et qu'on fait que aux je pense
qu'on est capable de
de porter auprès auprès de nos publics
pardonnez moi et je vais pas retenir
plus longtemps mais je me rends compte
que j'ai oublié une question de
catherine qui était pas totalement
inutile parce que justement non très
important de catherine morin dessailly
ça parlait d'europe et ça parlait de
jeunesse parce qu'il me semble que on
vient de parler de proximité mais c'est
vrai aussi que notre jeunesse européenne
celle du co vis du chômage des attentats
et elle est d'ailleurs en moi en
souffrance un peu partout elle doit
faire l'objet de toutes nos attentions
alors arte travail bien sûr sur ces
questions mais nous on vient de
remporter un appel d'offres avec la dot
chevet le dans le cadre du traité d'aix
la chapelle pour construire une offre
pour les jeunes européens une offre
multilingue le projet pilote est décliné
en six langues et qui va permettre aux
jeunes de produire d'échanger dans
différentes langues sur des thématiques
qui les intéressent que ça ait du
changement climatique au travail à la
vie amoureuse aux études etc
et c'est une façon comme toujours dans
tout ce qu'on lance de lutter contre les
manipulations et les uns fox parce qu'à
peu près tout ce qu'on fait finalement
en faisant de la bonne info de confiance
et certifier c'est le premier rempart
aux manipulations donc je voulais juste
dire que on en avait parlé avec petter
line beauchamp et ambitionner par la
commission culturelle et donc on a
remporté l'appel d'offres en novembre et
le projet pilote sera lancé en mars au
moment du sommet franco allemand
voilà si important pour toute dernière
question de max brisson nassi président
et ce sera court le message est lancé
en langage corporel par le président
sera court et c'est pas une question ou
plutôt message en complément de ce que
vient de dire tel code cannes et pour
rebondir sur vos propos madame r note le
je partage totalement ce que vous avez
dit sur la proche des télévisions
locales et régionales
j'approuve totalement en tant qu'élu
n'est enquêteurs sénateurs nouvelle qui
tu es ce que vous avez dit sur la
qualité du travail fait par noah mais
dans ces grandes régions et la nouvelle
aquitaine en particulier à la taille de
l'autriche nécessite encore plus
granularité dont vous avez parlé aussi
une approche locale
excusez moi le pays basque ce n'est pas
la creuse et c'est la même région
d'où la nécessité absolue de ces
télévisions locales surtout les sortes
et des territoires à forte identité et
surtout sur des territoires qui par
ailleurs peuvent avoir des langues à
paris en appel régional et doullens d'où
la nécessité absolue d'avoir cette bonne
échelle ce bond calage en termes
d'échelle que les forfaits en régionale
que je peux comprendre ma vie j anime en
ce doute sur ces régions décider sur un
coin de table ni à l'elysée et dont je
ne suis pas sûr qu'elles passeront le
siècle mais céleste la maille que vous
avez décidé de prendre ça n'enlève pas
de la pertinence à la maille locale qui
est elle est inscrite en une histoire
qui passera certainement le siècle alors
je vous remercie de cette intervention
et moi puisque les voeux sont encore
ouverts vous pouvez vraiment nous aider
sur ce sujet parce qu'aujourd'hui
sachez que la télévision elle est reçue
par les français principalement via les
box des opérateurs et il n'y a aucune
obligation aujourd'hui pour les
opérateurs à transmettre les chaînes
régionales au maillage que vous indiquez
donc il ya beaucoup de local aujourd'hui
que nous produisons qui ne sont pas vu
par les téléspectateurs
donc dans le projet de loi audiovisuel
d'ailleurs on avait beaucoup insisté
pour qu'apparaissent cette obligation
faite aux opérateurs de transmettre la
bonne my parce que on pourra faire
toutes les télés du monde à la tête là
toutes les échelles si c'est pas
transmis voilà ça n'existera pas ça
n'arrivera pas aux téléspectateurs donc
on a un vrai sujet de
voilà d'arriver jusqu'aux
téléspectateurs via les box et ça là
dessus c'est de l'ordre du législatif
nous on peut pas contraindre on discute
on discute mais bon on est en position
de faiblesse
on ne peut pas les contraindre à le
faire certains opérateurs le font mais
pas tous donc ça si vous pouviez nous
aider là dessus je pense que ça nous
aiderait vraiment adapté cette maille
pertinentes comme vous le voulez indiqué
bon je suis à moitié basque alors
évidemment je compense que vous voulez
dire pour pour avoir même si on a une
organisation par 13 des moments où on va
être différent au pays basque ou dans
les landes
par exemple il ya écoutez nous sommes
arrivés au terme de cet échange
évidemment nous vous remercions les uns
et les autres je crois que vos regards
croisés qui sont on l'a bien vu sur
claude à donges est pas déjà un artiste
rapidement alors avant quand il s'est
lié de moi qu'il s'agit
oui oui oui oui oui bonjour a tous un
gilet très vite monsieur le président je
n'oublie pas de faire des voeux à tous
chacun part avec mes 29 degrés au pays
je suppose que ça doit vous faire
sourire je vous demanderais s'est très
rapidement la dame et aux notes et lui
dire que que si je ne suis pas un sujet
que je me rappelle tout le débat autour
de la ferme tuned france ô
avec l'objectif de rendre plus visible
le monde une trame arena semble sûre à
100 de l'audiovisuel national
alors si on ne peut pas aujourd'hui
faire un bilan parce qu'il est trop tôt
vous pouvez vous nous fait rapidement
1.1 point le point d'étape
où en est-on exactement sur cette
volonté de rendre plus visible ce ce
monde ultra marins
merci de votre question monsieur le
sénateur c'est un sujet qui est très
important pour nous qui est donc on a en
plus dû comme impact de visibilité des
outre mer qui est une sorte de com en
soi puisqu'il comporte une quinzaine
d'objectifs et nous suivons l'avancement
de ses objectifs au travers d'un comité
de suivi composé de représentants du
ministère de la culture de la dg milk de
deux sénateurs deux
deux députés et nous faisons donc en
fait un point sur ce suivi à peu près
tous les trous tous les trois mois au 3
ou 4 mois environ
donc le dernier je crois doit dater de
septembre donc je pense qu'on aura un
point de sur ce pacte de suivi très
précis donc on compte par exemple le
nombre de sujet dans les éditions
d'information qui ont traité de sujets
ultramarins
on compte le nombre de premières parties
de soirées qui ont traité d'un sujet que
ce soit une fiction un documentaire un
magazine ultra marins etc etc
sur tous ces indicateurs on est bien
aujourd'hui ça veut pas dire qu'on n'a
pas encore des progrès à faire on a
encore des progrès à faire mais disons
qu'on est sur la pente d'amélioration
très net et donc on continue à
travailler dans ce dans ce domaine
certains m'ont du comité de suivi mais
ça je voudrais pas parler à leur place
nous ont dit la dernière fois que ça
commençait à se voir dire y voyait en
regardant nos éditions d'information en
regardant nos antennes que oui on
on prenait le soin de traiter les sujets
ultramarins à la bonne vitesse qui
n'était pas le cas auparavant
je me souviens des de mayotte ya pas si
longtemps il y avait des tremblements de
terre on a mis quinze jours avant
d'aborder ce sujet alors que c'était
majeur pour les mahorais envoyez donc
bon ce réflexe là de mettre au même
niveau tout ce qui se passe que ce soit
dans les départements les territoires
les régions où paris ça ça commence à ça
commence à s'acquérir et les premières
parties de soirées aussi on a on tourne
beaucoup de fictions sur place on a
renouvelé nos engagement d'investir dans
des productions qui sont ultra marines
donc basées outre mer
et puis nos chaînes ultramarines les
premières sont toujours aussi puissante
et nous avons déployé
c'est un engagement du pack le la
plateforme outre-mer la première c'était
en juin à la sortie du premier
confinement qui fait déjà une bien
meilleure audience que les offres
numériques antérieures donc voilà on est
on est lancés dans ce pack de visibilité
et évidemment on pourra vous faire un
point mais on le fait ça chez en comité
de suivi tous les tous les trimestres
3 février le procès elle 3 février
merci on va s'arrêter là donc en vous
remerciant les uns et les autres de la
clarté de vos réponses et ses regards
croisés que vous portez sur les sujets
qui sont les vôtres vous avez compris
mais vous le savez que notre commission
est très attentive et évidemment depuis
de nombreuses années et continuera de
l'être aux questions de le diviser le
public mais nous prononcerons des mois
quelques jours sur sur les com et au
delà bien sûr cesser ces contrats notre
suivi et notre volonté de vous
accompagner et sur ces sujets là est
bien sûr très très forte vous avez même
but que ici vous pouviez rêver ce qui
n'était pas forcément ce à quoi vous
attendiez en arrivant c'est peut-être
d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on n'a pas invité
l'état parce que - vous pouviez rêver
plus librement donc merci à chacun
d'entre vous une bonne soirée voilà pour
cette table ronde que vous avez pu
suivre sur notre antenne
n'hésitez pas à lire les articles de
réactions sur notre site
voyez à l'adresse qui s'affiche
www.publicsenat.fr c'est la fin de cette
émission merci à vous d'avoir suivi très
bonne sur des programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires
[Musique]
parlement hebdo c'est le rendez vous de
l'actualité parlementaire
chaque semaine autour d'un député ou
d'un sénateur nous décryptons les temps
forts à l'assemblée et au sénat
les projets de loi les meilleurs des
éditions les débats dans l'hémicycle
s'est sur lcp et public sénat parlement
hebdo
aujourd'hui à 17h30 sur public sénat
cette semaine dans les vendredis de
l'histoire le film l'abolition seconde
partie le ravisseurs demandent une
rançon
sinon et eu l'enfant s'il le fait vous
pensez pas que ce crime mérite la mort
la peine de mort n'a aucune vertu
dissuasive
cet homme c'est ce qu'ils risquent et il
le fait quand même derrière lui pris la
foule un appui mais je ne sais pas si
avec tout le monde alors vous l'aimez
votre frère pour patrick henry n'ont pas
de grâce à espérer c'est des jurés et
deux seuls que d'étendre à sa vie vous
avez la parole
si vous votez comme monsieur l'avocat
général vous le demande je vous ai dit
vous demeurez seul avec votre décision
à la question existe-t-il des
circonstances atténuantes en faveur de
l'accusé
la réponse est oui l'abolition seconde
partie ce soir à 22h sur public sénat
vivement qu'on ne voit plus ce logo
cette appli personne n'a envie de la
subir
alors s'il vous plaît aidez nous à nous
en débarrasser comme en plus vous êtes
nombreux à l'utiliser plus elle est
efficace contre le virus et donc plus
vite elle disparaîtra vous êtes déjà
plus de 10 millions à avoir téléchargé
tous sentis cogite
ceci est un message du gouvernement
[Musique]
je
très heureuse de vous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle émission bonjour chez
vous c'est votre rendez vous quotidien
avec l'actualité politique au plus près
de chez vous grâce à nos partenaires de
la presse quotidienne régionale des
télévisions locales et des indés radios
nous sommes ensemble pendant une heure
et demie est au menu du jour nous serons
tous placés sous couvre-feu dès demain
18h et ce pour au moins 15 jours c'est
ce qu'a annoncé hier jean castex la
situation est maîtrisée mais fragile a
dit le premier ministre en raison
notamment de la présence sur le
territoire du vary en britannique
bonne nouvelle néanmoins il n'y a pas eu
de flambées épidémiques pendant les
fêtes de fin d'année on va revenir sur
toutes ces annonces du premier ministre
avec le sénateur centriste de l'essonne
vincendo là il est avec nous ce matin
donc nos moeurs l'invité politique c'est
clémentine autain la députée la france
insoumise de la seine saint denis elle
est également candidate aux régionales
en île de france
et puis toutes les semaines vous le
savez nous allons à votre rencontre
suivent l'actualité dans nos régions
cette semaine vous l'avez vue nous
étions dans le pas-de-calais fortement
impacté par le bric site
notre journaliste jérôme rabier j'ai un
brave viendra nous faire le bilan de ces
semaines et puis enfin dans le club des
territoires on reviendra bien sûr sur
cette conférence de presse de jean
castex on sera en direct avec le maire
de metz françois grosdidier il a reçu
hier dans sa ville jean castex et
olivier ferrand
les élus locaux sont ils désormais plus
associés où il posera la question et on
verra tout ça dans le club mais avant
cela voici les autres d'information de
ce vendredi 15 janvier 300
mille deux cent seize personnes
vaccinées contre le coc vide
dès lundi on entrera dans une nouvelle
phase de vaccination pourront se faire
vacciner les plus de 75 ans ainsi que
les personnes présentant des pathologies
à haut risque sept centres seront
répartis sur le territoire
ce sont les annonces d'olivier ferrand
hier il maintient son objectif d'un
million de personnes vaccinées d'ici la
fin du mois
jean castex rencontre ce matin les
organisations étudiantes hier il a
exprimé sa préoccupation face au profond
sentiment d'isolement et aux vraies
difficultés pédagogiques des étudiants
ce sont ses mots
il a annoncé que les premières années
pourrait reprendre par demi groupes les
travaux dirigés dans leurs universités
et ce dès le 25 janvier et puis
lancement d'une consultation citoyenne
sur l'avenir de la nouvelle calédonie
dont les résultats seront rendus publics
fin mars le sénat qui s'empare aussi du
sujet une mission spécifique présidée
par gérard larcher sera constituée à la
fin du mois
[Musique]
et on débute donc avec les sénateurs du
joueur élu de l'essonne siège dans le
groupe union centriste bonjour personne
le jour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
ce matin on va bien sûr commencer par
ces annonces
hier de jean castex est la principale
annonce c'est que on sera tous placés
sous couvre feu dès demain 18h et ce
pour une durée d'au moins quinze jours
plus de différenciation plus de terriers
de territorialisation comment vous avez
jugé cette annonce à ce que c'est la
bonne pour vous on veut ut contre
l'effet apéro à priori comme si après 18
heures on ne faisait que des apéros donc
moi je suis je suis un peu surpris que
j'étais déjà surpris au printemps pour
premier confinement que le premier mois
on ne fasse pas distinction entre les
territoires je pouvais le comprendre
mais au bout d'un mois quand on connaît
la circulation du virus est et où il est
présent c'était facile comme de fer
distinction helayel faste hier jean
castex olivier verrons nous expliquer
que désormais la dynamique est à l'ouest
alors que les cas étaient jusqu'à
maintenant élevée à l'est est ce que du
coup c'est l'âge où parler du printemps
alors maintenant maintenant bien sûr ça
augmente un peu plus à l'ouest parce
qu'ils n'avaient pas pratiquement pas
donc il n'y a pas beaucoup c'est vrai
que ça augmente forcément un petit peu
plus moi j'aime pas qu'il s'est donnée
qui changent en permanence et l'absence
de transparence qui existent aujourd'hui
on manque de données alors après on nous
demande que qu'est ce qu'il faudrait
faire
mais ce qu'il faudrait faire c'est déjà
anticipé et sur la campagne de
vaccination mais je considère qu'on n'a
pas du tout anticipé qu'est ce que le
premier ministre a fait depuis trois
mois
qu'est ce que ces hauts fonctionnaires
ont fait depuis trois mois si ce n'est
préparé une campagne de vaccination va
revenir sur cette question là assure que
rien n'est préparé donc on n'anticipe
rien on nous parle à un moment donné des
réanimations qu'ils étaient
plein à craquer qui n'en pouvait plus
maintenant c'est le nombre de cas
positifs mais on nous parle pas d assam
automatique
on nous dit pas combien il ya de
personnes qui n'ont pas de symptômes
avec le virus avec des traces de virus
donc vous savez cette absence de
transparence moi je n'aime pas du tout
et je considère alors il y en a qui
considère qu'on en fait pas c'est moi je
considère je voulais déjà dit qu'on en
fait trop et cela veut dire qu'il
n'aurait pas fallu étendre le couvre-feu
pour vous et hier moi je pense pas sur
tout le territoire
non non je pense que ça va il aurait dû
garder les mairies travaillent à l'inps
années n'ont absolument pas démontré je
suis désolé même avec les conférences de
presse du premier ministre mais ce n'est
pas démontré que le passage à 18h a
vraiment ralenti le virus sais c'est pas
quelque chose qui est démontré
scientifiquement donc aujourd'hui
jean-pierre exit le conseil scientifique
de cycle et en effet qu un effet
couvre-feu 18h sur l'épidémie hilti n'y
croyais pas ils disent ils disent bon
voilà maintenant
moi j'ai lu aussi d'aider les
scientifiques qui disaient le contraire
donc cole qui disait que c'était pas
prouver donc maintenant moi je crois que
un élargissement sur tout le territoire
malheureusement quoi je ne pense pas que
ça soit nécessaire
alors on est en pointe en europe parce
que personne ne faire un couvre-feu à
18h en europe
donc bien sûr il ya des confinement et
les confinements totori adecco finement
partiel tout le monde ne fait pas la
même chose contrairement à ce qui nous
est dit donc ans au printemps on a été
les plus sévères les plus strictes et
les plus longs dans le confinement c'est
le cd1 organisation de 37 pays qu'il a
dit c'est pas c'est pas vincent delahaye
qui le dit donc moi je veux bien qu'on
soit toujours en pointe
c'est une épidémie qui est embêtant de
c'est vrai qu'ils mais qui ne touche pas
tout le monde je sais pas combien sur
les 65000 ou ce soixante dix mille morts
que l'on a
combien il y en a qui ont moins de 50
ans vous le savez vous qu il y avait 35
mille morts vous savez combien y en
avait moins de 50 ans moins de 200 ça
veut dire que le virus n'est pas
dangereux pour tout le monde
contrairement à ce que dit ce qu'a dit
le président de la république ce virus
mais qu'est ce qu'on fait ils ont plus
de 50 ans que je veux dire que j'ai me
dire ce que je ferais moi si j'étais au
gouvernement et si je devais décider de
la stratégie de vaccination
parce que si vous pouvez me résumer en
trois phrases la stratégie de
vaccination du gouvernement
je serais très heureux de l'entendre
parce que je trouve une sacrée
cacophonie sur le sujet moi je pense
qu'il faut vacciner bien sûr en priorité
les personnes à risque plus les
soignants donc ça doit nous faire une
quinzaine de millions de personnes
approximativement on aurait dû être prêt
dès la fin de l'année
quelle que soit la date de disponibilité
des vaccins
on devait être prêt à voir des centres
de vaccination par département je ne
comprends même pas qu'on est on n'est
pas préparé ce centre de vaccination que
la circulaire du premier ministre
n'arrive au préfet que le 12 janvier je
suis très très surpris et je pense que
d'ici fin mars
on aurait dû et on devrait pouvoir
vacciner toutes les personnes à risque
et tous les soignants
une fois que vous avez vacciner toutes
les personnes à risque et tous les
soignants vous le pensez qu'on a les
doses pour vacciner toutes les
personnels les aura on les aura on les
aura normalement à fin mars
je pense qu'il y aura une autre
normalement trentaine de millions de
doses de vaccins et ce qui devrait
permettre de vacciner une quinzaine de
millions de personnes à condition d'être
organisée à condition d'avoir anticipé
ce qui n'a pas été le cas et donc famars
normalement on doit pouvoir lever toutes
les barrières et et rétablir toutes les
libertés qui nous ont été supprimés
parce que depuis un an on vit quand même
avec de sacrées pour 30 sur nos libertés
vous dénoncez ce manque de transparence
est ce que du coup vous demander un
nouveau débat devant le parlement sur
cette stratégie vaccinale avec peut-être
cette fois un vote n'y avait pas une
voix thomas de décembre à l'écouté de
toute façon je moi je considère toujours
que leur gouvernement ne se sert pas
assez du parlement et que alors certains
pensent que les parlementaires sont des
décideurs en fait nous sommes pas des
décideurs
le seul élu qui décide dans ce pays
c'est le président de la république et
ensuite les élus en fait ne décide pas
grand chose on né peut associer on a peu
d'informations et c'est vrai que bon ça
touche sans doute pas le grand public
mais pour nous c'est très frustrant
parce que on aimerait être plus acteur
que on est aujourd'hui on est un peu
spectateur moi je sais pas mal de
personnes que je rencontre qui me
demandent à bas en tant que sénateur on
devait avoir des informations
privilégiées
qu'est ce qui va se passer en réalité on
n'a pas plus d'informations que le
citoyen et on a souvent des informations
à travers les médias travers les
journaux ce qu'on entend ici ou là mais
on en a pas plus il ya un débat qui va
avoir lieu en revanche c'est celui sur
le prolongement de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire qui va arriver au sénat la
semaine du 25 janvier
actuellement le lion de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire il court jusqu'au 16 février
gouvernement souhaite le faire aller
jusqu'au 1er juin est ce que vous y êtes
favorable est ce que vous le vôtre est
non puisque je n'ai pas voté les
précédents je ne vais pas voter c'est
prorogation je pense que l'état
d'urgence permanence c'est pas une bonne
chose
ensuite je suis très critique sur la
face au tour tourne à gérer cette crise
donc je dis pas que c'est facile je dis
pas que de façon une crise c'est jamais
facile quel que soit son ampleur
et là c'est vrai que c'est quelque chose
qui n'est pas facile à gérer mais je ne
suis pas d'accord sur pas mal de
décisions qui ont été prises par le
gouvernement notamment le fait
effectivement de prendre des décisions
sur tout le territoire quel que soit le
niveau de circulation du virus et donc
moi je ne voterai pas cette prorogation
de l'état d'urgence alité on va
continuer à parler d annoncer qui en
fait tu donnes des pleins pouvoirs au
premier ministre pour décider sans
passer par le parlement donc en fait on
se dessaisit le parlement se dessaisit
de ses prérogatives et des possibilités
éventuellement vous donner son point de
vue donc je moi je ne suis pas favori
mais ça on va continuer à voir les
annonces puisque et évidemment ça fait
réagir les sénateurs comment on va voir
ça avec notre journaliste parlementaire
quentin calmer
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour vincent de l'air bonjour
hélas non ce qui a fait réagir bien sûr
c'était cette extension du couvre-feu de
18h à tout le territoire et ce dès
samedi
oui tout à fait les sénateurs ont bien
vu un nouveau tour de vis en france qui
se justifie dans certains départements
dont 10 à certains sénateurs elle est la
réaction de loïc hervé il a dit mais
quel dommage d'abandonner une logique de
différenciation territoriale en fonction
d'éléments objectifs et rationnels la
culture jacobine est une maladie
incurable deuxième réaction je voulais
vous montrer c'est celle de l'unique
sénateur du rassemblement national
stéphane ravier lui il a ironisé sur ce
couvre-feu à 18 heures il a dit et
pourquoi pas 15 heures jusqu'à quand
pour quel résultat
ces mesures absurdes font de nombreuses
victimes dont on ne parle pas
la crise économique et social est à son
comble la dette explose il faut en finir
avec la mise sous cloche de notre pays
à gauche qu'elle souhaitait les
réactions quentin à gauche on a vu ce
petit résumé d'esther benbassa je
voulais vous le proposez castex parle ce
soir pour les scream à sion alors
vaccination au compte gouttes mais
couvre-feu de 18h dans toute la france
allez comprendre
bonjour la hausse des dépressions et
conséquences économiques voilà vous avez
tout le panel et on finit sur les
étudiants fantômes une ministre toujours
aussi peu convaincante
hélas a dit la sénatrice écologiste et
je voulais finir en parlant justement de
la souffrance des étudiants et qui a été
aussi un pointé du doigt par un deuxième
tweet à gauche celui du sénateur fabien
gay regarder il a dit détresse
psychologique décrochage scolaire
difficultés financières de plus en plus
forte on ne peut pas les laisser
indéfiniment confiné un plan d'urgence
sociale et scolaire doit être décrétée
pour les étudiants étudiantes avec ce
hashtag étudiants fantômes qui revient
de plus en plus vincent delhaize sur
cette question des étudiants vous si
vous êtes inquiet de la situation en ce
moment bah écoutez moi je cherchais
toujours pensé que depuis le début que
le remède que nous qu'on nous proposait
était pire que le mal et on fera le
bilan à la fin parce que en fait
toujours un bilan à la fin des courses
et on verra si on a été nettement
meilleur que les autres dans la lutte
contre la pandémie et quelles
conséquences économiques et sociales
et y compris aussi sanitaire
a pu avoir non pas le virus parce qu'on
dit toujours c'est la faute du virus non
c'est pas la faute du lot c'est la faute
de la façon dont on réagit par rapport
au virus etc les décisions qui sont
prises
donc effectivement moi je pense qu on a
sacrifié quand même beaucoup la jeunesse
les étudiants aujourd'hui ont beaucoup
de difficultés il y en a beaucoup qui
vivaient aussi de petits travaux qui
n'existe plus aujourd'hui en tout cas
qui ne sont plus proposés et puis
ensuite effectivement faire des cours à
distance
ça va un temps mais au bout d'un moment
on s'use et c'est vrai que détresse
psychologique
plein de choses comme ça et des
pressions tout cela on sait très bien
que ça augmente donc moi je suis je suis
très très inquiet effectivement des
conséquences non seulement économique
parce que les gens peuvent dire
économique c'est le business beau s'il y
en a un peu moi c'est pas très grave
mais on aurait dit et ses conséquences
sociales et humaines qu'il y a derrière
tout cela
donc il est temps de sortir de cette
phase effectivement de mise sous cloche
en tout cas moi je partage pas mal des
redirections que vous avez cités je
pense qu'il faut il faudrait comme se
préoccuper un peu plus de notre jeunesse
et nous étudions aujourd'hui de l'état
dans lequel il se trouve
merci content de vincent de l'est on va
parler quand même en d'économies bruno
le maire a pris la parole hier aussi un
le ministre de l'économie il ya des
nouvelles modalités pour le fonds de
solidarité
il ya un allongement du délai pour
rembourser les prêts garantis par l'état
vous suivez particulièrement vous ces
dossiers qu est ce que vous avez pensé
de ces mesures de bruno le maire
écoutez il ya pas mal de mesures qui
sont nécessaires indispensables
alors après ce qu'on en fait trop ou pas
assez c'est toujours un débat je pense
qu on a fait trop pêche
en fait je n'en sais rien honnêtement je
pense qu'on était moins bien préparés
que d'autres pays d'autres pays qui
dénonce des situations financières et
économiques meilleurs que nous et ce qui
leur a permis comme l'allemagne de
mettre beaucoup plus d'argent sur la
table finalement que nous avons pu le
faire nous finalement on s'endette
énormément on a un endettement qui a dû
augmenter en deux ans de 400 milliards
et en fait il ya 100 milliards de
deux plans de relance vous voyez un peu
là on sort des 2 400 milliards pour
propres pour finalement donner 100
milliards moi je pense qu'on fait quand
même pas mal mais l'argent ne suffit pas
et on le voit avec la détresse des
restaurateurs aujourd'hui il ya pas mal
de restaurateurs qui n'en peuvent plus
parce que ils ont besoin de travailler
ils ont besoin de travailler recevoir de
l'argent c'est bien mais ça ne remplace
pas l'activité rester chez soi au bout
d'un moment ça pèse quand même pas mal
donc moi je pense qu'il faut remettre
permettre aux gens de retravailler avec
des conditions comme on en avait qui
étaient quand même des conditions qui
bien sûr il y avait sans doute eu des
exceptions mais globalement les
les mesures étaient prises pour qu'ils
aient pas trop de propagation du virus
mais juste un mot sur les sur les
finances publiques
vous avez entendu bruno le maire dire
que le pire est devant nous dire que ça
sera un défi d'atteindre les 6 % de
croissance qui était prévu par le
gouvernement vous êtes inquiet pour ses
finances publiques
bah ça fait un moment que je suis
inquiet sur les finances publiques sera
l'occasion de l'écrire puisque je
prépare un livre sur le sujet pour cette
année j'ai déjà écrit révolution fiscale
je vais écrire un ouvrage aussi sûr mais
que mes convictions budgétaire parce que
je pense que ça fait des années qu'on se
laisse aller et donc là on a
effectivement un dérapage considérable
qui est en partie due à la crise
effectivement encore en tout cas la
réaction à la crise mais qui est aussi
dû à laisser aller sur un certain nombre
de dépenses parce que contrairement à ce
qu'on nous annonce il ya pas que de la
relance ou du soutien
il ya aussi
des choses sur lesquelles on sait on a
laissé faire et on laisse aller dont on
dépense beaucoup beaucoup trop beaucoup
plus que ce qu'on peut alors c'est sans
doute bien aujourd'hui on se dit
l'argent est facile on nous prête
facilement et merci l'europe
d'ailleurs à ce sujet à la banque
centrale européenne on critique souvent
l'europe et là en l'occurrence on est
content de les avoir
ils nous prêtent beaucoup d'argent
certains disent on pourrait annuler la
dette mais allez expliquer ça aux
épargnants allemands aux épargnants
hollandais et autres chi chi chi qui
vont dire à bas la france elle dépense
et puis finalement leur annuler leurs
dettes et c'est nous qui payons et à un
moment donné ne s'est pas présentable on
va parler de deux sujets qui vous
concerne un scénar vincent de l'est
d'abord les autoroutes 1 je me rappelle
vous étiez le rapporteur de la
commission d enquête sur les autoroutes
vous avez rendu votre rapport il ya
quelques mois pointant notamment le
manque à gagner de l'état lors de la
privatisation des autoroutes vous
souhaitez une commission de suivi sur
ceux de ses des autoroutes pourquoi bah
écoutez on reproche souvent pas
uniquement sénat mais à pas mal de
personnes de faire des rapports qui ne
sont pas suivies d'effet donc moi ce que
je souhaite c'est pouvoir assurer un
suivi des recommandations qu'on a pu
émettre dans ce rapport qui ont été
globalement bien reçus à la fois par le
gouvernement mais aussi par le public et
on souhaite pouvoir savoir comment
comment on met en place ses
recommandations et comment le
gouvernement prend en main le dossier on
avait notamment sur lesquels sa mise en
place
comment effacer on n'en sait rien
je doute moi ce que je veux c'est
qu'elle se mette en place réellement
aujourd'hui je n'en sais strictement
rien j'ai envie que le gouvernement
aussi ouvre une table ronde pour
discuter de l' équilibre financier des
contrats de la rentabilité puisque c'est
toujours une discussion qui est sur la
table
nous on a on a fait des propositions sur
le sujet moi je souhaite et j'ai vu les
ministres a priori sont favorables à une
table ronde
donc je souhaite qu'on soit aussi
associés à cette table ronde de façon à
ce que dans les prochaines semaines
écoutez gens sérieux je n'en sais rien
encore une fois je suis pas ministre et
c'est au ministre de décider mais on
veut nous ici au sénat en tout cas
suivre ces commission denquête moi je
trouve ces commissions des requêtes sont
très utiles parce qu'elles permettent de
soulever pas mal de sujets mais est ce
vraiment utile si on en assure le suivi
et c'est la volonté du sénat d'assurer
ce suivi des commissions des requêtes et
des recommandations qu'on peut faire et
un mot sur un autre sujet c'est le
nucléaire civil a aussi vous souhaitez
travailler sur le sujet une proposition
de résolution pour une commission
denquête service voilà écoutez moi
j'aime bien les commissions des requêtes
c'est vrai et je pense que sur le
nucléaire civil c'est nécessaire parce
que aujourd'hui on y voit pas très clair
on ne sait pas quelle est la stratégie
de la france jusqu'en 2015 à peu près on
y voyait à peu près clair le nucléaire
était quand même une priorité
aujourd'hui on a l'impression que ça ne
l'est plus même si dans le plan de
relance il en a mis 480 millions mais
sur 100 milliards ça fait pas énormément
et si on veut à la fois décarbonés notre
économie et lui permettent de croître
je suis persuadé pour ma part qu'il faut
réinvestir fortement dans le nucléaire
qui est une des meilleures et l'énergie
que l'on puisse avoir des grains verts
c'est ce que veut faire le gouvernement
le gouvernement n'a pas encore annoncé
commandement s'assagit moi je pour moi
est un peu illisible aujourd'hui et je
pense qu'on est on n'est pas dans une
clarté sur les objectifs à la fois
pour réduire le réchauffement climatique
et aussi pour permettre à l'économie de
croître parce qu'il faut où il faut pas
de baisse du nucléaire dans la part de
ce qu'on appelle le mix énergétique
ah ben moi je pense que même il faut une
augmentation c'est dire qu'il faut une
augmentation du nucléaire puisque dans
le mix énergétique en fait il faut le
mix énergétique c'est l'ensemble des
énergies qui permettent de faire
fonctionner l'économie
aujourd'hui le principal carburant de
nos économies c'est ce sont les énergies
fossiles pétrole le gaz le charbon et on
sait que pour réduire les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre il faut réduire la
part de ces énergies fossiles pour les
réduire il faut augmenter l'électricité
et dans l'électricité
notre principal fournisseur c'est
l'énergie nucléaire civile
et c'est ça qu'il faut qui est une
énergie décarbonée qui est propre
donc il faut il faut la développer et
moi je souhaite qu'on fasse le point sur
ce dossier pour voir où en sont les
différents acteurs allez on va suivre
l'actualité dans nos régions avec nos
partenaires de la presse quotidienne
régionale on va aller à grenoble
retrouver lors marnais bonjour la merci
beaucoup d'être magique non vous êtes
journaliste justice au dauphiné et
vous allez nous parler d'un sujet fort à
lire dans le dauphiné c'est une longue
interview d'eva thomas qui est une
interview en dernière page c'est la
première victime d'inceste à parler à
visage découvert à la télévision à une
heure de grande écoute c'était en 1986
est une pionnière
oui oui oui la tomate qui habite à
grenoble elle est aujourd'hui âgé de 79
ans et en 1986 elle a courageusement
pris la parole à visage découvert à la
télévision et c'était là la première
victime dans cette affaire ça est en
fait si elle a parlé emma thomas c'était
parce qu'elle voulait vraiment que l'on
s'empare de ce sujet de société que les
choses évoluent que les choses changent
qu'on prête qu'on prenne conscience de
ce sujet parce que en fait j'ai s'est
rendu compte qu'elle était pas seuls que
plein d'autres femmes avaient vécu la
même chose qu'elle est d'ailleurs selon
les derniers sondages en 2010 s'il ya un
français sur 10 qui déclare avoir été
victime d'inceste et malgré cela elle a
l'impression qu'en fait c'est encore un
tabou dans la société donc c'est pour ça
qu'elle a qu'elles témoignent
aujourd'hui ces témoignages il est fort
pour ces raisons elle revient également
sur l'actualité du moment c'est ce livre
de camille kouchner et son
retentissement médiatique et sociétal
oui oui en fait au cours de l'entretien
elle m'a répété à plusieurs reprises que
c'était un lit vraiment nécessaire qu'il
fallait le lire que elle l'espère en
fait que le retentissement médiatique
qui l'a qui est liée notamment à la
personnalité d'olivier duhamel va
vraiment faire évoluer les choses
faire prendre conscience à la société du
problème qu'on rencontre et elle espère
aussi que les pouvoirs publics vont se
saisir en fait de l'occasion pour
modifier la loi en fait donc c'est
vraiment ce qu'elle appelle de ses voeux
et c'est pour ça qu'elle trouve ce livre
important quelle manière elle veut faire
évoluer la loi elle alors en fait comme
toutes les associations qui militent
pour qu'on en prenne conscience du fléau
de l'inceste dans la société
elle voudrait comprendre ces crimes
imprescriptibles qui étiez plus de
prescription et elle aimerait aussi
qu'on crie une loi spécifique pour les
mineurs parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est
encore la loi des majeures qui
s'applique
c'est à dire que
l'enfant ou l'adolescent doit encore
prouver qu'il n'ya pas eu contrainte
menace ou surprise où violences et les
associations à dix ça revient à dire à
l'enfant prouve que tu étais tu n'étais
pas consentant et à 10 et les victimes
de violence d'inceste elles disent mais
un enfant ne plus jamais être consentant
à n'importe quel âge en fait parce qu'il
est sous l'autorité de quelqu'un donc
avouer qu'on modifie la loi de cette
manière et cette interview fortin est à
lire dans la dernière page du dauphiné
libéré aujourd'hui avant de se quitter
alors un mot de la une quand même du
dauphiné libéré qui est consacrée
évidemment jean castex samedi on change
d'heure c'est le titre que vous avez
choisi oui oui oui en fait on a décidé
de faire un petit clin d'oeil au
changement d'heure sur la une du journal
et donc on traite ce sujet de manière
nationale donc parce que c'est un sujet
qui concerne tous les français qui va
impacter la vie de millions de personnes
et donc voilà on a décidé de traiter de
sujets avec une page dans le journal où
on a des décryptages des interviews on
revient sur les changements qui vont on
peut avoir lieu et comment comment ça va
nous impacter au quotidien et c'est à
lire aujourd'hui dans le dauphiné libéré
merci beaucoup merci lors d'avoir été
avec nous en direct ce matin un mot sur
le sujet n'ont parlé lors excusez moi
j'ai juste avant de façon un peu elle
rit ça veut dire qu'il faut prendre
l'apéro à 17 heures maintenant voilà
avec stanislas guérini si vous voulez
vous sur ce sujet évidemment qui a remis
en lumière un par ce livre de camille
kouchner et cette interview à lire dans
le dauphiné ça repose la question de l'
imprescriptibilité
de la loi
en tout cas de l'inceste est ce que pour
vous il faut changer la loi pour rendre
lancé écoutez c'est vrai que la
prescription
et est une vraie question sur ce sujet
puisque soit il ya une omerta complète
sur ces sur ces crimes et
il ya souvent une attend quand même
assez long entre les faits et le
révélations donc on peut se poser la
question
d'ailleurs même sur les violents sur les
viols aussi on peut mais il n'y a pas
forcément si cette longueur et c'est
cette durée entre les faits et leur
révélation
donc c'est vrai que pour moi le débat
mérite d'être posée et que l'on puisse
revenir sur la prescription ne
paraîtraient pas aberrant et on va
suivre l'actualité dans votre
département va regarder votre revue de
presse je suis avec quentin calme et
[Musique]
voilà qu'est ce qui se passe en descente
si content qu'il va tous nous dirons
comment se content avec l'appel de deux
villes d'essen en matière de vaccination
voilà ce sont deux communes de votre
département s'appelle bures sur yvette
et sainte geneviève des bois et on a vu
apparaître sur le facebook de ces
communes un message qui disait nous
avons besoin de recenser tous les
personnels soignants volontaires qui
pourrait assurer le fonctionnement d'un
centre de vaccination aux côtés de la
ville et donc on voit effectivement ces
communes et qui vont essayer d'être
comme cela candidate à l'obtention d'un
centre de vaccination sur leur
territoire pour l'heure on compte déjà
quatre centres de vaccination dans votre
département dans 91 corbeil-essonnes et
amp longjumeau orsay et juvisy pour
ouvrir une quinzaine de centres
supplémentaires il ya une course de ces
communes qui cherchent du personnel ça
vous ça vous savez vous quoi cette
concurrence parfois entre les communes
pour avoir ce personnel soignant enfin
je reviens à ce que j tout à l'heure je
suis effaré du monde d'anticipation sur
ces sujets depuis trois mois et on en
avait le temps de préparer les centres
de vaccination par département et de ne
pas provoquer effectivement une course
une course
la récupération de ces centres et puis
se pose la question de la réquisition
des personnels soignants et y compris
dans les hôpitaux
parce que dans les hôpitaux il ya du
personnel qui pourrait
vacciner si c'est une urgence et moi je
pense que c'est une urgence dans ces cas
là il faut que les personnes les
personnels qu'ils soient payés avec de
l'argent public puisse être
réquisitionnés pour vacciner sur trois
jours deux jours j'en sais rien de par
semaine mais il faut qu'on utilise quand
même les le personnel soignant des
hôpitaux pour pour vacciner en priorité
la priorité
écoutez comme choisi twitter moi ma
stratégie ce serait de vacciner toutes
les personnes à risque et tous les
soignants d'ici fin mars et ensuite de
lever toutes les barrières donc voilà un
moment donné il faut il faut prendre les
dispositions qui permettent d'arriver à
cet objectif
allez on parle de l'essonne dans les
échos vincent dhelin on parle
d'urbanisme à evry tout à fait evry qui
veut en finir avec l'urbanisme de dalles
vous savez c'est un urbanisme typique
années 70 on envoie voilà comme ça un
échantillon est donc la ville comme
projet de démolir cette dalle du
centre-ville ainsi que les passerelles
qui relie ce différend et quartier un
autre enjeu nous dit d'article c'est de
ramener la nature en ville qu'est ce que
vous en pensez c'est un projet vous
allez soutenir écoutez je ne suis pas
élu d'evry mais en tout cas je pense que
c'est une bonne direction à prendre pour
faire évoluer cette ville c'est vrai
qu'on en revient complètement de ces
d'urbanisme sur dalle où on séparait
finalement les flux les flux routiers
des flux piétonniers et en général
malheureusement s'est aperçu que ça tu
es quand même une partie de la vie dans
la commune
et puis ça ne favorise pas effectivement
les commerces et ça favorise par contre
peu soeur certains trafics au les jours
tranquilles et où il est plus difficile
d'intervenir donc massi dont j'ai été
maire pendant 22 ans n'est pas une ville
qui a été
construite comme ça une ville nouvelle
sur dalle mais je pense que c'est une
bonne idée d'essayer de faire évoluer
quant à la nature en ville beaucoup de
maires s'en préoccupe depuis maintenant
un bon moment c'est vrai que c'est
intéressant de mêler la nature et la
ville donc moi je suis je suis très
favorable à cette évolution
et on termine avec le parisien cette
jeune entrepreneuse de massy qui fait un
carton avec ses petites maisons écolos
voilà vous lisez vous avez été élu de
messi bien justement elle a commencé son
aventure entrepreneuriale dans un espace
de coworking de massy il s'agit d'anna
hackett siaap les ailes effectivement si
une entrepreneuse de 26 ans et avec son
associé ils conçoivent des petits de
petits habitats écologiques autonome en
énergie et socialement responsables ils
sont déjà à l'ouvragé pour livrer des
bus 2021 un mini-village étudiants à
evry courcouronnes ça c'est donc le
parisien et qui nous l'apprend la re
start up effectivement est donc née dans
un espèce de coworking belle réussite
saluée par le parisien est donc dans
votre commune c'est peut-être une fierté
de voir ces profils de jeunes qui se
lancent et qui arrive bien sûr bien sûr
il y en a beaucoup qui se lancent
aujourd'hui tous ne réussissent pas mais
il y en a quand même qui réussissent et
c'est vrai que une commune doit faire en
sorte de pouvoir favoriser ces
initiatives c'est ce qu'on a fait à
massy avec des espaces de coworking et
aussi avec les bureaux parce que on a
souvent des bureaux à massy en a
recueilli carrefour par exemple mais on
a aussi besoin de bureaux pour les
toutes petites entreprises et les pme
c'est ce qu'on a fait aussi parce que je
pense qu'il faut avoir un tissu
économique diversifié et c'est très bien
d'avoir cette réussite est de la mettre
en avant parce que ça peut pousser
d'autres à se lancer aussi je crois que
c'est l'avenir connais des jeunes
entreprenant et dynamique et merci
beaucoup merci
ce matin merci quentin tout à l'heure on
va recevoir dans deux minutes clémentine
autant député la france atomise la
seine-saint-denis qu'on dise est aux
régionales en île de france
mais d'abord on va regarder un extrait
de livre et vous c'est l'émission
littéraire de public sénat à voir ce
soir à 19 heures guillaume erner reçoit
le sociologue gérald bronner et
l'humoriste sophia aram tous deux
traites d'ouvragés sur le thème des tic
et des ouvrages sur le thème des
stéréotypes et on va écouter sophia aram
sur cette question vous allez voir c'est
grave mais drôle
[Musique]
au sortir des stéréotypes vous donner un
seul exemple issu de la vie courante par
exemple lorsqu'on s'interroge sur la
réalité de votre prénom c'est sofia ou
zafira vous pouvez pas imaginer le
nombre de fois on l'a posé cette
question parce que mon prénom c'est
sofia et je dois expliquer que c'est
parce que mon père aimait sophia loren
qui m'a appelé sociable mais parce que
les gens s'attendent pas à ce qu'une
fille d'origine marocaine s'appelle
vraiment sofia sauf que sofia smith est
un prénom marocain et après on s'en fout
je m'appelle sofia pourquoi j'aurais
changé de prénom
parce que d'après ses interlocuteurs il
faudrait que j'ai un prénom + arabisé
que je n'aurais pas assumer et que
j'aurai francisé pour m'intégrer
enfin tout ça et elle renvoie trop de
questions et et du mal à une fille
d'origine marocaine né à trappes et ce
qu'elle a des savoirs particulier ben
forcément on me demande si j'ai des
planchistes ont tracé un truc
lorsqu'on est un avocat qui habite
boulogne qu'est ce qu'on peut lui
répondre
s'il a les plans but mais c'est pas très
heureux non c'est pas bien c'est pas
bien je les fais une fois j'ai vraiment
j'aurais pas dû c'était pas très sympa
mais alors on s'interroge quand même et
sur cet intérêt pour les sérotypes de
tout temps par exemple les stéréotypes
sexistes aussi qu'il faut partie de vous
traiter sophia aram dans la question qui
tue parce que les humoristes vivent
quand même un peu de ces stéréotypes
oui mais après il ya la façon dont on
les traits cercle si on les met en avant
pour les démolir et pour les démonter
goethe intéressant mais moi ce qui me
dérange avec certaine forme d'humour
c'est quand on les prend frontalement et
qu'on est bassement raciste ou bassement
sexiste
[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
clémentine autain bonjour mon cher c'est
un coup d'être avec nous aux députés la
france insoumise la seine-saint-denis
candidate aux régionales en
ile-de-france on va en parler
vous êtes avec nous pendant 20 minutes
pour une interview en partenariat avec
la presse quotidienne régionale
représenté par fabrice veysseyre donc
bonjour fabrice bonjour au regard du
groupe les journaux régionaux de l'est
de la france on commence bien sûr
trémentines autun par 6 annonçant hier
de jean castex est principales annonces
on sera désormais tous sous couvre-feu à
partir de demain 18h couvre-feu qu'est
donc étendu à toute la france
jean castex parle de freinage préventif
est ce que vous soutenez cette mesure
coûte et on se retrouve dans une
situation absolument ubuesque et depuis
le début de la crise sanitaire parce que
ce qui frappe c'est pas simplement que
nous avons un gouvernement très libéral
sur le plan économique et qui nous a mis
dans la nasse pas simplement celui ci
paie les précédents avec les fermetures
de lits avec un manque de moyens par
exemple dans la recherche on sait que
toute la recherche scientifique qui
aurait dû être fait sur des virus de
type qu'ovide ont été impossibles à
mener parce qu'il n'y a pas eu
d'investissements publics je vais pas
faire toute la liste mais on le savait
on a appris que le gouvernement était en
plus autoritaire et maintenant chemin
faisant nous apprenons que nous avons en
prime un gouvernement qui est incapable
d'organiser d'organiser la production
des masques en capable d'organiser les
tests d'un point de vue logistique et
puis maintenant incapable de prévoir une
vaccination en temps et en heure
correctement donc c'est un jeu est
question mais sur le couvre-feu rimer ça
à voir
comprenez bien que ça à voir c'est à
dire que le gouvernement patine change
de stratégie ne sait pas comment faire
et a fait un choix de société
le choix de société qu'il a fait c'est
de faire primer l'économie qu'aux voyez
ce que je viens l'économique au stick
c'est à dire la logique de compétitivité
en fait tout ce qu'ils rendent dans les
normes néolibérale sur la vie sur la
façon de mieux préserver la vie
quotidienne des français leur santé mais
aussi on n'est pas là simplement pour
être des corps vivants
voyez ce que je veux dire n'est pas
simplement pour décor vieux on est pour
être d
vu qu'ils ont de la vie or la situation
devient dangereuse heures pour répondre
à votre question précise parce qu'on est
temps maintenant en ferme plus à 20h mai
à 18h moi j'ai toujours pas compris en
quoi ça l'est davantage nos projets nous
protéger et je pense que beaucoup de
français qui nous regardent ce matin se
pose la même question un confinement
protégerait davantage mais ce qui nous
protégerait davantage c'est d'avoir pris
d'autres mesures plus tôt et en
particulier sur les enjeux de
confinement nous nous proposons depuis
un moment qu'il y ait des rotations et
que par exemple le spectacle la culture
l'accès à la culture tout ce qui fait
partie du plaisir de la vie ne soit pas
confinés comme ça l'est aujourd'hui que
du point de vue c'est désolant pour vous
il faut rouvrir les cinémas les théâtres
les musées ce qu'il faut c'est des
règles sanitaires et d'éviter des lieux
trop dense et se protéger avec des
gestes barrières
voilà ça c'est fondamental et ça ça
s'organise il faut maintenant organiser
aussi la vaccination parce que le vaccin
même s'il fait polémique et je sais
aussi que le laisser la recherche du
vaccin dans un canot néolibérale ça ne
peut que créer des inquiétudes par
rapport à ce qu'on a ce qu'on voit là à
ce vaccin là mais c'est l'espoir pour
sortir de la pandémie
bon si on n'a pas confiance dans le
gouvernement dans sa capacité à
organiser la vaccination c'est un fiasco
depuis des semaines maintenant vous
voyez bien que cela ne prochaine alors
une fois on est est ce que c'est encore
un fiasco le gouvernement avait dit on
sera un million fin janvier là on est à
70 milles vaccinations par jour à peu
près en tout cas la dernière
est ce que vous dites on est quand même
en train de rattraper le retard est ce
que du coup on sera dans l'est on a pris
un retard considérable notamment parce
que le gouvernement ne s'est pas être
correct sur la logistique terre qu'il ne
sait pas organiser comment voulez vous
qu'on ait confiance
les aiguilles se sont perdus les fâcheux
c'est insensé zekkal vendine autant
est-ce que c'est pas venez quand même un
angle d'attaqué difficile pour vous
attaquer le gouvernement sur cette
question logistique quand on voit ce qui
se passe dans le reste de l'europe
notamment l'allemagne qui est tj le bon
élève au départ la gestion de la crise
aujourd'hui signifient ces soutiens
encore bien plus difficile qu'en france
est ce que finalement tous les
gouvernements mondiaux ne sont pas
confrontés à la même problématique à que
tous les gouvernements mondiaux soient
confrontés à une immense difficulté
c'est pas moi qui vais vous dire le
contraire et je suis pas en train de
vous dire
c'est facile c'est pas ça que je dis ce
que je dis c'est que les choix qui sont
faits correspondent à des choix de
société et donc je conteste par exemple
sur le monde culturel parce que je pense
que c'est un choix de société que
d'expliquer qu'on peut tout à fait aller
dans des complexes commerciaux le
week-end s'entasser mais par contre on
ne peut pas aller au cinéma avec un
mètre de distance ou au théâtre ou au
musée c'est un choix de société
et là par exemple en mettant le
couvre-feu à 18 heures c'est encore un
choix de société qui va payer un prix
fort par exemple le monde sportif
vous savez très bien que les les
activités sportives notamment pour les
enfants qui pouvaient encore avoir lieu
c'est en général plutôt dans ses
horaires la voilà donc on supprime
encore ça et moi je mets en garde jeudi
que la société que nous sommes en train
de fabriquer qui est une société de plus
en plus liberticides avec des choix qui
sont des choix qui nous considère
simplement comme des individus devant
répondre à des normes économiques qui
nous dépasse et non pas à la production
de biens communs et à la vie tout
simplement est ce que j'appelle la vie
est une vie c'est pas simplement aller
travailler c'est pas simplement mais
quand vous avez vu ce qui se passe
depuis le début de la crise avec ce
confinement qui a eu un retentissement
très dur pour l'économie en a maintenant
une dette un déficit énorme est ce que
vous pouvez dire que le gouvernement a
privilégié l'économie sur la santé des
français a laissé une certaine économie
c'est une certaine économie moi je suis
pour protéger l'économie si vous prenez
ce terme là simplement bien sûr
d'ailleurs je peux vous dire moi je suis
élu de sevran villepinte et tremblay je
ne peux vous parler par exemple de ce
qui se passe dans la zone aéroportuaire
de roissy le massacre social dont il est
question on peut on pourrait parler de
ça je peux parler des petits commerçants
qui sont à l'agonie
voilà ça ça bien sûr qu'on peut parler
tout ça mais ils sont sanctionnés ont
également soutenu par l'état pour vous
bruno le maire a annoncé il ya encore
une extension du fonds de solidarité
le fort décalage dans le remboursement
des biens est garantie par l'état
revient sur monsieur le maire s'est
adressé à des entreprises qui ont déjà
une sacrée solidité 1 en termes de
chiffre d'affaires c'est à eux qu'il
s'est adressé
il s'adresse aux grands groupes depuis
le début a qu'il déverse des milliards
sans contrepartie sociale et
environnementale et pour les laisser
cela donne pas que les grands groupes
mais pour les petits bien sûr qu'il ya
eu des aides et notamment pour les tpe
les pme je le sais bien mais là encore
il ya eu d'énormes bug dans la
temporalité pour verser ces aides et un
certain nombre quasiment été au bord ou
ont mis la clé sous la porte parce que
les aides ne sont pas arrivés à temps sa
sa première chose ensuite vous avez
beaucoup de prêts les prêts ça veut dire
que vous allez sur soir c'est pas de
l'argent qui arrive t affirme moment
donné va falloir le rembourser quand
vous êtes une petite entreprise et que
c'est difficile c'est pas si simple de
rembourser et quand je vous parle de la
zone aéroportuaire de roissy où ces
massifs vous avez un trafic qui s'est
évidemment effondré et bien là que fait
le gouvernement que fait le gouvernement
eh bien ils déversent des aides sans
contrepartie et en attendant il ya des
plans sociaux
enormissime et aussi tous ceux qui sont
dans des petites entreprises en intérim
sous traitants etc qui sont licenciés
mis à la porte sans autre sans autre
discussion
donc quand je vous dis faut protéger
l'économie la question c'est quelle
économie quel est le sens que l'on veut
donner à ce que l'on protège et
aujourd'hui je considère que ce qui est
protégé c'est le modèle attractivité
compétitivité concurrence voilà c'est ça
c'est ça qu'il faut impérativement
protéger et non pas et non pas l'avis de
la majorité de nos concitoyens et de nos
concitoyens et pas les entreprises les
plus utiles pour répondre à nos besoins
vous y croyez encore au monde d'après
mais moi vous savez je ne crois c'est
pas de la croyance ccc on est pendus
c'est c'est la force de la détermination
et de la volonté ça qui compte
donc ma question c'est pas de savoir si
j'y crois c'est je milite je m'engage je
suis résolument tournée vers cet
objectif qui devient d'une impérieuse
nécessité c'était accès c'est urgent
anticipe maintenant parce que il ya la
crise sanitaire et à la crise sociale
il ya en plus la crise environnementale
quand vous mettez tout ça si on continue
à aller dans le mur dans lequel nous
allons alors je pense que la catastrophe
est très très sévère et en particulier
pour les plus fragiles
donc c'est pas une histoire de croyance
c'est une histoire vraiment de nécessité
donc je pense que le débat maintenant
qui est posée dans la société et nous le
porterons à l'occasion des échéances
électorales mais aussi tout au long de
l'année dans les mobilisations sociales
à l'assemblée nationale dans les
différentes instances où nous sommes à
chaque échelon et nous diront la même
chose
voilà il faut une société qui se
tournent vers la justice sociale vers le
partage des richesses vers la protection
des ressources naturelles
et donc qui réoriente en profondeur les
buts les finalités même de l'économie
pour que cela réponde à nos besoins et
non pas aux besoins du capital de sans
cesse voyez ce que je veux dire avoir
plus d'argent pour être dans cette
logique de compétitivité internationale
ça ça me paraît vraiment être le sujet
le sujet du moment qui va avec la
démocratie
parce que si le gouvernement est
autoritaire c'est aussi parce qu'il sait
que ses choix sont très contestées très
contesté dans la société est de plus en
plus avec une défiance un dégoût parfois
qui grandit à l'égard de celles et ceux
qui dirigent et moi ça m'inquiète ça
m'inquiète parce qu'une société peut pas
fonctionner correctement si elle est
aussi inquiète
cela vous inquiète déjà veut dire que
pour vous ça peut mener ou tout ça je
pense que la france aujourd'hui est dans
un état de cocotte-minute nom de
cocotte-minute
voilà et c'est la cocotte minute explose
ça donne quoi écoutez moi je me bats moi
je me bats pour que si la cocotte minute
explose elle donne un changement
progressiste humains et qu'on ne bascule
pas vers des solutions encore plus
autoritaire encore plus de fermetures
encore plus dangereux pour ceux qui
m'est cher c'est-à-dire ce fameux
partage des richesses mais aussi cette
ambition culturelle et démocratique
voilà c'est ce qui me tient c'est ce qui
me c'est ce qui me motive et j'ai de la
colère
j'ai beaucoup de colère mais il ya aussi
du ressentiment dans la société et le
ressentiment la haine ce sont des
mauvais moteur les bons moteurs c'est la
colère et l'espoir
et moi je veux transformer cette colère
en espoirs on va parler de la jeunesse
qui est touchée par cette crise on va
parler des étudiants dans quelques
instants mais d'abord les plus petits
ceux qui vont encore à l'école les
écoles qui seront donc maintenue ouverte
c'est ce qu'a annoncé hier jean castex
c'est ce qu'ont annoncé jean castex et
jean michel blanquer avec un protocole
sanitaire renforcée notamment sur les
cantines sur les activités sportives
vous en parliez et 300 mille tests par
semaine est ce que pour vous c'est la
bonne méthode
est-ce qu'il faut toute façon c'est en
effet protéger davantage les enfants les
enseignants ça ça me parait ça me parait
l'évidence et c'est vrai que ça attardés
qui a eu aussi beaucoup d'inégalités
puisque par exemple système de rotation
à fonctionner dans certains
établissements et pas dans d'autres
vous avez donc des élèves qui ont eu une
moitié de cours d'eau
pleinement cours avec parfois à la clé à
la fin de l'année des examens qui sont
des examens nationaux donc moi je
comprends le désarroi de beaucoup
d'enseignants mais vous comprenez vous
comprenez qu'on maintienne les enfants à
l'école
oui je suis pour qu'on maintienne les
enfants à l'école oui je suis pour qu'on
maintienne les enfants à l'école et
encore une fois des systèmes de
protection de rotation on voit bien
qu'on est inscrit dans potentiellement
quelque chose qui peut être au long
cours ça fait déjà depuis mars dernier
que nous sommes dans cette situation
très douloureuse face au co vide
donc il ya on peut pas rester ce que ce
que je veux dire c'est qu'on peut pas
vivre sous cloche en permanence les
répercussions sont terribles
les répercussions psychologiques les
répercussions sur la santé les
répercussions sociales vous allez 1
millions de pauvres
de plus un depuis depuis la crise et un
gouvernement qui ne protège pas
socialement donc on ne peut pas
continuer comme ça sur le monde étudiant
dont on parlait à l'instant que vous
connaissez bien d'ailleurs est-ce que la
situation est encore plus critique on
annonce d'accompagnement psychologique
c'est là c'est la bonne méthode lui faut
des hommes savaient qu'en france il ya
un psychologue pour trente mille
étudiants
étudiants en france nous n'avons erik
seidel a dit que le nombre de
psychologues serait de doubler à la
bonne heure à la bonne heure mais je
voudrais que tout le monde se rendre
compte que tous les choix qui ont été
faits depuis si longtemps de sabrer le
service public c'est pareil pour
l'organisation de l'état si on n'avait
pas tout dépensé sans arrêt essayer
d'être dans une logique de rentabilité à
court terme on ne serait pas dans la
situation dans laquelle on est donc pour
les étudiants c'est dramatique c'est
dramatique sur le plan psychologique
c'est vrai que on dit que le 20 ans
c'est le bel âge c'est un âge qui
aujourd'hui voler pour les étudiants et
pour la jeunesse pas simplement pour les
étudiants ne pas pouvoir aller en cours
ne pas pouvoir être dehors enfin c'est
une privation qui est qui qui a un coût
très très grand et qui en effet jean
cras saclay reçoit ce matin les
organisations étudiantes que ce qu'il
doit leur dire quelles mesures il doit
prendre pour vous moi je suis pour que
d'abord immédiatement et un filet de
sécurité
nous ne cessons de le dire l'ouverture
du rsa pour les 18 25 ans est une
impérieuse nécessité
voilà c'est urgentissime or pour
l'instant on nous annonce une espèce de
planck est une nouvelle usine à gaz
pas très convenablement dit non et bien
sûr mais parce qu'il crée une la place
une usine à gaz qui part du principe que
si les jeunes n'ont pas de job ou ne
travaille pas c'est qu'ils sont des
feignants puisque vous savez bien que
pour trouver un emploi en france il
suffit de traverser la rue donc quand on
a ça dans la tête
eh bien on arrive à des usines à gaz
incroyable alors que quand on dépense
des milliards pour des grandes
entreprises
là on demande aucune contrepartie or
vous avez vu que des grandes entreprises
en profite prennent l'argent et font des
plans de licenciements colossaux alors
qu'ils ont fait des profits records des
profits records pendant la crise c'est
un niveau dans des sens absolument
incroyable et on n'est pas capable
d'avoir un filet de sécurité pour les
jeunes tout de suite maintenant on n'est
pas capable enfin je dis on le
gouvernement n'est pas capable de
renoncer à sa réforme de l'isf pour
faire contribuer les hyper riches pas
c'est quand même insensé absolument
insensé on va parler d'un autre sujet
qui est dans l'actualité
clémentine autain c'est la question de
l'inceste fabrice oui le livre de
camille kouchner remet un inceste sur le
devant de la scène des projecteurs une
lumière très crue
vous êtes surprise parce que tout ce qui
se passe par ce déchaînement de de la
fois d'une émission de débat de deux
contradictoires vous êtes surprise parce
qu'ils pensent je suis agréablement
surprise par la vague mitu et le fait
que dans la durée
elles s'inscrivent dans notre pays et
même à lâcher l'international parce que
la libération la parole aujourd'hui le
thème des viols incestueux il s'inscrit
en réalité dans ce mouvement très très
vaste qui n'en finit pas d'éclore et ça
je ne sais pas comment vous dire ça me
mettrait presque les larmes aux yeux de
vous le dire parce que vous savez que
moi j'ai parlé avant la vague mythe où
on avait fait une pétition qui était un
manifeste des 313 qui déclaré
publiquement avoir été victimes de viols
c'était avant la vague mis tous et je
vous assure que le climat n'était pas du
tout le même
alors de voir ce déferlement de parole
ça me crée une émotion incroyable et un
espoir formidable dont moi je retiens
d'abord ça et ce café camille kouchner
avait dû vous l'avez louis j'ai lu j'ai
lu le lit
de camille kouchner ce week-end qui est
en effet assez édifiant sur sur ce
qu'elle raconte est qui permet parce que
ce sont des voix là parce que c'est un
livre parce que ce sont des
personnalités connues de soulever une
chape de plomb sur le viol incestueux et
de remettre aussi sur le devant de la
scène des questions législatives
importantes justement il faut la changer
la loi il faut créer une peine
spécifique pour cette question demain
c'est ce qu'il faut rendre l'inceste un
prêtre et pieds pour vous moi ce que je
dis déjà c'est que le plus important
c'est que la parole se libère
si vous voulez qu'on ait des plaintes
avant les délais de prescription
il faut que la parole se libère et que
ce soit donc plus facile de déposer
plainte parce que vous pouvez parler
déjà aux personnes qui vous entourent
vous pouvez un policier peut vous
recevoir sans vous regardé bizarrement
comprenant ce que vous dites la justice
il faudrait il mettre des moyens peut
aussi prendre des décisions plus ferme
plus clair donc c'est 700 compliqué
quand ça se passe au sein de sa famille
est ce que du coup il faut des délais
plus longs
justement pour que la parole se libère
plus longtemps et met plus de temps à se
libérer peut-être dans ces cas là elle
met beaucoup plus de temps à se libérer
aussi parce que il faut comprendre que
c'est ce que le livre d'ailleurs
explique assez bien c'est l'ambivalence
des sentiments c'est à dire que vous
êtes face à des adultes qui sont censés
vous expliquer ce que sont bas les
façons les façons devise fisc ce qui se
fait ce qui ne se fait pas quand elle
raconte que olivier duhamel dit à cet
enfant désolé cet enfant de 14 ans 13-14
ans n'est pas très bien c'est que c'est
comme ça qu'on fait ça se fait tout le
monde le fait bon il représente quelque
part là loi voyez ce que je veux dire il
est beau père il représente la loi mais
en même temps ce qu'elle raconte c'est
que ce beau père c'est aussi celui qui
illumine sa vie s'occupe d'elle et c'est
donc il ya une ambivalence des
sentiments et qui rend les choses très
douloureuse est très difficile pour
pouvoir sortir donc si on a d'autres
adultes qui eux mêmes encourage ce
silence condamne enfin si la parole ne
peut pas s'exprimer
alors c'est l'enfermement et c'est un
enfermement très dangereux comme le
raconte très bien qu'à une cousine
il nous reste peu de temps
malheureusement qui monte innocent va
parler des régionales en de votre
candidature avant de parler de votre
candidature avec fabrice un mot
sur un éventuel report de ce scrutin si
toutefois la situation épidémique ne
permet pas de le tenir au mois de juin
est ce que vous y seriez favorables ou
est ce que vous dites faut que ça tienne
en juin après c'est trop tard
je pense vraiment qu'il faut organiser
les conditions pour que ces élections
ont lieu c'était se passer la démocratie
par temps de crise c'est pas du tout une
bonne idée voilà alors évidemment il
faut que cette organisation si nous
sommes encore confrontés à une vague
terrible puissent se tenir dans des
conditions sanitaires qui ne mettent pas
en péril
avant d'apprécier toute façon c'est soit
en juin soit après parce qu'il ya un
délai d'un an incompressibles que donc
ces joints ou alors après on reporte
très très loin ces élections régionales
et départementales
ce qui ne me paraît vraiment vraiment
pas souhaitable vous serez pas parler de
votre candidature vous savez pas encore
quoi tu quoi que coûte que coûte pour
reprendre une expression du moment j'ai
été pour l'instant désigné par la france
insoumise et j'ai présenté à la france
insoumise le profil que je voulais avoir
dans cette campagne c'est à dire un
profil de rassemblements notamment avec
les communistes qui ce week end vont
avoir une conférence régionale pour
discuter de leur stratégie et mon état
d'esprit ma candidature est celle qui
veut prôner un rassemblement des
insoumis des communistes des acteurs et
des actrices du mouvement social et tous
au delà et au delà si possible de
rechercher encore plus loin des
alliances des alliances pour porter une
gauche de transformation sociale et
écologique dans notre région face à
valérie pécresse
riel qui vaut bien à droite aussi à une
logique très importante dans la région
puis ce qu elle l la rime tout à cette
obsession de la compétitivité si bien
que la vie quotidienne et les
franciliennes et les franciliens
finissent par être les grands oubliés de
la politique régie du sculpteur avec
audrey poulin julien bayou audrey pulvar
a proposé un rassemblement sans les
insoumis bon c'est une curieuse approche
de rassemblement à gauche donc elle
difficile de discuter avec elle en tout
cas elle n'a pas pris contact avec moi
avec julien bayou nous discutons aussi
parce que nous nous rencontrons souvent
dans un certain nombre
événement est par exemple dimanche nous
serons je crois ensemble enfin en tout
cas au même au même événement au
triangle de gonesse pour dire que nous
voulons un projet qui s'appelle le
projet car ma quête un contre-projet par
rapport à celui vous souvenez europa
city de la famille mulliez est ce qu'ils
voulaient faire un immense complexe
commercial
même avec des pistes de ski en
ile-de-france imaginez vous un peu le
niveau du projet est bien la
mobilisation a permis de faire capoter
ce projet est maintenant il s'agit de
savoir qu'est-ce qu'on en fait et donc
voila moi je suis pour le projet carmack
et un projet d'économie circulaire avec
une préservation des terres agricoles du
maraîchage du recyclage un institut de
formation aux métiers de l'environnement
et donc par exemple nous serons ensemble
dans cette bataille dimanche et vous
reviendrez nous parler de votre projet
votre candidature clémentine autain mars
avec grand plaisir merci d'avoir été
avec nous ce matin merci fabrice
personnes ont pas de suite au club des
territoires la mutuelle nationale
territoriale
la mutuelle des agents des services
publics locaux vous présente le club des
territoires angie acteurs engagés dans
des transitions zéro carbone et région
vous présente le club des territoires
[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale et les
télévisions locales vous présente le
club des territoires le club des
territoires en partenariat avec la
presse quotidienne régionale les
télévisions locales et les indés radios
vont nous rejoindre dans quelques
instants jean baptiste forêt césar arman
et arnaud benedetti on analysera bien
sûr avec eux les annonces hier de jean
castex et puis on verra la réaction dans
nos régions sera messe avec le maire de
la ville françois grosdidier qui a reçu
d'ailleurs hier la visite de jean castex
et d'olivier verrons ce rachat avec
sébastien couratin journalistes à l'écho
républicain mais d'abord vous l'avez vu
toute la semaine nous étions dans le pas
de calais et le vendredi vous le savez
c'est l'heure du bilan
[Musique]
hessabi l'ont fait avec nous gérons
gravier bonjour bonjour aux vous a suivi
toute la semaine dans le pas de calais
vous étiez avec quentin calmer sur les
conséquences de cendres excitons a vu
vos trois reportages et ce matin vous
lire revenir sur un peu les francs que
la sortie du royaume uni de l'union
européenne a déjà provoqué dans ce
département
oui parce qu'on a beaucoup dit que ce
break site ils n'avaient pas provoqué le
chaos tant redoutée s'il a pas provoqué
le chaos il ya quand même déjà quelques
couacs
mardi matin on vous a montré les
contrôles à la frontière au port de
calais ça n'a pas provoqué de longues
files d'attentes de poids lourds mais
quand on arrive quand on est arrivé il y
avait déjà 60 camions dont les
formalités n'avait pas n'était pas
complète et qui devaient patienter 60
camions
ça paraît pas beaucoup mais on n'est
qu'à 30 % 1 du rythme de croisière du
trafic normal crise sanitaire oblige le
directeur régional des douanes nous a
dit que si le trafic était normal et que
ça a commencé à coincer des deux côtés
de la frontière se pouvait très
rapidement paralyser tout le trafic
empêchant les ferries de débarquer leurs
camions et donc d'en charger rapidement
l'embolie tant redouté serai là et c'est
un scénario qui n'est pas du tout écarté
par les autorités et mercredi matin d'un
vu votre reportage à boulogne-sur-mer et
là aussi tout n'est pas non plus réglé
en du côté des pêcheurs malgré l'accord
si les pêcheurs sont plutôt soulagé de
pouvoir continuer leurs activités dans
les eaux bri
ni qu'ils ne peuvent pas encore allé
pêcher au plus près de ses côtes entre 6
et les 12 milles marins les eaux très
poissonneuses
il faut pour cela des licences qui n'ont
pas encore été délivrés par les
autorités britanniques
depuis 15 jours les gouvernements disent
ça va c'est une question d'heure c'est
une question de jours mais pour
l'instant toujours aux rien ça crée une
grande inquiétude et certains comme le
maire de boulogne frédéric willy
préviennent que dans ce domaine la pêche
on a on est loin d'avoir tout régler
ecoutez-le il ya une base générale il
convient là encore d'être précis sur les
zones de pêche sur la l'observation
scientifique des stocks sur les
conditions d'étalement de la diminution
des droits de pêche de la précision du
droit interne britannique désormais qui
pourrait sacralisé peut-être des espaces
de pêche de zone poissonneuse brest il
ya encore beaucoup beaucoup
d'incertitudes et d'interrogations
pour finir je voulais revenir sur leurs
portages que vous avez vu hier à calais
calais qui craint de perdre la clientèle
britannique 1 et qui rêve d'une zone de
duty free en centre ville dans ce
secteur de l'hôtellerie on place
beaucoup d'espoir dans ce dispositif
écoutez cette directrice d'hôtel qu'on
insurgés à quand un calme et free était
basé à calais on voyait énormément de
bus d'anglais venir faire ses achats
faire travailler les commerces
calaisiens et c'est vrai que quand duty
free est parti ça s'est arrêté
totalement
c'était vraiment duty free qui faisait
venir les anglais les britanniques à
calais on n'attend pas du duty free qui
règle tous les problèmes par contre
qu'il apporte une participation
bénéfique qu'il amène un petit peu de
de d'activité à la ville le problème
c'est que pour créer une zone duty free
il faut l'accord des 27 pays de l'ue et
il est loin d'être acquis donc plutôt
qu'une zone de duty free aura sans doute
simplement un système de détaxe comme
dans les grands magasins parisiens pour
la clientèle extra-européenne
c'est pas tout à fait la même chose ce
qu'une zone de duty free comme on la
connaît dans les aéroports et sa demande
encore beaucoup de détails à régler
avant que ça puisse être installé et
merci beaucoup jérôme tous vos
reportages réalisés avec quentin chalmé
sont à voir ou à revoir sur notre site
internet la semaine prochaine on va dans
le gers on va reparler du bric site qui
n'est pas sans conséquence sur les
conseils municipaux là aussi vous allez
le voir
et puis on consacrera deux reportages à
la grippe aviaire qui prend de plus en
plus d'ampleur et qui menace toute une
filière
merci jérôme un merci d'accueillir nos
clubs heures dans quelques instants on
va analyser avec eux les annonces de
jean castex mais d'abord on va voir le
résumé de ces annonces et avec jonathan
du prix est jean castex a tranché le
couvre-feu à 18h déjà en place dans
certains départements va s'appliquer à
l'ensemble du territoire et ce dès
samedi une nouvelle mesure restrictive
nécessaire selon le gouvernement
en raison de la circulation toujours
active du virus le couvre-feu
s'appliquera à compter de 18 heures à
partir de ce samedi et pour au moins 15
jours
malgré ce nouveau tour de vis jean
castex a estimé la situation maîtrisée
mais fragile en france 24 mille
personnes hospitalisées ces dernières 24
heures et des services de réanimation
toujours sous tension mais les
inquiétudes du gouvernement portent
surtout sur les deux mutations du virus
identifié dans l'hexagone l'une
sud-africaine et l'autre britannique se
variante qu'est ce qu'on sait de lui
d'abord qu'il est plus contagieux que le
virus qui circule classiquement en
france de l'ordre de 30 à 70% et ce
virus et potentiellement aussi plus
contagieux chez les enfants autre point
abordé cette fois par jean michel
blanquer air écoles collèges et lycées
verront leur protocole sanitaire durci
mais ne fermeront pas c'est évidemment
essentiel quand on mesure les avantages
et les inconvénients d'aller à l'école
ou de ne pas aller ricol de maintenir
les écoles ouvertes car il ya des
conséquences éducatives sociales
psychologiques
sanitaire même pour les enfants de ne
pas aller à l'école le ministre de
l'économie à lui détaillé de nouvelles
mesures notamment pour les entreprises
ayant contracté un prêt garanti par
l'état nous allons donc permettre à
toutes les entreprises qui le souhaitent
de différer d'une année supplémentaire
le remboursement de leurs prêts garantis
par l'état si elle souhaite le
rembourser au 1er mars 2022 au lieu du
1er mars 2021
elles pourront le faire outre l'aide au
pge bruno le maire a annoncé la prise en
charge jusqu'à 70% des coûts fixes de
certaines entreprises ou encore
l'élargissement du fonds de solidarité
au total ces nouvelles mesures coûteront
4 milliards d'euros par mois à l'êta et
on va donc commencer ce club avec ses
annonces bonjour jean baptiste genre
bonjour enlever l'étiquette avec nous à
distance du côté d'un bel endroit
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin
où j'ai tant qu'enfant on précise on va
commencer par
ces annonces la principale annonce un
finalement évidemment de jean castex et
ce couvre-feu qui sera appliquée à tout
le monde dès demain fine et la
territorialisation oui alors c'était une
territorialisation quand même assez
limité 1 c'était le couvre-feu dans
certains dans certains départements pour
une période quand même très courte on
s'aperçoit que la territorialisation ça
ne marche pas du côté de l'état c'est un
paradoxe parce que le maquereau on avait
fait un peu son mantra au début de sa
mandature c'était quand même lié une
conception quand même assez managériale
de l'action publique d'adaptation
permanente de culture du résultat et là
où sortent vraiment aux mammouths et
éthique on sait tous fermés mais on sait
pas ouvrir progressivement
ouais c'est compliqué arnaud à cette
question on le voit depuis le début de
la crise
quand il ya des mesures nationales les
élus demandent des mesures territoriales
quand c'est a été réalisée on entend
dire que ça crée une injustice une une
inégalité compliqué pour le gouvernement
cette question oui c'est compliqué parce
qu'il ya aussi le fait que nous vivons
dans une culture politique et
administrative qui est quand même de
tradition jacobine et où finalement le
sentiment d'égalité de traitement et
quelque chose qui est profondément
enracinée dans les esprits alors ceci
dit ils valent sera qu' on comprend bien
que la volonté du gouvernement est
aujourd'hui d'essayer de faire cela
quitteront préventive parce que la
pression épidémique eux restent fortes
même si elles semblent un peu moins fort
peut-être pour l'instant en france que
dans d'autres pays voisins en
l'occurrence la difficulté c'est que roy
bien qu'un certain nombre aujourd'hui
d'élus notamment d'élus locaux mais
aussi d'acteurs économiques comprennent
mal cette décision parce que c'est une
décision qui va perturber profondément
le fonctionnement et qui déjà perturbé
depuis quelques jours le fonctionnement
d'un certain nombre de départements et
de de métropole et qui aujourd'hui cette
généralisation c'est que peut-être le
fait aussi que la région ile-de-france
soit touché par ce couvre-feu à 18h fait
que cette annonce quelque part
vient un peu perturbé fondamentalement
les les opinions et surtout les
réactions à la fois des élus mais aussi
d'asante allons encore une fois
d'acteurs économiques et sociaux césar
sur cette question de la
territorialisation oui écouter ça a
commencé progressivement et maintenant
ce sera étendu à tout le monde
je suis peut-être que c'est la bonne
solution je la gravité la situation
peut-être qu'il aurait fallu associer
les élus dès le début plus tôt
qu'annoncé ça comme d'habitude devant
tous les français
voilà mais au moins sur la vaccination a
l'impression que l'état est prêt à
travailler avec les collectivités
c'est là l'autre grande inquiétude un
évidement cette question de la
vaccination avec un nouveau calendrier
annoncé hier
par le gouvernement finalement les
personnes qui présentent des pathologies
à haut risque pourront se faire vacciner
dès lundi il y aura 700 centres
finalement qui seront opérationnels dès
lundi est ce que le gouvernement est en
train de rattraper son retard - le
gouvernement est en train de trouver sa
rite pardon sa vitesse de croisière
après le fiasco du lancement là il ya
quand même deux petit rayon de soleil à
l'horizon pour lui il ya déjà d'une part
les français qui d'après les sondages
seraient aujourd'hui davantage prêts à
se vacciner on a une majorité de
français même prêt à ceux à se faire
vacciner puis un deuxième petit rayon de
soleil qui est l'extension de cette
vaccination donc on voit quand même que
les choses se mettent en marche si je
puis dire
peu à peu bon ceci dit quand même encore
de la la friture sur la ligne
des connexions à trouver aussi avec avec
les élus locaux et en particulier avec
les avec les régions qui sont très très
actif sur ce sujet à la veille des
élections
un changement de braquet de la part du
gouvernement avec une multiplication des
vaccinations quotidiennes et
effectivement bascule dans l'opinion
dont on a l'impression d'après les
sondages qu'elle est en tout cas de plus
en plus favorable à cette vaccination
ah oui on peut se demander si finalement
la controverse sur la lenteur assumé
dans un premier temps par l'exécutif de
sa stratégie de vaccination n'a pas
servi la cause finalement dû du vaccin
en tout cas manifestement les études
d'opinion depuis quelques jours montrent
que la défiance semble décroître et
c'est plutôt quelque chose d'assez
positif en l'occurrence mais je crois
que quand même fondamentalement c'est
quand même la pression indéniablement de
l'opinion publique et d'un certain
nombre de voix qui se sont élevées
contre la stratégie initiale de
l'exécutif qui a fait en sorte
qu'aujourd'hui l'exécutif et une
conscience qu'il fallait accélérer le
calendrier de
vaccination même si quand même quand on
regarde les chiffres
même s'il ya une augmentation très nette
des vaccinations depuis eu quelques
jours en france
si on regarde les chiffres
comparativement par rapport à leurs
voisins qui ont commencé de manière plus
rapide de leur campagne
on est encore très loin du nombre de
vaccinés que l'on retrouve chez nos
voisins c'est le voisin où on parle
notamment et ses annonces elles ont bien
évidemment fait réagir les politiques de
tous bords on va regarder quelques unes
de ces réactions c'est avec quentin
calmer quand on vous avait scruté pour
nous les différents on nous annonce des
politiques au discours de jean castex
l'occasion de revenir sur trois mesures
principales annoncé hier soir oui tout à
fait rien j'ai scruté les réactions
effectivement à ses trois principales
annonces on commence avec le couvre-feu
un bien sûr parce qu'il a été étendue
partout en france dès samedi pour au
moins 15 jours a lancé
il concernait déjà 25 départements il
est élargi dans une logique de freinage
préventive a dit hier le premier
ministre alors principal reproche
adressé à cette mesure
l'affluence des français juste avant 18
heures dans les transports ou dans les
commerces
regardez la réaction d'adrien 4 mince le
député la france soumise il a dit
monsieur déconfinement annonce le
couvre-feu de 18h partout nous serons
plus nombreux à nous concentrer dans les
lieux communs comme les transports ou
les magasins sur des créneaux plus court
ces nouvelles trouvailles perpétuelle
sont insupportables une solution la
rotation et on avait entendu cette idée
effectivement dans la bouche de jean luc
mélenchon la semaine dernière avec des
horaires qui varierait dans les
entreprises en fonction des jours du
côté des verts on accepte le principe du
couvre-feu mais le gouvernement doit
anticiper les conséquences de ce couvre
feu notamment dans les grandes villes et
dans les transports écouter julien bayou
c'était il ya quelques minutes sur sud
radio
nous nous disons deux principes la santé
la prévention et le principe de
précaution
mais le principe de précaution par
exemple si on avance notamment pour
l'ile-de-france très densément peuplées
et si on avance le couvre feu de 20
heures à 18 heures oui eh bien on sait
qu'on aura des difficultés dans les
transports et dans ce cas là le principe
de précaution l'anticipation la
logistique c'est prévoir des transports
supplémentaires aux heures de pointe
voilà et bien nous l'avait que l'amour
depuis des mois et des mois
en vérité depuis des années c'est le
moment de le faire autre point qui a
fait réagir quand ans et cette annonce
de contrôles renforcés aux frontières
oui tout à fait rien car dès lundi les
voyageurs en provenance d'un pays
or eux devront présenter un test négatif
et s'isoler ensuite pendant sept jours
et bien marine le pen à réagir et des
sweats elle a dit que de temps perdu par
pure idéologie pour maîtriser nos
frontières tous les pays qui ont
maîtrisé rapidement leurs frontières
s'en sortent beaucoup mieux que nous a
dit marine le pen sur twitter
effectivement c'était un des angles
d'attaqué hier de la présidente du front
national triomphalement nationale et on
termine avec le volet consacré aux
entreprises un bruno le maire a lui
aussi fait quelques annonces
voilà les milices de l'économie a
notamment annoncé que les entreprises
auraient le droit de bénéficier d'un an
de plus de remboursement des prêts et
garanties par l'état
les coûts fixes des entreprises fermées
seront pris en charge jusqu'à 70% alors
je voulais proposer d'écouter le
président des républicains qui a réussi
il ya encore quelques minutes et sur
europe 1 à propos du couvre-feu à 18h
écoutez le je pense qu'il aurait fallu
le territorialisée parce qu'il ya des
conséquences économiques lourdes vous
savez sur le je pense notamment au
commerce
vous avez beaucoup de commerces moi je
suis à provins dans une ville qui a été
très commerçante entre 18 et 20 heures
vous avez beaucoup de commerçants qui
font entre 20 et 30% de leur chiffre
d'affaires
voilà pour les principales réactions à
ces annonces et merci beaucoup
quant à un mot peut-être avec vous
arnaud 1 sur ses réactions et ses
critiques toujours vives de la part de
l'opposition
oui manifestement en tout cas ce qui est
sûr c'est que le premier ministre n'a
pas convaincu ses oppositions on s'y
attendait un peu c'est vrai que la
question des frontières est une question
qui se pose est un depuis un certain
nombre de temps quelques-uns là aussi de
nos partenaires avaient pris des mesures
qui en tout cas semblé de limiter
l'accès dans leur propre pays de
voyageurs étrangers en tout cas le
conditionné à un test pc ce qu'il faut
noter c'est que pour l'instant on n'a
pas bougé sur les frontières à
l'intérieur de l'espace schengen en
l'occurrence c'est que manifestement en
tout cas on considère que ce qui le plus
important c'est évidemment de limiter en
tout cas de de contraindre l'accès au
territoire par des conditions
en tout cas de d'obtention d'un test pc
d'autant plus qu' il ya quand même un
élément important ou non nous avons reçu
récemment dans le cadre de la revue
politique et parlementaire le professeur
delfraissy qui l'addition d'autres
mondes
en l'occurrence il ya une inquiétude
quant aux variants non seulement variant
britanniques mais aussi variant sud
africain qui qui pose problème en
l'occurrence c'est effectivement et ce
qu'a dit jean françois delfraissy on
on a entendu ces derniers jours les élus
locaux ont demandé à être plus consultés
plus associé on va voir ce qu'en pense
justement ces élus locaux on va se
rendre à metz avec françois grosdidier
bonjour françois grosdidier merci
beaucoup d'être un direct avec nous vous
êtes le maire de metz vous avez entendu
bien évidemment ces annonces de jean
castex notamment sous couvre-feu pour
tout le monde à 18 heures les écoles qui
restent ouvertes avec de nouvelles
restrictions que pensez vous de ces
annonces écoutez je les connais c'est un
peu avant je dirais que j'ai présentée
puisque j'avais rencontré le premier
ministre qui était venu à metz dans la
journée et le et lors de sa visite à
metz vous avez dit qu'il allait annoncer
le soir non il m'avait pas dit s'il
allait annoncer je lui avais dit quel
était mon analyse je sentais bien qu'il
contre argumenter et donc qu'il n'était
pas sur la même position
en clair nous sommes tous d'accord sur
un point il faut absolument éviter de se
retrouver dans la situation épouvantable
dans lesquelles les urgences sont
saturés et nous sommes obligés à ce
moment là quoi les soignants sont
obligés de choisir entre ceux qui
sauvent et ceux qui ne sauve pas pour
l'été il y a deux façons soit le coup de
frein brutal fort le plus fort c'est le
confinant total qui à ce moment là peut
être limité dans l'espace et dans le
temps mais confinement total c'est comme
en mars avril
ça veut dire que les collégiens les
lycéens tous les salariés qui ne sont
pas indispensables pour des questions
vitales de travail reste à la maison et
ça ça marche c'est un vrai coup de frein
ou alors on est dans la demi mesure
c'est par exemple est ce que nous
faisons depuis déjà des semaines à metz
c'est le couvre-feu à 18 heures et ça
c'est un fait une demi mesure
ça freine un peu et pour que sa porte il
faut que ce soit totale généraliser et
que ça dure longtemps
or c'est assez insupportable parce que
d'abord
500 prend toujours le même c'est les
commerçants le monde de la culture
totalement paralysée et beaucoup de
commerces sont à l'agonie et risquent
d'être de ne pas s'en remettre
et puis ça veut dire qu'on réduit les
citoyens à leurs fonctions de production
et puis après ils mangent qu'ils dorment
ça rend la vie impossible aux citoyens
qui n'ont même pas le temps de récupérer
les enfants de faire quelques courses
avant de rentrer chez eux et ça
concentre sur des créneaux très court à
la fois les trajets dans les transports
en commun le fait d'aller chez les
commerçants les commerces vont être bon
dès le samedi matin dans que j'étais
plutôt partisan effectivement du
confinement total territorialisée donc
limité dans l'espace et dans le temps
plutôt que ces demi-mesures que nous
connaissons déjà généralisé cela dit le
gouvernement a fait son choix il faut
que tout le monde respecte atra tj
nationale vont arriver à juguler les
entrées aux urgences
jusqu'au moment où nous aurons atteint
l'immunité collective mais nous en
sommes loin avec un rythme de
vaccination qui reste beaucoup beaucoup
trop lent juste on a bien compris votre
votre position à ce couvre-feu à 18h
vous à metz vous y êtes passés depuis
quelques jours vous n'attendez pas
demain il pour y passer ça c'est une
mesure qui n'a pas prouvé son efficacité
dans votre ville et plus largement dans
votre écoute et je voulais dit qui est
un peu stabilisé qui n'a pas vu et qui
n'apparaît lui le taux d'incidence qui a
ralenti sa progression et qu'il a
stabilisé à un haut niveau mais je vous
le redis c'est une demi mesure
c'est une mesure qui s'est avérée
insuffisante si elle n'était pas prise
sur un plan général en mai il valait
mieux le confinement territorialisée est
plus court que cette mesure générale
cela dit le gouvernement a tranché et
maintenant la question c'est de vacciner
au plus vite
nous sommes voisins de l'allemagne et du
luxembourg au milieu de la semaine
dernière
r il avait vacciné huit fois plus de
personnes que nous alors même qu'ils ont
commandés au même moment au même endroit
des vaccins ces cinq hommes qui pose
question et ceux sur lesquels nous avons
interpellé fortement le premier ministre
y est justement on va en parler puisque
effectivement jean castex et est venu
vous voir à metz notamment sur cette
question des vaccins est ce qu'après
votre rencontre avec le premier ministre
vous dit toujours que les élus ne sont
pas suffisamment associés pas
suffisamment écoutés est ce que ça vous
a rassuré cette rencontre avec jean
castex
bah écoute et on écoutait pas toujours
entendus c'est le cas notamment sur ces
mesures couvre-feu ou ou confinement
confinement cela dit effectivement les
réponses peuvent être différentes selon
les territoires
je crois que le message est passé au
premier auprès du premier ministre sur
la situation courtelinesque en fait dans
laquelle nous retrouvons avec une
bureaucratie qui est inopérante
je vois chez nos voisins allemands des
ongles vacciner deux fois plus mais
l'administratif par rapport au ce
il consacre la même part 2 du pib à la
santé
et ils sont trois fois plus de lits
d'urgence donc j'irai à la décharge des
dirigeants actuels et faut qu'ils y
mettre fin
nous sommes structurellement dans une
bureaucratie centralise atik qui est
inopérante et on regrette que le
gouvernement ou que les autorités ne
sera-t-il n'est pas plutôt accepter le
concours des collectivités territoriales
je rappelle que les présidents de région
de département les maires de france des
mois de novembre avaient fait des offres
de service qui s'était heurté à des fins
de non recevoir de la part de l'état on
imagine que vous l'avez dit ça irait
évidemment un jean castex qu'est ce que
vous lui avez dit précisément qu'est ce
qui vous a répondu un message
d'ouverture de bonne volonté en disant
qu'on allait tenter de rattraper le
temps perdu même s'il a du mal à
admettre que du temps a été perdu
m'enfin on sent bien que le message
passe et qu'il est déçu il que le rythme
de vaccination soit le même que le
rythme d'approvisionnement ça n'arrive
pas assez vite
mais si on a autant de pertes
de temps qu'on augmente et les stocks on
n'a pas des vaccins pour les stocker
surtout à moins 80 degrés donc il faut
vraiment que le système soit plus
opérants plus fluide
l'ipres ici tout le monde va dans le
même sens mais pour ça il faut que
l'état accepte de s'organiser avec
d'autres je pense là que le message a dû
passer auprès du premier ministre merci
beaucoup merci françois grosdidier
d'avoir été avec nous maire de metz
d'avoir été en direct de votre ville
merci françois legault on entend
françois grosdidier
les élus on est on a entendu on n'est
pas forcément très écoutée ou l'inversé
d'ailleurs
jean castex et est à massilly olivier
ferrand est à 3 aujourd'hui il va
rencontrer françois baroin le maire de
la ville le président de l'association
des maires de france est ce que c'est un
gouvernement qui essaye de retisser le
lien avec les élus
oui il tend la main si je puis dire en
série s étendent qu'ovide aux élus
locaux mais il ya encore quand même un
certain nombre de deux pommes de pomme
de discorde moi ce qui m'étonne c'est
quand même jean castex quand même ils
aient été nommés pour ça quand même au
moins 2 au mois de juillet ça un élu à
l'accent rocailleux basée à 900 km2 de
paris c'était l'homme des territoires
nous disent et on est quand même
notamment dans l'opinion il n'a pas
cette image il n'a pas cette image là
enfin il a quand même plutôt images d'un
chef de bureau pas très marrant qui
adressent des bons et des mauvais points
la halle à la population
bon hier il a dit qu'on avait on qu'on a
eu bien agi pendant les fêtes on est
très contents des des félicitations de
monsieur de monsieur castex mais on se
souvient quand même qu'il ya un mois
lors d'une réunion devant les députés
marcheurs il parlait du risque d' usine
de co vide donc apparemment il s'est
quand même trompé dans la il s'est
trompé dans l'analyse bon il n'a pas
avalé sans son chapeau hier mais il ya
quand même encore aujourd'hui de de
fortes tensions entre entre les élus et
l'état parce que rien ne bouge quand
même depuis un an fin la vue sur les
matchs sur les tests sur la vaccination
c'est toujours la même histoire mais on
a vu la réaction de mr avec françois
grosdidier on va voir la réaction
d'autres représentants d'élus avec vous
quentin qu'est ce qu'il se dit du côté
des autres associations d'élus et bien
rien ne voulais vous montrer la réaction
du patron de l'assemblée des
départements de france c'est dominique
bussereau il a réagi sur twitter il a
dit regretter vivement le couvre-feu
généralise
et dans tout le pays il a dit une
différenciation selon les territoires
aurait été plus juste ce couvre-feu
avancé le patron des régions de france
de son côté est bien lui il n'y était
pas non plus favorable mais renaud
muselier a tout de même applaudi hier
soir à la conférence de presse de jean
castex tu écoutais le c'était hier soir
donc au micro de bfm tv
je trouve que le premier ministre a été
bien sûr vigilant attentif lucide mais
aussi positif et ça c'est quand même la
première fois qu on a quand même un
petit message d'espoir sont là pour la
première fois des moyens colossaux sur
le plan économique qui sont mis en place
monde répond aux charges fixes et on a
aussi le traitement social derrière donc
globalement quand même on est n'a pas
simplement avec une démarche toujours
conçus aux jeunes que de la santé mais
traitement global sur la base de ce
qu'on a pris en 10 mois voilà vous
l'avez entendu un renommé yeux qui a
salué le ton de l'intervention de jean
castex mais il a également
particulièrement applaudi les mesures en
faveur des entreprises il a parlé d'
acte fort avec un notamment on le sait
le prolongement des prêts garantis par
l'état par exemple oriane merci beaucoup
quand un procès réaction longtemps c'est
à reims est pas le même son cloche du
côté des associations d'élus oui à les
régions elles ont obtenu gain de cause
sur deux points de la part d'olivier
verront particulièrement mises à santé
plutôt que de jean castex
elles vont avoir des réunions
hebdomadaires entre le préfet de région
le prix en région les présentes
département les interconnecter les
communes pour décider de la stratégie
vaccinale hyperlocal et de l'autre voilà
les départements on joue déjà le rôle
avec les préfets de département
ils ont la qualité des départements le
rhône jeudi ce service de départemental
d'incendié de sécurité de ce qui permet
aussi en saône et loire par exemple j'en
ai parlé hier extrême la saône et loire
qui est monsieur interlocuteur du
gouvernement pour les départements il
faisait moi je des pompiers j'ordonne
des centres parce qu'ils peuvent le
faire et préfets de département ils
peuvent le faire les régions si nous
faut en plus des réunions
bert ça va être un merdier pas possible
faut arrêter la bureaucratie
voilà ils parlent clairement comme ça
après l'association des petites villes
de france qui dit non on n'est pas assez
équipés donc faut faire ça au niveau
départemental mais tout s'ils veulent
finalement que le département soit la
bonne échelle après des différenciations
peut-être qu'il va falloir attendre la
fameuse loi 4d pour qu'on ait de la
différenciation comme l'appelle de ses
voeux
dominique bussereau et qu'on attend ça
va être l'enjeu de ces prochaines
semaines arnaud d'organiser notamment
cette campagne de vaccination avec les
élus avec les collectivités
oui c'est l'enjeu maximale parce que
l'on sait très bien que pour sortir de
cette situation fait quand même une
situation assez mortifère il faut
absolument atteindre l'immunité
collective et que c'est la stratégie de
vaccination qui permettra de l'atteindre
en l'occurrence donc il faut l'organiser
en l'occurrence mais si oui la question
d'indifférenciation le problème c'est
que les élus veulent vraisemblablement
la différenciation c'est à dire une
approche qui soit une approche
territorialisée en fonction de la
circulation du virus dans les
différentes régions et dans les
différents départements
mais la difficulté c'est que cette
différenciation elle est réclamée par
les élus mais n'est pas toujours très
bien comprise par l'opinion publique
donc l'exécutif est obligé à la fois de
naviguer entre ces deux écueils et ce
qui rend récent difficile parfois je
crois que cette crise du coc vide comme
c'est le cas ce sont de nombreuses
crises elle n'a fait que révéler les
tensions qui existaient maintenant
depuis finalement 2017 l'élection d'
emmanuel macron entre le pouvoir central
et
les élus les élus locaux elle n'a fait
d'une certaine manière que les exacerber
en l'occurrence et on voit bien que
depuis le début de cette crise qu'ils
s'agissent des présidents de région des
présidents de départements des mères en
l'occurrence ils essayent de palier
parfois à la lourdeur qui est celle de
l'état pour organiser une riposte par
rapport à cette crise sanitaire et
finalement on se rend compte depuis
maintenant près de prédalles en
l'occurrence puisque le confinement le
premier campement date du mois de mars
que la situation n'a pas
fondamentalement évolué et qu'on reste
encore dans une situation qui est une
situation à la fois de malentendus et
d'incompréhension et la dette et la
campagne vaccinale d'une certaine
manière l'entâme de la campagne
vaccinale la fois démontré et on va
continuer à voir les réactions dans nos
régions en réaction à cette conférence
de presse on va aller à chartres on va
retrouver sébastien couratin bonjour
sébastien merci beaucoup avec nos
journalistes à l'écho républicain et la
une de l'écho républicain bien
évidemment consacré à cette principale
annonce 18 heures à la maison c'est
votre titre oui tout à fait comme le
mentionne notre lune à partir de demain
fait 18 heures à la maison pour une
durée d'au moins deux semaines alors un
couvre-feu que le le premier ministre
présente comme un freinage préventif à
des fêtes de fin d'année n'ont pas
provoqué explique-t-il la flambée de
contamination redouté mais la situation
reste selon lui préoccupante d'autant
plus que de nouvelles souches virales
plus contagieuse est aujourd'hui dans
les pressions alors après les annonces
de jean castex nous sommes allés à la
rencontre des acteurs économiques
associatifs de l'eure et loir pour
prendre le pouls du territoire dans un
département qui n'a pas connu un jusqu
alors ce couvre feu de 18h à une
commerçante nous confie son inquiétude
on sait dès 17h30 explique-t-elle qui
aura plus de clients sur un credo
pourtant fréquenté un éducateur de club
qui a appris hier la suspension de toute
activité sportive en intérieur nous nous
dit levet nous explique vivre très mal
cette situation alors vous l'aurez
compris pour ses forces vives du
territoire qui estime avoir déjà
consenti beaucoup d'efforts depuis le
début de la crise
l'extinction des feux à 18h ben ça passe
mal
et aujourd'hui il ya un autre sujet à
lire dans l'écho républicain sébastien
célèbre excite vous évoquer les
conséquences de ce break site sur
l'économie en eure et loir
oui le divorce entre le royaume et nous
au pn est consommée depuis le 1er
janvier pour l'économie de
l'eure-et-loir c'est un coup dur il faut
savoir que le royaume uni c'est le
troisième partenaire commercial du
département avec 400 millions d'euros à
des échanges de marchandises et de et de
services entre septembre 2019 et juillet
2020 alors concrètement qu'est ce qui
change pour ces acteurs économiques
ils font face à de nouvelles barrières
douanières une réglementation plus
drastiques
patron d'une ébénisterie locale qui
exportent 10% de sa production vers
l'angleterre
alors depuis le vote de bray du
président son chiffre d'affaires sur le
territoire britannique a chuté de 3%
et depuis le 1er janvier mais ils
rencontrent des difficultés sur le plan
logistique car les transporteurs répugne
à accepter des convois de peur de d'un
blocage aux frontières dans la
cosmétique est très présente département
le break site à moins d'impact
semble-t-il qu'à la réglementation n'a
pas vraiment évolué mais le
rétablissement des formalités douanières
se fait sens coulé dans un moule et dans
des réflexes de grands groupes qui sont
beaucoup plus rompus à ces échanges à
l'international merci beaucoup merci
sébastien d'avoir été avec nous ce matin
depuis chartres en voilà une de l'écho
républicain 18h à la maison c'est votre
une et on va voir vos autres une
régionale ce matin avec content
[Musique]
et quant à la plupart de nos quotidiens
régionaux ce matin consacre évidemment
leur une à ces annonces de jean castex
voilà on voulait vous montrer une petite
collection d'une de ce matin consacrez
vous le voyez il ya une grande unanimité
effectivement consacré à la conférence
de presse hier de jean castex et on va
commencer du coup à regarder ce qui se
passe par exemple à la une de la
charente libre et ce titre 18 heures un
vaccin est au lit ce titre nous a fait
sourire c'est un peu le nouveau métro
boulot dodo mais version 2021
la charente libre qui essaie d'imaginer
ce que le couvre-feu à 18h à l'échangé
dans nos vies quotidiennes oriane et est
la une de la nouvelle république
toujours jean castex wii un titre
similaire la france au lit à 18 heures
et encore une photo d'un centre-ville
désert là il s'agit de la ville de blois
où depuis fin octobre les rues se vident
dès 20h nous dit journal et donc à
partir de samedi soir à 18h oriane on va
aller du côté des outre mer puisque des
annonces spécifiques 1 pour les outre
mer hier tout à fait on voulait faire un
petit focus ce matin sur le journal de
l'île de la réunion où on peut lire
voyage de poing tests négatifs exigé
vers la métropole c'est lié aux variants
sud africain qui inquiète fortement je
cite le gouvernement les passagers des
vols en provenance de la guyane et de
mayotte auront la même obligation car on
le sait le virus et ces variants circule
dans les comores qui sont pas très loin
de mayotte également en amérique du sud
ce qui inquiète donc en guyane oriane et
puis évidemment la question des vaccins
qui est à la une aussi de vos quotidiens
régionaux notamment du journal de saône
et loire
oui tout à fait regardez ce centre de
vaccination mis en place à chalon déjà
3969 rendez vous ont été pris jeudi donc
hier et là encore comme dans l'essonne
que l'on évoqué au début de l'émission
oriane on cherche des médecins
volontaires et des infirmières pour
renforcer les équipes de ces centres de
vaccination nous apprend le j 1
l comme on dit quand on est un team
comme vous l'êtes
et on termine avec centre-presse mais la
haute avec centre-presse on voulait
finir pour parler de cette visite hier à
rodez du secrétaire d'état en charge de
la ruralité joël giraud il a été
question de lutter contre l'enclavement
de ces territoires ainsi que de la place
de la jeunesse dans les campagnes au
real merci beaucoup canton pour cette
revue de la presse quotidienne régionale
on va regarder vos une messieurs arnaud
la une de la revue politique et
parlementaire consacrée à cette crise
sanitaire une crise sans fin et puis un
numéro spécial sur la concession un
outil pour la relance lundi vous en
parlerez arnaud nouveau numéro 1 de la
revue politique et parlementaire a line
de la gazette des communes cette semaine
2021 faites vos jeux jean baptiste oui
on a tenté d'y voir clair dans cette
année qui ne l'est pas trop à priori
c'est à dire d'aborder les grands sujets
qui seront ceux des collectivités en
particulier la loi 4d donc par les césar
je vous épargnerai la signification on
aura tendance à l'erreur et allen de la
tribune césar justement c'est la méthode
de meo qui va déconstruire le renaudot
ghosn oui le nouveau patron de renault
qui a succédé à carlos ghosn après avoir
été le patron de seat voilà lancé hier
la résolution ce néologisme de renault
et leur évolution et en clair c'est
faire moins de volume mais plus de
qualité et c'est à dire aujourd'hui dans
l'édition numérique de la tribune merci
messieurs seulement rêver avec no mercy
arnaud benedetti on vous retrouve lundi
arnaud et nous si on se retrouve lundi
l'invité politique ce sera à amélie de
montchanin la ministe de la
transformation et de la fonction
publique à lundi on vous souhaite un
très bon week end la presse quotidienne
régionale et les télévisions locales
vous ont présenté le club des
territoires
[Musique]
la mutuelle nationale territoriale la
mutuelle des agents des services publics
locaux vous a présenté le club des
territoires angie acteurs engagés dans
la transition zéro carbone des régions
vous a présenté le club des territoires
[Musique]
revoir ce programme en replay sur public
sénat remet en effet livré vous votre
émission littéraire sur public sénat
s'intéresse cette semaine à la question
des stéréotypes stéréotypes raciaux
stéréotypes tout court avec une
humoriste sophia aram est un sociologue
gérald bronner livrez vous ce soir à 19h
sur public sénat
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition des matins du sénat
poursuivre aujourd'hui une table ronde
organisée par la commission de la
culture et qui se tenait mardi au sénat
il a été question de la stratégie de
l'audiovisuel public
vous allez pouvoir écouter les prises de
parole de deux pdg
il s'agit de sybille veille la patronne
de radio france ainsi que delphine
ernotte
la pdg de france télévisions il va être
question de l'arrêt de la diffusion de
la chaîne france 4 ou encore de la
stratégie de la chaîne arte sans plus
attendre direction la salle clémenceau
poursuivre cette table ronde préparer
aujourd'hui pour public sénat paralyse
bardot et laureline vion monsieur le
président donc je vais essayer d'être
concise et jeffrey sur ce tome 4 des
remarques en quatre points
le premier point c'est que ce contrat
confirme les arbitrages qui ont été
rendus par le gouvernement et le premier
ministre en juillet 2018
vous l'avez rappelé vous même parfois
certains cons comme n'ont pas été
honorées là on peut se féliciter d'avoir
une trajectoire financière qui est
conforme à celle qui a été annoncée en
il comporte des synergies renforcée
entre les entreprises je reviendrai et
il s'inscrit dans un calendrier cohérent
au fond parce qu'on sait que les les
changements de gouvernements putatif
peuvent entraîner des changements pour
usain public là on s'arrête en 2022
on peut peut-être le regretter mais
c'est pragmatique
une remarque néanmoins depuis le rapport
schwartz on sait qu'il ya énormément
d'indicateurs dans l'est dans les
différents documents qui régissent au
fond les entreprises publiques de
l'audiovisuel le cahier des charges les
contrats d'objectifs et de moyens et
celui ci si les consignes en sa forme a
quand même un nombre d'indicateurs
importants à 33 versus 19 dans le com
précédent pour france télévisions
le deuxième point c'est que c'est un
projet qui renforce les missions et
l'utilité de france télévisions pour ces
publics
il confirme bien la place renforcer la
culture et de la création
on as
suivant ce que nous-mêmes nous avons
annoncé d'ailleurs en début de semaine
en nouvelle grille c'est à dire la place
du spectacle vivant en première partie
de soirée sur nos chaînes la
transformation du modèle de france 3
deux chaînes nationales à décrochages
régionaux à chaîne régionale à
décrochage nationale l'offre
d'information qui évidemment
structurantes chez nous qui est toujours
le sel de la télévision et puis enfin un
projet numérique pour toucher tous les
publics avec le doublement des
investissements pour totalement cohérent
avec là aussi ce qu'avait annoncé en
2018 troisième remarque c'est un contrat
d'objectifs et de moyens qui insistent
et a raison sur la nécessité d'avoir une
entreprise ou et des entreprises en
l'occurrence exemplaires en premier lieu
l'attention très marquée à une
représentation plus juste de la société
ce qui veut dire pour nous très
concrètement d'abord la parité la juste
représentation de tous les territoires
et en particulier des territoires
ultramarins
ça s'inscrit chez nous dans un pack de
visibilité que nous mettons en oeuvre et
que nous suivons d'ailleurs en tant que
tel et puis la diversité aussi dans les
programmes au sens du csa tels que le
csa le définit lui même
la deuxième chose en matière
d'exemplarité c'est qu'il insiste aussi
sur l'accessibilité services et
l'inclusion à la fois dans l'entreprise
sur les antennes
il ya une forte hausse du sous titrage
notamment de la chaîne d'information de
de service public et france info on
passe on va passer de 1h20 de
sous-titrage en 2019 on a déjà à monter
une marche assez importante en 2020 mais
on va passer à 6 heures en 2022 et on
est en train de travailler avec des
systèmes d'intelligence artificielle à
une forme de sous titrage automatique
évidemment c'est du direct c'est donc
c'est assez compliqué à sous-titrés pour
pouvoir sous titré si nous pouvons la
totalité de france info les efforts
aussi sur le dieu de réinscription sur
le langage des signes
puisque c'est quand même une des
particularités du service public de
d'être accessible
le plus accessible possible à l'ensemble
des publics et puis enfin aussi les
enjeux de développement durable dans
notre entreprise france et visions ça a
été initiée assez tôt je peux en parler
d'autant plus que c'est mon prédécesseur
qu'il a initié ce plan développement
durable en 2013 et donc on a
différentes démarches des coproductions
on est en train d'éliminer tous les
plastiques tels que ces bouteilles en
plastique progressivement dans la maison
on poursuit un plan climat énergie le
passage aux voitures électriques on a
des plans vélo pour inciter les
collaborateurs à se déplacer voilà un
item d'exemplarité qui est aussi
important en ce moment les dernières
points et j'en viendrais s'arrêterait là
même si il ya une grande cohérence dans
ce comme entre ce qui nous a été
demandée en 2018 la stratégie tels que
elle nous a été développée et ce que
j'ai moi même porter en tant que
présidente de france télévisions quand
je me suis représenté devant le csa en
briguant un deuxième mandat il ya trois
contradiction quand même que je voudrais
un peu soulevé la première c'est qu'on a
des objectifs de couverture qui sont en
hausse donc les couvertures c'est le
nombre de français en fait qui qui
regarde un programme de français vision
une fois par semaine au minimum une fois
par semaine dans un contexte où on va
quand même supprimer une chaîne qui est
france 4 la chaîne des enfants
augmenter le nombre d'enfants qu'on va
toucher en supprimant la chaîne pour
enfants autant dire ça semble quasiment
impossible
voilà donc ça c'est la première marque
et la couverture en général on est
soumis quand même une concurrence des
plateformes qui va grandissant donc
c'est un enjeu difficile
voilà la deuxième difficulté ce n'est
pas une contradiction mais c'est quand
même une difficulté c'est le maintien de
l'équilibré d'exploitation sur la
période
on a des engagements en création qui
augmente on a
voilà certain nombre de missions
supplémentaires je parlais du sous
titrage de france info salaires des
gothiques mais ça représente quand même
des montants assez considérable c'est
pratiquement eu millions d'euros le sous
titrage de france info et dans le même
temps une ressource publique qui
baissent donc c'est pas évident
néanmoins on a pris les devants dès 2018
sont assignées et vous le savez un
accord de gestion prévisionnelle des
emplois avec les avec les organisations
syndicales 85% d'entre elles au sein de
france télévisions qui prévoit une
baisse des effectifs importante 900
personnes en net à fin 2022 ce qui fait
que français vision aura baissé ses
effectifs de plus de 20% en disant que
c'est pas une petit gain de productivité
ça je veux dire c'est un gros gains de
productivité donc dans ce contexte
l'équilibré n'est pas facile à atteindre
ça s'éteint c'est un défi et puis le
troisième point que je relèverai
évidemment ce com met en avant les
synergies entre services publics mais il
est quand même très en deçà de ce qu'on
imaginait comme vous le faisiez remarqué
d'ailleurs monsieur le président de
votre préambule on est on est parti d'un
projet de loi avec une ligne on arrive
finalement avec des synergies qui sont
voilà pas si pacy aux messieurs ce que
ça en définitive donc voilà il ya
peut-être quelque chose de 2 à regarder
sur ce terrain là voilà ce que je
voulais vous dire très rapidement je ne
cherchais pas excéder mais cinq minutes
de madame la présidente le plan
d'affaires du projet de qom de radio
france prévoit une hausse sensible des
ressources propres de l'entreprise de 63
millions d'euros en 2020 à 77 millions
d'euros en 2022
ce qui correspond à une augmentation de
plus de 22 % en deux ans est ce crédible
dans le cadre de la crise sanitaire et
économique que nous connaissons
cette hausse correspond notamment un
accroissement des recettes publicitaires
de 4 millions 7 qui passerait de 51
millions en 2020 à 55,7 millions d'euros
en 2022
le com 2015 2019 prévoyait que sur toute
la durée du comme les ressources
publicitaires ne pourront excéder un
plafond de 40 2 millions d'euros par an
pourquoi la notion de plafond at elle
disparu du nouveau projet de qom est-ce
que vous fixiez des limites en termes de
publicité au delà de la cible de 55,7
millions d'euros mentionnés dans le plan
d'affaires
ne craignez-vous pas enfin que cette
hausse de la publicité porte une
atteinte sérieuse à l'identité des
radios de service public ainsi qu'au
modèle économique des radios privées
merci messieurs ces états pour cette
première question tout d'abord pour
expliquer cette tendance par une raison
extrêmement simple c'est que nous
partons d'un point bas qui est l'année
2020 année de crise durant laquelle il
ya eu une baisse extrêmement importante
des différentes ressources propres et
évidemment des recettes publicitaires
donc que nous ne faisons dans ses
projections la queue retrouver sur la
durée du comme le niveau de recettes de
donc la croissance de nos ressources
propres en particulier celle des
recettes de publicité est liée au fait
que l'on retrouve ce niveau d'avant la
crise
il ya aussi dans le document un élément
qui figure qui élit au matinal filmé et
qui sont liées aux conditions
contractuelles entre france télévisions
et radio france qui se traduisent par
une ressource externe qui obéit à une
logique très différentes
de l'once est le mystère en tout cas
elle est notée tel quel dans le com ce
qui je vous en jeu j'en conviens on rêve
dû être notés différemment en tout cas
c'est une recette qui n'est pas de la
caps et on a peu de recettes
commerciales donc ça en fait partie
pour aller sur le fond du sujet sur
lequel vous m'interrogez c'est à dire
les recettes publicitaires j'appellerai
deux éléments très simple le premier
c'est que nous avons une approche
extrêmement modérée sur nos antennes de
la publicité c'est ce qui nous
différencie des autres acteurs privés de
la radio à la fois en durée
j'oserais un chiffre la durée de la
publicité sur nos antennes est inférieur
sur une journée complète à ce qu'elle
est sur la matinale de l'ain nos
concurrents de l'ensemble de nos
concurrents je devrais dire elle ne
concerne que trois de nos radios sur 7
ce qui vous gêne que sur france culture
sur france musique sur fip sur move par
exemple il n'y a pas de publicité
ensuite on prend des engagements
responsables de parer les obligations
réglementaires qui pèsent sur nous sur
la durée avec des limitations du ray qui
sont extrêmement strictes
d'autre part j'ai pris des engagements
importants de verdissement la publicité
dans l'esprit d'intérêt général qui
s'est lui des messages de publicité sur
nos antennes à ce titre on renonce à
partir du 1er janvier de cette année à
certaines or à la commercialisation de
certains espaces au profit d'acteurs ou
de produits qui sont éco responsable
donc ça répond bien en engagement aussi
important de notre entreprise
ensuite un dernier point puisque je sais
combien c'est une question sur laquelle
les différents acteurs privés sont
extrêmement mobilisés
je note d'ailleurs qui sont très
mobilisés depuis que france inter est
devenue première radio de france
ils sont très mobilisés or je ne pense
pas que la réponse aux difficultés
économiques du secteur soit d'affaiblir
le service public je ne pense pas
d'autant plus que si on devait supprimer
la publicité sur nos antennes
cela n'entraînerait pas de fait un
report de nos auditeurs
chez ces autres acteurs dont san
induirait pas une augmentation de leurs
propres recettes publicitaires elle
dirait sans doute plus probablement chez
les gaffes à ce qui se produit déjà
depuis plusieurs années ce qui explique
d'ailleurs les difficultés économiques
d'une partie du secteur donc affaiblir
le service public de la radio n'est pas
une réponse au modèle économique du
secteur commercial de la radio je pense
aussi qu'il faut une certaine solidarité
d'intro secteur parce que la présence un
acteur fort comme radio france contribue
aussi positivement à la dynamique de
l'ensemble du secteur y compris sur le
prends le plan la publicité beaucoup
d'annonceurs n'irai pas sur le marché
publicitaire de la radio cd radio france
n'y figurait pas voilà c'est très
rapidement les éléments de réponse que
je pouvais vous apporter merci est ce
que certains on trouvera des questions
spécifiques à poser la prison de radio
france 7 plusieurs avoir dit qu'en fait
c'est des questions générales qui
s'adresse aux cinq interlocuteurs est-ce
que hisser globalcom dit david assouline
est ce que quelqu'un une question
spécifique non à ce moment là ce que je
propose c'est qu'on reprenne le fils de
de l'entretien avec toujours les
questions de genre et moins jeunes et
aux autres intervenants
donc ma question s'adresse à madame
delphine ernotte le président de france
télévisions madame la présidente en
juillet 2020 vous avez pris dans votre
projet de candidature france télévisions
notre bien commun
vous avez pris plusieurs engagements
importants qui vous ont permis d'être
choisi par le csa permettez moi d'en
citer quelques-uns vous avez pris
l'engagement que france télévisions
réservera ses premières parties de
soirée aux séries européennes ou
d'expression originale française
vous avez déclaré que vous croyez au
maintien de france quatre offres
numériques et linéaire dédiée à
l'éducation et à la jeunesse
vous avez ensuite proposer une évolution
du cahier des charges de france 5
afin qu'elle devienne la chaîne de la
connaissance et du savoir au service de
la conscience écologique
vous avez annoncé la création avec l'ina
d'un campus des médias ouvert à tous
vous avez également proposé la
transformation de france 3 en un réseau
de 13 offre 100% régional et la création
d'une offre numérique en symbiose avec
france bleu
enfin et c'est peut-être d'ailleurs la
proposition la plus ambitieuse de votre
projet vous avez annoncé la création de
france médias plus une plateforme
d'agrégation numérique commune de tous
les contenus audio et vidéo de
l'audiovisuel public
ma question sera simple comment
expliquez vous que ces engagements très
ambitieux sur lesquels vous avez été
désigné ne se retrouve pas dans le com
où sont mentionnés sous une forme très
édulcoré est-ce que la force de votre
projet ne se trouve pas affaibli par les
choix de l'actionnaire inscrit dans le
code plus généralement quel est
l'intérêt de vous demander de faire un
projet lors de votre candidature si
celui ci
une fois validé par le csa n'engage pas
votre actionnaire
monsieur le sénateur merci de cette
question je sais pas si c'est à moi
tellement d'y répondre en fait d'abord
il ya deux remarques que ce pourrait
faire l'engagement que j'ai pris devant
le csa et qu'il entend bien tenir bien
entendu vos pour mon mandat qui est de
cinq ans alors qu'on voit qui ici notre
contrat d'objectifs et de moyens comme
le faisait remarquer fort justement
marie-christine s'arrête en 2022 donc on
peut imaginer que sur cinq ans on puisse
prendre un peu plus de souffle parce
qu'on a plus de temps pour réaliser des
choses
néanmoins je voudrais quand même relevé
qu'il ya beaucoup de choses qui sont
déjà dans le code truc même vous parlez
de la de la création et de l'orientation
en soutien de la création française
c'est dans le contrat d'objectifs et de
moyens au travers de cet engagement de
500 millions d'investissements annuels
dans la création audiovisuelle française
et j'ai pris moi même l'engagement gelé
a annoncé en début de semaine dernière
parce que c'était notre conférence de
rentrée le 5 janvier qu'il n'y aurait en
effet plus de fictions euros enfin hors
fiction française et européenne
à une exception près ce qui nous reste
encore un stock qui on va diffuser en
juillet donc oui je précise et sinon le
reste de l'année et pour les années qui
viennent on a on va effectivement se
concentrer sur les fictions françaises
et européennes le maintien de france 4
ça ne m'appartient pas je vous ai dit ce
que j'en pensais dans la cohérence en
fait des indicateurs le dollar et france
4 est actée par le gouvernement
j'indique simplement qu'on peut pas
demander
la télévision d'augmenter d'aller au
delà de ce qu'on fait cette année c'est
france 4 a été extrêmement utiles dans
toute la période où l'école était fermée
on a on a été la plus grande salle de
classe de france on a cette année et
encore aujourd'hui parce qu'on est dans
un mode un peu pas confiné mais enfin
quand même particulier d'épidémie un
beaucoup de gens qui sont dans la
télévision beaucoup d'enfants et là on
nous demande en fait d'augmenter notre
présence auprès des enfants par rapport
à ce qu'on a fait cette année en
supprimant la chaîne pour enfants
j'indique juste qu'il ya une incohérence
en fait un voilà sur linas alors ça on
peut en parler parce qu'il se trouve que
j'ai visité une initiative de laurent
vallet qui est absolument formidable et
dont je tiens à souligner le enfin moi
le côté formidable laurent tue et on
parlera mieux que moi mais il a lancé
une classe alpha
qui enfin je vous invite à aller le jeu
fait l'invitation pour toi laurent mais
c'est génial ce qu'il a fait et donc on
va je vais me mettre en fait dans la
roue de laurent 1 et finalement faire
des projets ensemble s'est inventé
autant les lits des pics temps en temps
se mettre dans la roue de celui qui sait
le faire en l'occurrence c'est laurent à
l'ina et donc on a on a un projet
effectivement de campus alpha on va le
rebaptiser pour reprendre le nom que que
le roi a trouvé et tu en verras mieux
que moi sur les offres aux régionales là
c'est assez cohérent avec ce qui est
inscrit dans le coffre je crois même si
moi je souhaite aller plus loin mais ça
c'est peut-être un peu là là là voilà le
l'élan supplémentaire parce que j'ai un
mandat de cinq ans et france médias plus
alors ça moi je crois d'ailleurs s'il
l'a dit un camp quand tous ici on donne
nos podcasts finalement à radio france
c'est une manière de de faire cette
plate forme c'est-à-dire de regrouper
par par grandes thématiques
moi je pense que le son en est une si on
regarde la bbc qu est un peu le modèle
de cette fameuse holding il ya bbc news
l'aïe player émis 6 à 11 ans donc il ya
trois grandes plates formes en réalité
donc que radio france et le lead sur le
podcast
ça me semble logique c'est pour ça qu'on
a tous accepté d'ailleurs de donner nos
podcasts à radio france 1
voilà donc ça c'est dans cette idée là
de construction d'offres qui se
répondent les unes aux autres et qui se
renforcent les unes aux autres les unes
les autres
voilà pour répondre rapidement donc la
raison de continuer ça n'amène pas
forcément de réponse et puis j'aimerais
aussi que mes collègues y compris ce que
je salue qui sont en visio puisse poser
des questions alors j'entends bien la
question du temps madame la présidente
surtout que
vous parliez de com de trois ans en fait
c'est un homme comme l'a dit le
président de deux ans ce qui est déjà
sur un point de vue juridique
borderline mais il y avait urgence
maintenant quand même à force de se
hâter avec lenteur je pense que on a
besoin d'accélérer maintenant tu as
d'autres questions a proposé aux parties
votre ma troisième question s'adresse à
madame marie-christine saragosse
présidente directrice générale de france
médias monde
le projet de qom de france médias monde
insiste sur la vocation universelle des
offres proposées
pourtant ces programmes restent
difficilement accessibles en france
alors que ce sont les téléspectateurs
français qui les financent à travers la
cape tandis que la diffusion
internationale recule dans plusieurs
territoires et notamment en amérique du
nord
que prévoyez-vous pour accroître la
diffusion en france même
par exemple sur le des abbés plus pour
rfi et monte carlo doualiya et à
l'international par exemple pour
france24 aux états unis sachant
notamment que la chaîne n'est plus
diffusé à washington
merci monsieur le sénateur alors en
effet la vocation universelle de notre
groupe est très importante c'est à ce
prix qu'on a vocation à rivaliser avec
d'autres grands opérateurs
internationaux qui n'ont pas de
frontières non plus sur sur terre et je
vous remercie aussi de souligner que ce
sont les téléspectateurs et auditeurs
enfin français en tout cas les
téléspectateurs puisque c'est le poste
de télévision qui déclenche la redevance
aujourd'hui qui financent notre groupe
et c'est une fierté d'ailleurs et c'est
ce qui garantit comme je le disais tout
à l'heure
notre influence parce que nous pouvons
dire que nous sommes financés par les
citoyens français directement par une
recette affecté alors c'est bien normal
qu'ils en aient leur tour ils l'ont aux
faux puisque france 24 dans ces trois
langues le français l'anglais et l'arabe
est disponible sur tout le territoire
alors le territoire métropolitain france
24 était également distribuer en tnt
aller sur le câble et satellite à jeudi
passée antennes t elle été distribués
dans les dom-tom l'existence de france
info dans laquelle nous coopérons dans
laquelle nous fournissons des programmes
entre minuit et 6 heures ce qui
correspond d'ailleurs pas toujours
avenue et 6h dans les dans les outre-mer
dans les autres mers ça peut être au
contraire un prime time et en plus avec
france info ont fourni deux magazines 7
duplex par jour des journaux
internationaux donc effectivement quand
on cherche des économies
ça semble moins préjudiciable de rester
sur le câble et de satellite et ne plus
être sur la tnt dans les dom-tom que de
disparaître par exemple d'afrique
si vous perdez transféré en fait une
économie beaucoup transformée en même
temps c'est pas france 24 et diffuser
ses biens france info delphine que le
confie c'est notre c'est d'autres frais
commune met donc en tout cas toujours
est il que alors on va sortir également
de l'île de france où on était depuis
plusieurs années en tnt
ça fait partie de la trajectoire
budgétaire d'économies pourquoi toujours
parce qu'on est déjà sur france info
mais aussi parce que les équipements ont
changé et que en ile-de-france très
sincèrement les gens qui ont un mono
équipements tnt sont très marginaux et
qu'aujourd'hui comme on est sur le câble
le satellite l'adsl tout ce qui bouge
ils vont nous retrouver et on va
s'évertuer à ce qu'ils nous retrouvent
ailleurs
et puis par ailleurs notre notoriété
n'est pas la même aujourd'hui qu'en 2013
et donc cette exposition sur la tnt sur
le canal 33
dites 33 ai demandé comment va le monde
et bien elle a servi ses objectifs donc
on va pouvoir le faire
alors ça c'est pour france 24 en france
sur le territoire français vous parlez
du des habits plus monsieur le sénateur
est en effet c'est notre relais de
croissance en complémentarité avec les
radios de radio france rfi est donc
présente en fm là pour le coup on line
de france elle est présente à lyon lille
strasbourg marseille en plein
confinement valence et marseille hurd
avait plus bordeaux toulouse en novembre
dernier
donc rfi à un bon maillage des grandes
villes si d'autres appels d'offres
étaient faits dans des dans des villes
en plus un enjeu de diversité culturelle
et de cohésion sociale on serait tout à
fait partant les sommes dues des abbés
plus sont raisonnables par rapport au
coût des fm et monte carlo doualiya fait
l'objet d'une préemption de la mise de
la culture la très récemment pour être
présente en ile de france et à marseille
où là aussi on a eu une expérience très
positive à marseille à quelques années
je pense qu'une radio arabophone
républicaine laïque peut avoir un rôle
et on est très proches d'ailleurs des
autres radios du sirti on aime beaucoup
travailler avec les autres radios
associatives sur les états unis
alors le fait est que quand vous avez
des contrats à millions d'euros par
ville c'est une façon il ya plusieurs
façons de censurer les chaînes
étrangères à buzz politique et puis ça
peut être financier alors là aux états
unis
ces financiers c'est très très cher et
quand on vous demande des économies vous
avez un contrat 900000 euros sur
seulement new york
vous êtes très tentés de ne pas le
renouveler plutôt que de faire de casse
est ailleurs alors mais pour autant on
n'est pas totalement suicidaire et on
s'est dit que malgré tout il fallait il
fallait qu on mise sur la maturité
technologique des états unis c'est quand
même une zone et donc on a tiré cette
carte alors est ce qu'on a on n'a pas le
choix de toute façon comme ça c'était
plus simple mais au tt réseaux sociaux
applications alors qu'est ce que ça
donne en 2020 les les usa son deuxième
pays en termes de visites sur nos
environnements numériques propres après
la france le premier pli c'est la france
est le deuxième c'est ce sont les états
unis et ça ils représentent quand même
10 % des fréquentations de sites
propriétaires soit à peu près 80
millions de
visite en 2020 et puis sur youtube là
aussi sur les usa qui nous regardent le
plus après la france et en plus ils nous
regardent terriblement longuement parce
que sur youtube les durées sont courtes
et une regarde plus de 8 minutes en
moyenne donc c'est on est bon et on est
noté très bien c'est à dire on est notée
l'équivalent de la bbc mais devant
toutes les autres chaînes
internationales en anglais aux états aux
états unis donc on est bien aimé on est
aussi au pentagone à l'onu à la maison
blanche et au congrès au capitole
voilà donc c'est beau c'est bien donc
personne ne nouveaux fans où on voit pas
ce qui se passe à la maison blanche je
veux dire c'est la maison blanche ce qui
peut nous regarder voilà donc je pense
que on l'hôte et et se développe
ça nous permet de mettre le français
l'anglais et l'espagnol
aux etats unis parce que c'est une
langue importante et on était obligé de
faire ce pari mais je crois qu'il va
marcher quand même et qu'on n'est pas du
tout absent d'ailleurs la preuve on a
une interview exclusive du conseiller du
chef de la gestion épidémique de au
début par de 30 de l'épidémie de kovy
deux états unis antonio fauci il nous a
accordé une interview exclusive et le
parti républicain a fait ses clips en
piquant les images de france 24 en
anglais on a dû j'ai dû intervenir
donc s'il faut croire qu'on est quand
même passé absent des états unis voilà
merci deux dernières questions
jean-raymond cette question s'adresse au
président du directoire d'arte et france
monsieur bruno patino lors de votre
dernière audition à l'occasion de
l'examen du budget vous aviez indiqué qu
arte france souhaitait développer la
co-création européenne de ce qui
nécessitait une évolution de la
réglementation des droits au niveau
européen vous en avait parlé dans votre
propos liminaire le projet de qom
mentionne la nécessité d'une obtention
de droits équivalents de diffusion et
l'exploitation à l'échelle européenne
mais n'évoque aucune méthode ni aucun
calendrier pour atteindre cet objectif
pourquoi ce manque de précision est ce
le signe que l'actionnaire n'entend pas
agir afin de faire évoluer au niveau
national et aux européens la
réglementation sur les droits attachés
aux productions
plus généralement comment comptez-vous
développer votre ambition en matière de
production européenne merci beaucoup
alors évidemment le tout stratégie
européenne passe par une disponibilité
et une capacité d'obtenir des droits
européens et aujourd'hui ce qui fait
d'une certaine façon la spécificité
d'arte et c'est qu'on a l'habitude de
construire au cas par cas des des
disponibilités européenne pour pour
chacune quasiment chacune de nos
productions
quand on peut financièrement se le
permettre encore une fois il ya deux
économies qui sont totalement
différentes en termes de droit européen
les fictions et tout le reste tout le
reste est assez accessible aujourd'hui
les fictions depuis l'éruption des
plateformes mondiale avoir des droits
européens pour les fictions est quelque
chose qui paradoxalement est
techniquement plus facile et
économiquement plus inaccessibles donc
aujourd'hui ce que nous faisons c'est au
cas par cas avec la production avec les
pros avec les différents producteurs
négocier une extension européenne de
leurs droits
on le fait au sein d' art et france ô le
fait au sein du gie eu lieu aussi et
comme vous le savez une partie de la
stratégie européenne voire toute la
stratégie européenne d'arreter passe par
le g au lieu
nous avons un certain nombre de chaînes
partenaires aussi donc pour nous si vous
voulez clairement dans les années qui
viennent
l'ambition c'est et vous me pardonnerez
ce terme qui ne réflète pas de façon
très juste ce que nous allons faire mais
c'est d'industrialiser ou en tout cas de
deux de faire que ce soit pas à chaque
fois un artisanat ou de la haute couture
pour chacun des programmes parce que
sinon ça demande évidemment beaucoup de
temps beaucoup de beaucoup de beaucoup
d'agilité pour chacun des programmes
donc ça c'est un enjeu mais qui ne peut
se faire qu'au sein j'allais dire
qu'avec l'accord à la fois des cadres
réglementaires d'une part et des
différentes sociétés de production
d'autres donc le ge pour nous est un bon
endroit
en plus en écho avec le air pur pour
avancer dans ce domaine
je me permets de mentionner ce qui n'est
pas un détail que le le vice-président
du ge com comme vous le savez la france
à la présidence du g us en ce moment et
je l'exercé le président le
vice-président du ge qui est monsieur
péter gruber et le directeur juridique
de la zdf est très très actif au sein de
l'ue air mais mais mais delphine ernotte
en parlerait mieux que moi au sein de la
commission juridique de l'ue air donc je
pense car tu es peut être effectivement
un facilitateur dans la création de
solutions on va dire industrielle jamais
vraiment mille guimet à industriels pour
leur européaniser les droits par
ailleurs comme vous l'avez mentionné je
veux pas être trop long là dessus une de
nos ambitions c'est de remonter petit à
petit la collaboration européenne c'est
à dire que là aussi art est pour moi un
rôle absolument centrale aujourd'hui
nous coproduisons beaucoup
la grande majorité de nos fictions sont
des coproductions européennes des
coproductions ça veut dire évidemment
des financements de plusieurs
partenaires européens nous sommes
rentrés depuis un certain nombre
d'années déjà dans un mécanisme de
co-création alors de temps en temps de
co-création un pays prend en charge le
développement fait participer d'autres
pays nous avons parfois aussi au sein de
mécanismes spécifiques eu des bureaux
d'écriture qui qui comment dire
regrouper deux nationalités ça ne vous
surprendra pas de savoir que c'était la
nationalité allemande et nationalité
française évidemment pour arte je
mentirais en disant que c'est
extrêmement simple mais en même temps je
mentirais aussi en disant que ça
n'apporte pas des choses absolument
absolument fascinante dans la complexité
des récits et dans la capacité de voir
que effectivement ces récits né de
plusieurs de plusieurs regards européens
donnent une profondeur forte donc dans
les années qui viennent notamment dans
les coproductions en termes de fiction
nous allons passer à une étape
supérieure en essayant d'instaurer des
mécanismes d'incubation d'écriture au
sein du gie eu lieu bonjour à tous ses
meilleurs voeux encore à nos présidents
des hôtels publics français pour une
année qui s'annonce un peu difficile
compte tenu de la persistance de la de
la crise sanitaire dira peut-être en
préambule que nous sommes tout de même
nombreux à regretter la suppression de
cette réforme ou du visuel tout
simplement parce qu'on ne fait que
reculer à un certain nombre de problèmes
qu'il y avait à résoudre je remercie
mari fils saragosse d'avoir souligné la
fragilité finalement directement de ce
com qui ne porte que sur deux ans
j'aurai mon bonnet l'a rappelé il est
presque hors la loi puisque les comme
c'est minimum de 3 à 5 ans et donc le
fait de ne pas avoir traité cette
question de la réforme
ça laisse l'audiovisuel de toute façon
dans une forme de fragilité
à l'échéance 2022 vous avant les
élections majeures
et ne faut jamais sous-estimer la
possibilité de l'arrivée ou au
gouvernement la tête de l'état de
gouvernement justement qui pourrait
avoir tentation de réformer profondément
la devance pour la supprimer
avec kinshasa bien évoquer le risque
qu'ils auraient de se conformer une
dotation publique pour une dotation
d'état
ça parle à l'indépendance de nos
entreprises de l'audiovisuel public donc
je souligne la fragilité de ce code mais
en même temps bien entendu le côté
positif les cinq indicateurs communs les
sagas sion spécifiques dans les
indicateurs comme un agent sera une de
mes premières questions à l'ensemble des
présidents de l'audiovisuel public n'est
pas évoqué la question des publics dits
empêcher j'ai bien noté que la recherche
de la diversité de la parité et
d'égalité professionnelle tout ça relève
d'ailleurs ce qu'on appelle plus
largement les droits culturels dans une
certaine mesure inscrit dans la loi par
le sénat
et j'imagine que c'est un des objectifs
forts aussi que vous portez que celui de
la tension à la question des publics
empêchés du handicap mais j'aimerais
vous entendre de peut-être en reparler
un satisfecit bien sûr pour ce qui est
le modèle vertueux de l'entreprise à
savoir le respect environnemental on
dise que je serais tout à fait ma
question plus large les transversales
serait de vous demander comment vous
avez travaillé et préparé
c'est comme vous êtes il était demandé
concrètement de travailler en équipe et
de constituer en quelque sorte aussi un
bilan des actions qui vous ont
rapprochés puisque c'était un peu
l'objectif notamment par exemple à
travers la question des matinales france
3 france bleu la question de france info
à tignes yat-il un bilan de le france
info qu' un petit peu décevant en terme
d'audience donc comment on corrige le
tir
comment on gros travail de la
transversalité entre vos différentes
équipes
est-ce que vous avez travaillé la
question comme l'a évoqué tout à l'heure
pour nos patino d'un bouquet éditorial
par exemple on va prendre le thème de
j'ai passé par une information prônons
le thème de la jeunesse qui est très
important puisque on va supprimer
malheureusement en scat en dépit la
réformation de delphine ernotte de la
nécessité de cette chaîne pour porter
l'ambition pour la jeunesse qu'y at il
donc à un travail sur les objectifs à
atteindre de vraiment ensemble cibler la
jeunesse avec une déclinaison
programmatique d'une entreprise à
l'autre permettant voilà une offre
extrêmement force et on pourrait parler
de l'ensemble des thèmes bien entendu le
sport la culture mais je vais pas trop
être longue sur ces sujets ma deuxième
question porte sur l'ambition universel
de notre audiovisuel public même chose
comment avez vous travaillé entre france
télévisions qui forcément envoie aussi
des reporteurs à l'étranger france
médias mandant c'est le coeur de métier
mais aussi art et pardonnez moi de ne
pas citer tout le monde comme elle vous
avait travaillé ensemble cette dimension
universelle et cet approfondissement
européen cette stratégie européenne si
nécessaire peut-être marie christine
saragosse pourra-t-elle de manière
spécifique d'ailleurs expliqué le
travail qui est fait et à y at-il assez
de moyens dans ce contrat d'objectifs et
de moyens selon vous pour toutes cette
ambition notamment de lutter contre la
désinformation
ce qu'on appelle les uns fox mais aussi
la radicalisation il ya ce programme en
européen enter qui est certainement
extrêmement important somme toute est ce
que ce com selon vous décline qu'il a
suffisamment ambitieux en matière de
moyens pour porter ce rôle qui est
devenu fondamental de notre devise est
lé public à l'heure de la mondialisation
et de la puissance des dégâts femmes et
on l'a vu dans la crise c'est à dire que
plus que j'avais lu est important pour
course la voilà en quelques sortes mais
mes questions elles sont assez peu
nombreuses parce que nous sommes
nombreux à vouloir intervenir
merci catherine david assouline
merci monsieur le président merci à tous
les patrons et patronnes de
l'audiovisuel public
non seulement nous avoir exposé ses com
et mais d'avoir travailler à leur mise
en place
sur la forme il ya une avancée certaine
qu'ils aient ces indicateurs communs ça
commence à nous donner une idée d'une
spécificité global de l'audiovisuel
public et pas dans quelque chose qui
s'égayent et qui n'est pas visible
ça compense qu'en partie le fait qu'il
n'y aura pas de audi il n'y a pas de
marque commune comme peut l'être la bbc
mais saâdane a quelque chose d'important
je regrette quand il s'agit de comme
puisqu'il s'agit de suivre des
indicateurs et tout donc quelque chose
de très aussi techno précis concrets
qu'on se soustraient à l'exercice
minimum qui est l'évaluation du comme
précédent parce que quand même derrière
faire semblant qu'à chaque fois
recommence à zéro parce que quand on
commence à avoir quelques années de
mandat on en a vu des corps et des
engagements et des trucs qui deux ans
après n'était même pas discuter dire que
les budgets étaient complètement
différent les objectifs changé et on
disait pas ben voilà là on a échoué là
sympa était donc on a rectifié ce même
pas où on fait qu'à chaque fois comme si
on a inventé l'eau chaude
bon donc 2022 qu'est espérons que ce
soit pas une majorité si différentes que
discutera pas deux comme nés de enfin
bon
donc ça c'est sur la forme pourquoi n'y
a pas d'évaluation si on veut dans la
culture des indicateurs tatatata et
pourquoi et bravo pour cette mise en
commun
je regrette une chose qui est que vous
n'évoquez pas et qui est complètement
acquis dans les indicateurs communs
culture création jeunesse éducation
d'information proximité ofp l'action
extérieure très bien donc on a décidé
que un pas gigantesque dans le jeu du
linéaire
parce que il ya les spécificités du
linéaire qui fait qu'on regarde encore
la télé qu'on écoute la radio et qu'on
n'est pas que sur des plateformes
donc ça c'est la force de ce que vous
représentez
c'est le direct et dans le direct il ya
un marché gigantesque entre guillemets
marché c'est le sport qui se regardent
direct donc le service public a
abandonné l'idée qu'il pouvait avoir un
quelconque rôle
jeudi alain papot concurrentiel mais un
quelconque rôle spécifique pour ce
double dont le pays qui organisent les
jo en 2021 voilà je lance ça avec la
crise
mediapro et c'est du financement du foot
n'est qu'une partie du sport je pense
que il serait bon de relancer ce débat
sérieusement très sérieusement parce que
l'audiovisuel public ne peut pas
abandonner ce qui est la lisibilité la
plus populaire et la plus fédératrice de
nos concitoyens que le sport point qu'on
peut juger à la culture et où moi je
suis sereine dans la culture vous le
savez et je la mets en avant et je la
défends mais là cet abandon de quelque
chose très populaire et de
spécifiquement linéaire et de partage
d'émotions de deux communes
extraordinaire le service public dit
c'est pas mon truc
bon voilà ça c'est sur la forme juste
une chose je connais l'exercice
compliqué que vous avez parce que vous
ne pouvait être que satisfait autres
guillemets de vos com même quand voilà
en france 4 qui est un engagement
important de delphine ernotte et mis à
la poubelle alors je dis pas que rien
n'assure la jeunesse a je pense pas ou
plus que vous l'aurez accepté mais
davantage c'est que nous politique où on
pense toujours qu'on peut faire bouger
les choses et on n'a pas de patron des
tutelles enfin certains en ont mais qu'à
moi je peux vous dire que jusqu'à la
dernière minute
je ferai tout pour que franska ne ferme
pas un peut-être perdre à l'état mais on
a moins perdu doté des frondes a gagné
des médailles
donc ça c'est vraiment incroyable
si un confinement vous allez voir
incroyable parce que tout le monde est
d'accord je ne rencontre pas une
personne de droite ou de gauche ou
professionnels ou spécialistes ou
impliqués dans l'audiovisuel qui me
disent c'est bien de fermer france 4
mars elle vient d'où ce truc là
le président a dit mais où on est mais
on est franchement c'est scandaleux
des fois il ya des pots et on écoute les
vrais arguments notamment l'argument
financière aurait pu en être un or il a
été battu en brèche parce que ça coûte
pas grand chose et que forcément le fait
de
quand même faire une offre va donc je
veux le soulever je veux féliciter
votre travail et tout mais je vois bien
que on demande de faire bien mieux
qui à la concurrence des plateformes
tout ça et bien analyser on demande de
faire la révolution numérique et de
l'approfondir avec des vrais objectifs
mais sur fonds propres et on diminue
globalement d'ici 2022
la dotation donc ça c'est inacceptable
non plus on va pas faire semblant qu'on
est content parce qu'il faudra rectifier
cela
et la question de la deûle a fait
consensus
maintenant de la redevance universel du
fait que l'audiovisuel soit entièrement
financé par ce tuyau pour assurer
l'indépendance de l'âme saragosse a dit
les choses telles que nous les pinceaux
mais pareil il ya consensus et ceux qui
gouvernent la partie bercy que ce soit
sous la gauche ou sous la droite
actuelle fait toujours la même chose
elle empêche pas ce qu'avait consensus
aussi moi je travaille concrètement à la
mise en place de cela dans le
quinquennat précédent et j'ai vu qu'on
m'a dit l'année prochaine l'année
prochaine l'année prochaine là où là dès
l'année prochaine les prochaines années
prochaines
donc deux quinquennats où il y avait
plus ou moins un consensus politique
pour papa retard par rapport à des
usages et rien n'a bougé
donc il faudra parler ensemble très fort
là dessus je suis d'accord avec marie
christine saragosse
merci julien bargeton qui ensuite céline
brulin julien s'est tu nous entends
julien oui très bien évidement les
sujets numériques est ce que vous pouvez
nous préciser un peu ce que vous
attendez notamment de sato de la façon
dont vous travaillez ensemble et quels
sont les objectifs précis que que vous
attendez sur sur le sujet du numérique
peut-être pour approfondir un peu le
débat qui a juste été abordés pour
l'instant merci céline brulin merci ce
président merci mesdames messieurs le
président je parle plus près du micro
pour ma part je mets connaissait cet
exercice et je voudrais dire ma
frustration pas du tout à l'égard de vos
interventions qui sont très éclairantes
mais en fait on a face à nous et on ne
peut interroger qu'une partie des
acteurs d'un contrat et pour nous c'est
quand même un peu compliqué parce que ça
éveille forcément des questions d'autres
l'ont dit avant moi bien qu'on voudrait
poser à l'état actionnaire tout
simplement et on vous met dans la
difficulté de devoir y répondre à sa
place et y compris nous nous ne
partageons pas toujours les chouettes
septs états actionnaires donc on est
aussi en difficulté pour vous
questionnez voilà et puis je rejoins
tout ce qui a été dit par mes
prédécesseurs sur la fragilité à
laquelle conduit ce
c'est comme à laquelle conduit c'est
comme d'une durée raccourcie
je vais vous dire même un peu mon
inquiétude parce que j'entends qu'en
2022 il ya des élections importantes
mais c'est précisément pas pour me
rassurer que le calendrier soit calé sur
ça pour des raisons d'indépendance
et puis pour quelques inquiétudes qu'on
peut aussi nourrir sur ce qui se passe
dans notre pays à la lumière de ce qui
se passe dans d'autres pays de par le
monde
alors vous avez tous dit et david
assouline disait que vous ne pouviez pas
faire autrement que de vous satisfaire
de ces com et vous avez quand même tous
10 ans vous en satisfaisant que que les
choses étaient extrêmement difficiles à
mettre en oeuvre dans certains domaines
après et je voudrais souligner des
efforts déjà extrêmement conséquent qui
ont été mis en oeuvre ces dernières
années
donc pour éclairer le débat public et
les parlementaires que nous sommes est
ce que vous pourriez aller un petit peu
plus loin pour préciser très
concrètement sur quoi vont porter
précisément les difficultés qu'on peut
attendre dans les mois et les jours à
venir
ensuite il ya eu 1 est un élément quand
même important c'est la directive et
sema puisqu'on voit bien que à terme il
ya des enjeux de financement très
important quelle est votre réflexion je
déborde un peu le cadre de l'exercice
d'aujourd'hui mais quelle est votre
réflexion sur la manière dont pourrait
être réparti ses nouvelles recettes
parce que je crois que aux côtés de la
contribution à l'audiovisuel c'est
évidemment quelque chose qui a regardé
ensuite j'ai posé la question d'une
manière un peu détournée si rêvons un
peu
on pouvait se dire que d'ores et déjà on
peut mettre des avenants à ses com parce
qu'on considère qu'on est dans une
situation de crise plus durable qu'on ne
l'avait imaginé et que effectivement ça
a été dit
4 a montré tout son intérêt en matière
éducative
on ne sait pas ce qu'il va advenir dans
les prochains jours les prochaines
semaines de l'éducation des enfants
mais on pourrait dire la même chose du
spectacle vivant et du fait que les
lieux culturels sont toujours fermés
donc si d'aventuré ensemble nous
pouvions dire que la crise est durable
et de que donc ça amène peut-être à
revoir un peu c'est comme pour répondre
à la crise que nous traversions quelles
seraient les priorités que vous voudriez
définir et enfin vous êtes un certain
nombre et je trouve que c'est une
réflexion très juste avoir insisté sur
le besoin de proximité particulièrement
dans le contexte est ce que vous
pourriez aussi la préciser un peu les
choses
je pense évidemment à france ô qui
manque à beaucoup mais il ya eu par le
passé aussi des inquiétudes sur des
décrochages régionaux de france 3 etc
dans un contexte et j'en termine là deux
régions administratives qui sont
aujourd'hui des territoires un peu
bizarroïdes par moments faim qu'ils
correspondent tout à fait à de vrais
bassin de vie et donc comment se traduit
la proximité dans ce contexte là je vous
remercie
si des questions qui s'adresse un peu
après chacun d'entre eux peut être que
delphine ernotte commencé alors merci
monsieur le président
je vais essayer de répondre à cet
ensemble de questions tout d'abord je
voudrais prendre un peu ma ma casquette
européenne puisque bruno patino il
faisait allusion depuis le 1er janvier
je suis présidente des télévisions et
radios publiques européennes
donc c'est lui le r le fameux er d'une
très vieille association qui a plus de
70 ans qui regroupe 56 pays et qui met
déjà en partage un certain nombre de
choses donc il faut savoir que les
sujets d'information sont partagés entre
membres publique de l'ue air depuis
soixante ans que nous que nous en tant
que m
répondons à des appels d'offres sur les
droits sportifs et c'est là dessus que
je voulais en venir parce que je crois
que david assouline a complètement
raison sur le sport ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est que comme vous l'avez
signalé nos moyens baissent enfin bon on
va pas on va pas dire autre chose non
voyants baisse et les droits sportifs
augmente de manière considérable et par
ailleurs comme il ya aussi une
compétition effrénée des médias globaux
que sont amazon aurait bien vu un roland
garros a donné ses matches du soir
amazon 1
eh bien on se retrouve dans une dans une
forme de squeeze donc si il n'y a pas de
sport dans le com
c'est pas de notre fait déjà mais c'est
aussi parce que finalement on ne peut
pas établir de stratégie sur le sport
alors qu'on a plus les moyens
d'augmenter les droits sportifs que nous
mettons sur la table et on n'a même plus
les moyens au niveau européen
je vous donne un exemple et là ça
concerne pas la france mais c'est avec
ma casquette européenne pour les jeux
paralympiques que les services publics
européens défendent depuis des années
nous on les senteurs de jeux
paralympiques sur nos antennes tous les
services publics européens défendent les
jeux paralympiques
il ya eu un appel d'offres du comité
olympique ils ont choisi non pas la
totalité des services européens mais une
agence de droit chinoise voilà qui va se
charger de vendre les droits
paralympiques
il ya un moment si vous voulez on peut
pas être nous sur des missions pur de
service public à défendre l'intérêt
général
la meilleure exposition des compétitions
sportives et à voir par ailleurs
finalement voilà les comités qui joue un
autre jeu pour quoi 2 millions d'euros
moi je dis ça parce que je trouve que là
on est dans une espèce de
on est dans un squeeze économique et je
pense que ça sera préjudiciable
je pense qu'il finira pas y avoir une
crise c'est quand on verra que
finalement la bonne vieille télé c'est
encore 4 français sur 5 toutes les
semaines qui regarde france télévisions
etc etc c'est la même chose partout en
europe
quand on verra que les télés privées
sont extrêmement mise à mal par la
difficulté du marché publicitaire et que
en europe les seuls télé indépendante
ça va être et radio d'ailleurs un des
seuls médias indépendants s'arrêtent les
médias de service public on sera bien
content d'avoir des médias de service
public fort voilà et le sport ça en fait
partie
le sport en fait partie les les
émissions quotidiennes en font partie
parce que ce cas la télévision et que
non pas nos concurrents
c'est cette espèce de lien c'est le
plaisir de regarder la même chose
ensemble au même moment d'avoir la même
émotion et ça on sait maintenant de
piles confirmant que ça une énorme
valeur et ça ça se joue tous les jours
au travers de la formation mais des
rendez vous quotidiens pour les gens
avec leurs animateurs avec ses tableaux
avec des émissions récurrentes faut pas
oublier qu'il ya des millions de gens
qui vivent seules en france 10 millions
de gens qu'on peut rien dans leur agenda
le lendemain si ce n'est des je l'espère
ce c'est notre fierté
un rendez vous avec une émission de
france télévisions voilà c'est ça la
réalité humaine est ce qui fait ça c'est
les rendez vous quotidien le sport les
grands événements qui peuvent être des
grands spectacles vivants des grands
moments de partage et donc effectivement
il faut qu'on arrive à préserver à la
fois la création mais aussi ce qui est
le propre de la télévision donc le flux
le sport est donc je remercie d'ailleurs
sprint c'est une bonne remarque alors
ben vous nous avez interpellé moi je
vous
j'adore ces début de l'année
on peut faire des voeux j'en ai deux
extrêmement concret le premier je le dis
c'est sur france 4
je pense que voilà on peut être qu'on
pourrait attendre un peu la fin de tout
ça pour pour fermer france 4 et on sait
pas qu'on va être la fin ça c'est une
première la première remarque et la
deuxième c'est france info parce que
madame morin desailly en parallèle on
parle toujours de ce qu'on sait pas
faire il ya quand même une chose qu'on a
su extrêmement bien faire tous ensemble
je dis bien tous ensemble ces fausses
infos on a des duplex avec
marie-christine les pas si de l'ina soit
génial on à radio france qui qui poste
des choses aussi sur numérique sur tout
ça tout ça dès des antennes des heures
d'antenne quotidienne commune avec radio
france donc france info il faut vous
dire quand même que la bbc est venu voir
comment on avait fait la rai est venu
voir que l'on allait faire les pays du
nord de l'europe sont venus voir comment
on avait fait donc tout le monde est
fier de france info sauf nous enfin ici
je veux dire donc dans mais je le dis
parce que bon il ya des trucs qu'on fait
bien faut quand même le dire
voilà donc pour revenir à france info
moi mon souhait c'est un canal qui
expose mieux france info il faut savoir
qu'entre le canal 30 on est à peu près
le canal 15 vous x de l'audience en
cemex et mécanique parce qu'il ya encore
beaucoup de gens pour une télécommande
et qu'il faut 1 2 3 4 5 et c'est donc
voilà donc j'ai deux souhaite très
simple faisable à notre échelle on a
besoin de changer la réglementation pour
répondre à votre sollicitation gentil de
jeu
monsieur bargeton doivent aussi posé la
question sur le numérique
vous avez raison énormément de projets
qu'on a je réponds aussi au travers de
ça à la question de mme morin dessailly
qui nous a interrogé sur comment on
avait travaillé en fait ça fait déjà pas
mal d'années qu'on travaille ensemble il
faut il faut le dire tous ici on se
connaît bien
d'ailleurs ça nous manque nos réunions
de partenaires parce que là on peut plus
les faire à cause de la pandémie mais on
a monté quand même beaucoup de projets
ensemble franceinfo bien sûr lumni on
oublie de le dire monsieur sy non bibi
[Rires]
que nous avons lancé relancer en fait
tous ensemble quand même fin 2019
on a été bien inspiré parce que
heureusement voilà voilà
il ya maintenant un élève sur deux un
prof sur deux qui connaît lui nie donc
voilà c'est quand même heureusement
qu'on a tous ensemble refabriquer 7,7
nature inconnue culture prime alors
c'est moins connu parce que c'est pas du
linéaire c'est sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est des pastilles mais ça bon ben
voilà ça existe et ça marche très très
bien
donc voilà donc on est dans une
dynamique en réalité donc il ya déjà
tout ce qu'on a fait qu'on va continuer
à faire grandir
et puis tous les projets nouveaux et là
dessus je pense qu'on a oui un peu de
rationalisation à faire donc en effet si
on peut être si on peut arriver à faire
sur le reste ce qu'on a fait sur france
info c'est se mettre tous derrière une
même ombrelle et ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui c'est la première source
d'information sur numérique en france 1
donc c'est voilà on est on est leader
sur sur la formation
eh bien je pense qu'on pourra faire des
merveilles donc ça reste à construire
mais c'est quand même dans une dynamique
extrêmement positive voilà je sais pas
si j'ai pas été un peu longue mais
est-ce que d'autres personnes âgées je
voulais avec le rebond d'hier battue
devait partir non non je vais répondre
dans l'ordre alors parce que catherine
morin dessailly évoqué la question des
handicapés il me semblait que le service
public se doit de
d'être vigilant là dessus et que c'est
bien dans l'indicateur du kof c'est à
dire que sousse et toutes les diversités
et notamment le handicap et nous par
exemple on a un indicateur de plan
d'action très précis et d'ailleurs
delphine mentionné qu'elle allait sous
titré tout france info en pour les
soussignés et c'était effectivement
c'est un automatique m'en mets donc
c'était clairement un des objectifs
communs fort du secteur je voulais je
voulais le dire je dire aussi que en
termes de coordination bien sûr on a on
a fait le bilan de ce qu'on faisait déjà
ensemble mais j'étais un tout petit peu
étonné par la question de david
assouline sur l'évaluation parce que
chaque année on présente un bilan du com
année après année avec tous les
indicateurs et dieu sait qu'il y en a 30
on vient le présenter en commission on
vient de prétendre au csa enfin rang
conseil d'administration devant ces
mêmes formalisé par la loi alors
peut-être qu'ils voulaient dire c'est la
trajectoire générale sur de bilan alors
le fait est que la les com qui avait il
était arrêté depuis longtemps puisqu'on
avait plus les trajectoires financière
mais on avait quand même les objectifs
mais donc je comprends mais sinon il est
pas mais sur leur combi oui mais en même
temps chaque année quand on vient de
présenter devant les instances eux on
peut voir si on si ça a du sens il me
semble quand même on a une la loi
encadre ça mais je pense qu'ils
voulaient parler aussi de la durée
complète et du fait que c'était rarement
respectés dans leur durée complète
je reviens pas sur l'abandon du sport
parce que des pilatus
dire que nous à notre modeste échelle en
radio on garde quand même tous les
droits mondiaux et on l'est on les a pas
encore perdu pour le privé et par
exemple pour l'afrique franchement on
aurait pas autant de succès si on
n'avait pas radio foot tous les jours et
ce genre de droit la can
si vous n'avez pas la cas dans l'afrique
c'est pas la peine d'essayer d'exister
par exemple donc c'est vrai que c'est un
enjeu qui est pas du tout second
monsieur le sénateur bargeton a parlé
des plateformes je voulais juste dire
parce que souvent quand on dit
transformation numérique conti plate
forme et c'est je reviens là dessus
parce que c'est vrai plateforme salto
d'autres plateformes la plateforme de
radio france la patronne de tv5 monde
mais je redis que pour moi la
transformation numérique c'est la lutte
contre les manipulations de
l'information le complotisme la perte de
confiance dans les médias traditionnels
et que c'est vrai à l'échelle de la
planète et c'est vrai dans toutes les
langues
il ya des langues particulièrement
offensive contre notre pays contre ses
valeurs contre sa démocratie et donc je
pense que la transformation numérique
c'est aussi notre capacité collective à
pas nous laisser faire et pas laisser
manipuler les jeunes non plus pas jeu
juste quand on dit transformation
numérique ne pensons pas que plateforme
et puisqu'on a été invité à arriver par
madame la sénatrice du coup tout de
suite évidemment que pas de bijoux pas
de choses comme ça mais alors en
revanche moi je rêverais de langue
étrangère nouvelles et par exemple dans
la vraie du tueur croyez vous j'aurai
beaucoup que mes répondre en turc à
monsieur erdogan a il n'y a pas très
longtemps
j'aurais beaucoup aimé m'adresser à la
communauté turque très nombreuses qui
est en france et qui communiquent en
turc sans qu'aucun service public ne
sache exactement puisque alors on
communique dans dix villes entre dans
mon groupe mais pentue et il avait une
réaction turque figurez-vous en 2010 à
vérifier pas de chance elle a été fermée
dans un plan de départ donc je me
permets de dire que moi je trouverais ça
très bien qu'on parle tu as et aux
frontières de l'europe il ya plein de
niveaux toujours mieux blabla que pan
pan disait churchill
donc je trouve qu'il faudrait faire
beaucoup de bien
la banque turque et dans les langues
africaines dont convient d'en lancer au
visage
donc je vous disais c'est d'ailleurs
vous êtes si vous voulez vous branchez
ont fait la conférence paris dakar un
vrai paris-dakar en virtuel jeudi est
donc le foulfouldé donc la langue peule
pascal à l'épaule pas de fouday c'est la
langue la plus anti françaises de la
bande sahélienne et c'est alors qu'il ya
des talons extraordinaire il ya des
jeunes extraordinaire des femmes
extraordinaires dans cette es donc on va
parler avec eux mais il faudrait parler
aussi des longues touareg il faudrait
probablement parlé le lingala kehl qui
est la langue de la rdc 85 millions
d'habitants pays le principal pays
francophones d'afrique
donc en fait moi mon rêve ce serait de
d'avoir la tour de babel a encore plus à
issy les moulineaux
si c'était ou ailleurs d'ailleurs en
proximité voilà c'était ça mon cadeau de
ce que je demanderai pour la promo
patino mais si vous le permettez je vais
vous prendre la parole sans être très
très original d'ailleurs fort forcément
pour peut-être sur sur deux points pour
compléter ce qui était dit tout en juste
notant que sur la capacité de faire des
choses ensemble
moi je pense qu'en ce moment on est
effectivement sur une dynamique où on
construit beaucoup de choses ensemble
sybille veille les n'est plus là pour
pour qu'on puisse évoquer l'offre qu'on
a fait avec france musique avec delphine
ernotte et france télévisions ont fait
pas mal de choses aussi et je voulais
juste souligner qu'avec marie christine
saragosse et france médias m'ont
beaucoup de nos reportages dans les
zones les plus compliqués
la planète sont faits ensemble en fait
entre art et j'ai eu lieu la rédaction
d' art et j'ai eu lieu et france médias
monde et que c'est quelque chose je
pense qu'ils assurent aussi cette
couverture mondiale et internationales
de l'information et non juste sur deux
points le premier puisque puisqu'on nous
a proposé de rêver et d'avoir et d'avoir
les cadeaux de début d'année il sera pas
dit que je n'aurais pas évoqué cette
possibilité là et je pense qu'ils nous
concerne nous je vais juste mettre
l'accent sur deux choses en fait
quand je parle du développement européen
quand je rêve du développement européen
d'arte et je me dis que de temps en
temps j'ai l'impression que notre
actionnaire peut être où nos partenaires
ne se rendent pas compte qu'il suffit de
peu pour avoir potentiellement beaucoup
c'est à dire que effectivement on
pourrait venir devant vous et dire pour
avoir un développement européen
important il me faut 500 millions sur
deux ans et je connais déjà le résultat
de 2,2 telle demande
non je vais faire des demandes plus
modestes mais plus modeste et en même
temps plus compliqué parce
qu'aujourd'hui si je pense qu'on a en ce
qui concerne la chaîne arte de murs ou
plutôt deux obstacles majeurs à franchir
sur le développement européen ce sont
des obstacles accessible mais pas
toujours compris le premier il est
linguistique marie-christine en a parlé
aujourd'hui je vous ai mentionné le fait
d'avoir des droits europe sur un très
très grand nombre de programmes
pratiquement toute notre offre
culturelle musicale possède aujourd'hui
des droits europe
notre offre culturelle des droits europe
ne le droit nono pardon nos
documentaires des droits europe vous
avez bien alors pourquoi bas parce
qu'après il faut sous-titré voire doublé
or sachez le camp même quand on double
on est vu par trois fois plus de monde
que canton sous titre c'est la
statistique dans l'ensemble des pays
d'europe donc le sous titre moi je moi
j'adore les sous titres mais en réalité
pour le rendre disponible pour rendre
disponible un programme dans d'autres
pays
faut il faut le double et ce à un coût
c'est pas identique à un coût de
production évidemment mais c'est un réel
coup et qu'effectivement quand on est
dans un contexte de restrictions
budgétaires ce coup là devient très
important or pardonnez moi de le dire
comme ça c'est un investissement
somme toute modique pour un
élargissement territorial grand et je
pense que donc la rentabilité d'un tel
investissement est extrêmement forte par
bon de parler comme ça la deuxième chose
et je pense que là aussi il faut je me
permets de parler pour arte mais mais ça
m'étonnerait que que mes collègues et
amis est un autre discours
souvent il ya beaucoup de élèves répond
notamment à catherine morin desailly
souvent il ya beaucoup de réflexions de
la part de deux de nos partenaires ou de
la tutelle sur mécanisme une seule plate
forme de plateformes trois plateformes
quatre plateformes en fait ma conviction
c'est que c'est pas si important il faut
que j'en ai beaucoup
mais ce qui est très important très
important c'est la compétence
technologique derrière on peut faire la
plus grosse plateforme française
possible si elle est pas
technologiquement à jour ça ne servira à
rien mais fait 15 plateforme n'ont pas
concurrente parce que la magie de cet
univers numérique c'est quoi ils
pourront peut être dans plusieurs
endroits en même temps c'est pas
compliqué ça ne nous a posé aucun
problème de rejoindre la plateforme de
radio france pour les podcasts parce que
ça nous a pas priver de quelque chose ça
nous a donné quelque chose de plus et
donc pouvoir travailler ensemble et ce
cross poster se lancer ensemble se
permettent la circulation entre ces
plusieurs endroits et quelque chose de
tout à fait possible et personnellement
moi j'ai tendance toujours à penser
qu'on nous met devant 1 devant un
arbitrage qui n'existe pas une seule ou
plusieurs ben non on peut faire
plusieurs et plusieurs qui marche très
bien et qui s'entraident
en revanche plusieurs qui parlent entre
elles plusieurs qui j'allais dire qu'ils
font comme unis
et qui font circuler le public entre
elles et qui est je crois que c'est
delphine tout à l'heure qui a parlé de
deux cultures prime culture prime ça
marche très bien parce qu'en plus on
grosse poste c'est à dire qu on se
pousse les uns les autres dans les dents
les audiences les uns les autres et
c'est pour ça que ça fonctionne mais en
revanche il faut de la compétence
technologique et la compétence
technologique ça coûte cher
et aujourd'hui je je je je crois que si
on ne veut pas désarmer le service
public
il faut lui permettre d'avoir les moyens
d'acquérir cette compétence
technologique
ça coûte cher non seulement en
investissements technologiques mais
aussi en ressources humaines dans des
marchés extrêmement compétitif et ça je
crois si je pouvais rajouter ce cadeau
là c'est qu'on nous permette
effectivement ensemble de développer
cette compétence technologique propre
merci oui bah en fait je vais sans doute
me dis que je ne leur ai dit qu'il est
effectivement pour ce qui est de des
plateformes d'abord pour mina vous vous
savez c'est pas un sujet de plateformes
versus antenne puisque nous sommes que
plateforme est à la fois plus simple et
très compliqué mais il ya clairement un
enjeu sur notre notre plateforme
gratuite n'a point fr voilà devant
richir et et d'en faire un axe est de
profiter de la puissance din a.fr qui
est passé en cinq ans de de moins de 80
millions à près d'un milliard de vidéos
vues pour en faire un accès à l'ensemble
des offres et des services a uniquement
que de contenus audiovisuels
mais pourquoi pas aussi de formation de
produits de notre recherche d'études et
c'est bon c'est par là c'est ce que
ina.fr devienne un espèce de pub
accès gratuit très large à toutes les
propositions services commerciaux pas
commerciaux devinable par ailleurs il ya
évidemment au bide et de contribuer de
participer chaque fois que c'est
possible aux autres aux offres communes
comme sur france-info com sur le crime
comme sur lui me delphine a dit céline
hacker qui a copiloté notamment en
travaillant sur la partie 10
professionnel réservé aux enseignants
avec des parcours pédagogiques et
interactives is able en sac de classe en
dehors en mettant tout ce qui est le
sonore et les podcasts sur sur la
plateforme d'applications de nos amis de
radio france et puis aussi en
développant des offres de niche propre à
guînes à éditorialisé comme comme
madeleine avec une offre payante qui
répond aussi à notre statut
d'établissement public et au fait que
comme je vous disais tout à l'heure il
faut bien qu'on voit bien qu'on gagne de
quoi ce que veulent couvrir 20 de quoi
boucler notre budget au delà des 70 %
qui sont assurées pas de la cap mais que
au fond je crois que c'est pas tant le
nombre des plateformes et l'idée d'une
plateforme unique type de temps tout est
à cause peut pas être stockée un autre
projet et on est un projet de hauts
lieux publics est un très beau projet
mais d'exposition de la création
française
je crois que derrière c'est plus des
coopérations autour effectivement de
tout ce qui est la façon dont on se
d'abord des contenus présents à
plusieurs endroits bruno patino elle dit
ces plates formes différentes de
l'audiovisuel public qui ont des
objectifs différents perceuse
effectivement se renvoyer les unes vers
les autres
intégrée pour partie des contenus les
unes des autres et puis surtout il ya un
travail technique et y compris sur sur
la data qui peut être fait de façon très
utile voilà en bhagwan bénéfice de
l'ensemble de ses plateformes entre et
celles qui sont opérés au sein de
l'audiovisuel public et ça je crois que
il ya des expériences dans toutes les
entreprises et alina par définition
puisque on gère 80 pétaoctets de données
et de métadonnées haut on est là aussi
dans un champ de coopération tout à fait
intéressant à développer dans les années
qui viennent libérer jeu contient une
dernière question de claude kern
oui très rapidement donc c'est une
question qui s'adresse plus directement
à madame r note une question et il peut
être aussi un peu puisque c'est la
période des ddv veux je vais commencer
par le veut puisque david un solide m'a
pris ma question sur le sport moi c'est
la culture géant grand regret j'aimerais
bien revoir un jour au théâtre ce soir
2,99 par mois vous aurez tout sur
madeleine mais je parlais de regin a à
sortir de l'ornière de yako vide
je parle de france si vous appréciez
naturellement une carte d'abonnement qui
rendra cette offre gratuite les six
premiers mois
merci gratuit tous les vendredis soirs
sur l'a5 d'accord il très bien voilà
donc mon voeu est déjà exaucé merci par
contre moi je voudrais rebondir sur des
questions qui ont été abordées et je
trouve que la réponse n'a pas été
apportée
ça concerne
de ce qu'on retrouve dans le projet de
qom c'est-à-dire l'accélération de la
régionalisation de france 3 pour en
faire 13 chaînes locales
alors est-ce que france 3 est prête à
cela sur le terrain et surtout quel est
le devenir des anciennes chaînes je
parlais de france 3 paris ile de france
france 3 pays basque france 3 alsace
pour ne citer que celles-là des chaînes
auxquelles nos télés ce pacte
spectateurs sont très attachés alors
c'est vrai que vous avez raison j'ai pas
répondu à cette question est pourtant
c'est un des sujets peut-être les plus
importantes du du plan de travail de
france télévisions qui est cette
inversion du modèle de france 3 ça
repose beaucoup sur les attentes de nos
téléspectateurs qui se renforce
d'ailleurs de consultation citoyenne en
consultation citoyenne on voit que plus
le monde se complexifie plus ils ont
besoin d'avoir une vision du monde qui
va du très très haut très loin donc il
s'agit pas de transformer france 3 en
chaîne qui ne parlent que du local bien
entendu un mais en des chaînes qui parle
et du local et 2 et 2 et d'humour et de
la france et du monde en fait donc donc
avec cette perspective de champ parce
que les gens aussi disent au fond deux
choses d'abord une europe qui ne se voit
pas représentés suffisamment à la
télévision et donc parler des zones
rurales des agriculteurs des petites
villes des périphéries convoi - la
télévision c'est important parce qu'ils
ont besoin qu'on parle de leur
territoire de leurs difficultés et aussi
ils ont besoin qu'on parle de dé de
toute l'énergie qui assure les
différents territoires dire des
initiatives
d'ailleurs vous avez remarqué que sur le
nouveau trésor de la ii il ya une
nouvelle rubrique qui s'appelle
évidemment j'ai un trou de mémoire sur
le nom de la rubrique mais qui génére
l'ag une idée pour la france et qui
montrent en fait une initiative locale
absolument génial qu'on transpose pas
forcément de reproduire à l'échelle
internationale mais qui montre la
vitalité une idée géniale ici ou là bon
c'est ce que françois aussi la chercher
à faire a montré à la fois les
difficultés et aussi les initiatives
d'individus de collectivités
d'associations qui sont quand même
incroyable et exemplaire voilà alors
pour faire ça on n'a pas de moyens
supplémentaires on a même des moyens en
baisse je voulais dit on à une baisse
des effectifs qui est quand même très un
très conséquente mais à l'intérieur de
cette baisse des effectifs on va pas du
tout l'élu de la même manière sur france
3 et sur le reste du groupe
même si france 3 les autres maires c'est
plus de la moitié des effectifs du
groupe
quand même donc
voilà on a des moyens plus modernes de
fabriquer de la télévision aujourd'hui
on en a l'expérience france 3 corse
fabrique une chaîne via stèle avec les
moyens de france 3 corse et plus
récemment on a fabriqué à la demande et
sous l'impulsion du conseil régional une
chaîne de plein exercice s'appelle noah
en nouvelles aquitaine
donc si on a déjà des savoir faire à
l'intérieur de notre maison dé manière
de faire qui nous permettent de
construire ce qu'on a chez encore ce
qu'on a fait un noir ailleurs sur le
territoire
on a fait une approche dogmatique parce
que si on fait des chaînes régionales et
je reviendrai après sur la granularité 1
si on fait des chaînes régionales c'est
parce qu'on peut penser que la région
hôte france va pas avoir tout à fait la
même vision des choses que la région
paca et c'est pas gênant est d'ailleurs
tant mieux après tout la question et
c'est ce qu'on est en train de caler
sait quelle est la bonne graine une
arrêtez vous parliez des ce qu'on
appelle les antennes locales qui ont
évidemment toute leur place sur une
chaîne régionale et notre notre plan de
marche qui comprend notamment les
matinales que nous faisons avec radio
france
sow sur des échelles qui sont pas celles
de la région administrative donc ce
qu'on imagine nous c'est treize chaînes
régionales mais qui peuvent par moments
de la journée
déjà en commençant le matin est beaucoup
plus fils parce qu'il n'ya pas 13
matinale à terme france bleu il y en a
donc on imagine qu'on peut être à 44 sur
les matinales sur les éditions
d'information on n'est déjà pas très
sonné à 24 donc continuer à être à 24 en
édition d'information est en fait en
fonction des sujets trouver des
granularité puisqu'ils vont du plus
proche ou au plus loin et puis investir
d'autres champs on parlait tout à
l'heure du soir des grandes compétitions
qui ont des droits exorbitants
il ya aussi beaucoup de compétitions qui
sont libres de droit ont fait
l'expérience sur nos à des compétitions
locales et qui mériterait d'être captés
et de transmises en direct sur
précisément ces chaînes région
il ya énormément de vivacité culturelle
dans les territoires les festivals les
représentations qui mériterait aussi
d'être repris sur sur seychelles donc
entre l'information qui est quand même
le coeur de la tente des téléspectateurs
au sens large
l'actualité et puis l'actualité sportive
l'actualité culturelle on voit que là on
a quand même un terreau extrêmement
riche et qu'on égorge je pense qu'on est
capable de
de porter auprès auprès de nos publics
pardonnez moi et je vais pas retenir
plus longtemps mais je me rends compte
que j'ai oublié une question de
catherine qui était pas totalement
inutile parce que justement non très
important de catherine lebrun dessailly
ça parlait d'europe ça parlait de
jeunesse parce qu'il me semble qu'on
vient de parler de proximité mais c'est
vrai aussi que notre jeunesse européenne
celle du co vis du chômage des attentats
et elle est d'ailleurs en bon en
souffrance un peu partout elle doit
faire l'objet de toutes nos attentions
alors arte travail bien sûr sur ces
questions mais nous on vient de
remporter un appel d'offres avec la
deutsch vélo dans le cadre du traité
d'aix la chapelle pour construire une
offre pour les jeunes européens une
offre multilingue le projet pilote est
décliné en six langues et qui va
permettre aux jeunes de produire
d'échanger dans différentes langues sur
des thématiques les intéressent que ça
ait du changement climatique au travail
à la vie amoureuse aux études etc
et c'est une façon comme toujours dans
tout ce qu'on lance de lutter contre les
manipulations et les uns fox à peu près
tout ce qu'on fait finalement en faisant
de la bonne info de confiance et
certifier c'est le premier rempart aux
manipulations donc je voulais juste dire
que on en avait parlé avec peter
lindbergh en étant dit sonné par la
commission culturelle et donc on a
remporté l'appel d'offres en novembre et
le projet pilote sera lancé en mars au
moment du sommet franco allemand
voilà si important pour toute dernière
question de max brisson
merci président et ce sera court le
message est lancé
en langage corporel par le président
sera court et c'est pas une question est
plutôt un message en complément de ce
que vient de dire quelle côte kane et
pour rebondir sur vos propos madame
ernotte
le
je partage totalement ce que vous avez
dit sur la proche des télévisions
locales régionales
j'approuve totalement tant qu'élu nero
khiter c'est la tonne une nouvelle qui
tu es ce que vous avez dit sur la
qualité du travail fait par noah mais
dans ces grandes régions et la nouvelle
aquitaine en particulier à la taille de
l'autriche nécessite encore plus
granularité dont vous avez parlé aussi
une approche en local excusez moi le
pays basque ce n'est pas la creuse et
c'est la même région
d'où la nécessité absolue de cette
édition locale surtout le sort des
territoires à forte identité et surtout
sur des territoires qui parieurs peuvent
avoir des langues qu'à paris on appelle
régional et doullens d'où la nécessité
absolue d'avoir cette bonne échelle ce
bouclage en termes d'échelle que les
forfaits en régionale que je peux
comprendre même si j'y anime en ce doute
sur ces régions décider sur un coin de
table une nuit à l'elysée et dont je ne
suis pas sûr qu'elles passeront le
siècle nice et l'as la maille que vous
avez décidé de prendre ça n'enlève pas
de la pertinence à la maille locale qui
est elle est inscrite en une histoire
qui passera certainement le siècle alors
je vous remercie de cette intervention
et moi puisque les voeux sont encore
ouverts vous pouvez vraiment nous aider
sur ce sujet parce qu'aujourd'hui
sachez que la télévision elle est reçue
par les français principalement via les
box des opérateurs et il n'y a aucune
obligation aujourd'hui pour les
opérateurs à transmettre les chaînes
régionales au maillage que vous indiquez
donc il ya beaucoup de local aujourd'hui
que nous produisons qui ne sont pas vu
par les téléspectateurs
donc dans le projet de loi audiovisuel
d'ailleurs on avait beaucoup insisté
pour qu'apparaissent cette obligation
faite aux opérateurs de transmettre la
bonne my parce que on pourra faire
toutes les télés du monde à la tâte là
toutes les échelles si c'est pas
transmis voilà ça n'existera pas ça
n'arrivera pas aux téléspectateurs donc
on a un vrai sujet de
voilà d'arriver jusqu'aux
téléspectateurs via les box et ça là
dessus c'est de l'ordre du législatif
nous on peut pas contraindre on discute
on discute mais bon on est en position
de faiblesse
on peut pas les contraindre à le faire
certains opérateurs le font mais pas
tous ça si vous pouviez nous aider là
dessus je pense que ça nous aiderait
vraiment adapté cette maille pertinentes
comme vous le voulez indiqué bon chat
moitié basque alors évidemment je
compense que vous voulez dire pour pour
avoir même si on a une organisation par
13 des moments où on va être différent
au pays basque ou dans les landes
par exemple bien écoutez nous sommes
arrivés au terme de cet échange
évidemment nous vous remercions les uns
et les autres je crois que vos regards
croisés qui sont on l'a bien vu sur
claude a pas danger par des géantistes
rapidement alors avant caen oui c'est
bien de moi qu'il s'agit oui oui a dit
oui oui oui bonjour à tous j'ai très
vite monsieur le président je n'oublie
pas le fait un début à tout achat que
par 9 degrés au pays
je suppose que ça doit vous faire sourit
je voudrais m'adresser très rapidement
madame ernotte et lui dire que que si je
ne suis pas un sujet que je me rappelle
tout le débat autour de la ferme tune
france ô
avec l'objectif de rendre plus visible
le monde ultra marins d'un ensemble sur
l'ensemble de l'audiovisuel national
alors si on ne peut pas aujourd'hui
faire un bilan parce qu'il est trop tôt
mais pouvez-vous nous faire très
rapidement 1.1 point le point d'étape
où en est-on exactement sur cette
volonté de rendre plus visible ce ce
monde ultra marins
merci de votre question monsieur le
sénateur c'est un sujet qui est très
important pour nous qui est donc on a en
plus dû comme un pack de visibilité des
outre mer qui est une sorte de com en
soi puisqu'il comporte une quinzaine
d'objectifs et nous suivons l'avancement
de ses objectifs au travers d'un comité
de suivi composé de représentants du
ministère de la culture de la dg milk de
deux sénateurs deux
deux députés et nous faisons donc en
fait un point sur ce suivi à peu près
tous les tous les trois mois au 3 ou 4
mois environ
donc le dernier je crois doit dater de
septembre donc je pense qu'on aura un
point de sur ce pacte de suivi très
précis donc on compte par exemple le
nombre de sujet dans les éditions
d'information qui ont traité de sujets
ultramarins
on compte le nombre de premières parties
de soirées qui ont traité d'un sujet que
ce soit une fiction un documentaire un
magazine ultra marins etc etc
sur tous ces indicateurs on est bien
aujourd'hui ça veut pas dire qu'on n'a
pas encore des progrès à faire on a
encore des progrès à faire mais disons
qu'on est sur la pente d'amélioration
très net et donc on continue à
travailler dans ce dans ce domaine
certains noms du comité de suivi
mais ça je voudrais pas parler à leur
place nous ont dit la dernière fois que
ça commençait à se voir dire y voyait en
regardant nos éditions d'information en
regardant nos antennes que oui on
on prenait le soin de traiter les sujets
ultramarins à la bonne vitesse ce qui
n'était pas le cas auparavant
je me souviens des de mayotte n'y a pas
si longtemps il y avait des tremblements
de terre on a mis quinze jours avant
d'aborder ce sujet alors que c'était
majeur pour les mahorais vous voyez donc
dans ce réflexe là de mettre au même
niveau tout ce qui se passe
que ce soit dans les départements les
territoires les régions où paris ça ça
commence à ça commence à s'acquérir et
les premières parties de soirées aussi
on a on tourne beaucoup de fictions sur
place
on a renouvelé nos engagement d'investir
dans des productions qui sont ultra
marines donc basées outre mer
et puis nos chaînes ultramarines les
premières sont toujours aussi puissante
et nous avons déployé
c'est un engagement du pack le la
plateforme outre-mer la première c'était
en juin à la sortie du premier
confinement qui fait déjà une bien
meilleure audience que les offres
numériques antérieures donc voilà on est
on est lancés dans ce pack de visibilité
et évidemment on pourra vous faire un
point mais on le fait ça chez en comité
de suivi tous les tous les trimestres
3 février le prochain elle 3 février
merci on va s'arrêter là donc en vous
remerciant les uns et les autres de la
clarté de vos réponses et ses regards
croisés que vous portez sur les sujets
qui sont les vôtres vous avez compris
mais vous le savez que notre commission
est très attentive
évidemment depuis de nombreuses années
et continuera de l'être aux questions de
le diriger le public ne nous
prononcerons dans quelques jours sur sur
les com et au delà bien sûr que c'est
ces contrats notre suivi et notre
volonté de vous accompagner et sur ces
sujets là est bien sûr très très forte
vous avez même vu que ici vous pouviez
rêver ce qui n'était pas forcément ce à
quoi vous vous attendiez en arrivant
c'est peut-être d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on
n'a pas invité l'état parce que au moins
vous pouviez rêver plus librement donc
merci à chacun d'entre vous et bonne
soirée
[Musique]